ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER
**** BATH BONTA BROUGH BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP. EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE. HIGHLY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAMOS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH. STONE NG VOEPEL WALDRON
WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK THAT OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND PATTY OSHA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. A BRIEF BRIEF
REFLECTION ON LIFE IT IS LIVE
WE MIGHT ASK WHAT IS THE
MEANING PURPOSE OF MY LIFE. WHO
AM I. THESE ARE QUESTIONS WE
ALL QUIETLY ASKED WHEN WE
ENCOUNTER CHANGES IN OUR LIVES
IS ONLY NATURAL. ULTIMATELY
LIFE IS NOT SOMETHING FOR US TO
JUST UNDERSTAND LIVING LIFE IS
SO MUCH MORE. THE DANISH
PHILOSOPHER IN THE OCEAN SOREN
KIERKEGAARD HAD A LIBERATING
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION WHAT
IS LIFE. IT IS THIS. LIFE IS A
MYSTERY TO BE LIVED NOT A
PROBLEM TO BE SOLVED. AT ANY
AGE EVERY DAY CAN BE A NEW
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE THE
WONDERFUL MYSTERY OF LIFE. NOW
MORE MENDOZA WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MYSTERY BUS READY SALUTE
.
YEAH. THANK YOU YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON A
WILLIAM P. BRO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEVENTY THIRD DISTRICT
PRESIDING CHIEF QUICKIE DOCTOR
WILSON AT THE DESK READING FOR
CAPPING A MYSTERY CALDERON
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
HABITATIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. S. AGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES THERE ARE NO ABSENCES
TODAY
. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
RESEARCH SHE IN KILEY TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
NUMBER THREE FORTY ONE SB
SEVENTY ONE LEYVA FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. PLEASE MOVE THE
FALLING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY NINE SB TWO
TWENTY HILL AND ITEM TOOL FOR
SB FIFTY ONE HERTZBERG. THE
CLERK WILL AGAIN NO. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT REAL SIXTY TWO A THE FALL
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO HOLD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH.
UPON A GERMAN OF SESSION IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OF TWO. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY FOUR D. ON THE
FOLLOWING RESOLUTIONS TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THESE
MEASURES. AFTER THE RESOLUTIONS
DEADLINE. THOSE ARE AJ AJ ARE
SEVENTEEN RAMOS H. R. SIXTY
FOUR SMITH AND H. R. SIXTY ONE
MELENDEZ. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING A
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. IS AB NINE FIFTY
SEVEN. THIS IS KEN CURRENTS
CORPORATION. AS SOMEONE BILL
NINE FIFTY SEVEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING TO CLAIM
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MISTER
DAVID CHIU YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
AB NINE FIFTY SEVEN IS THIS
YEAR'S HOUSING OMNIBUS BILL IT
MAKES TECHNICAL NON SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES TO STATUTE LIKE ALL OF
THE MOST BILLS ALL PROPOSALS
WERE BETTER STAKEHOLDERS
CONFIRM THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CHIU SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE. GLOBAL ROLE ALL
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THOSE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON
THE URGENCY. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ALL TIRED BUT I FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO ON THE URGENCY ICE
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE SENATE AMENDMENTS. OUR
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE A. B. FIVE NINETY MISTER
MATHIS CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE NINETY BY SELLING.
OVER MATHIS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO MELT MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE MR
MATHIS YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIVE
NINETY MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
THE CURRENT STATE LAW TO COMPLY
WITH CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL MILK
MARKETING ORDER. IT'S BACK OVER
HERE ON CONCURRENT ASK YOU FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
MATHIS SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ADAM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
. WHAT
A PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB NINE EIGHTY TWO
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AND ACTUALLY TO
PEOPLE'S. MR HOLDEN YOU MAIL
BUT I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M HERE TO PRESENT A. B. NINE
EIGHTY TWO WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK LIBERAL. SARAH VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU
THAT I AS FIFTY ONE KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS. OUR
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB FOURTEEN NINETY
SEVEN COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER HOLDEN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO BUSINESS MR HOLDING
YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY ARE RISE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN WHICH IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AB FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WILL INCLUDE A
PROPERTY LISTED ON AN ONLINE
HOSTING PLATFORM IN THE
DEFINITION OF A HOUSING
ACCOMMODATION. IN DOING SO AB
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN WILL
CODIFY THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING CURRENT.
PRACTICE INVESTIGATING
COMPLAINTS OF DISCRIMINATION IN
PROVIDING RETRIBUTION FOR
VICTIMS. THE MINUTES IN THE
SENATE WERE TO ADDRESS CHAPTER
IN OUT ISSUES. THIS BILL HAS NO
ZERO NO VOTES AND ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR OVER.
THERE WAS HOLDEN SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OF DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT
IS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL. ZERO
TIE THAT ICE FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
IS AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND ACTUALLY THE
TRIBAL GAMING DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY MR GARCIA YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WOULD
RATIFY THE TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT ENTERED INTO BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CABAZON BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
CALIFORNIA EXECUTED ON AUGUST
TWENTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. CABAZON BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS IS A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES LOOKING
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND HAS CALLED
THE COACHELLA VALLEY HOME FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS BIT OF UP
KIND OF HISTORY THE CABAZON
ALSO IS THE TRIBE ALONG WITH
THE WRONG WILL BAN MISSION
INDIANS. TO LEAD THE CHARGE ALL
THE WAY TO THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN TO GIVE TRIBES A RIGHT TO
ESTABLISH OPERATION OF GAMING
FACILITIES ON RESERVATION LANDS
THIS COMPACT AUTHORIZES THE
DRIVE TO OPERATE A MAXIMUM OF
ONE ON ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED SLOT MACHINES UNTIL
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE RESPECTFULLY A
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR GARCIA SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK.
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WHAT PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM NINE
PASS AND RETAIN. ON FILE ITEMS
TEN AND ELEVEN. THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. AB
TWO OH NINE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER LIMóN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO PARKS MS AMONG
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWO OH NINE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE OUTDOOR
ACTIVITY GRANT PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. TO INCREASE THE
ABILITY OF UNDERSERVED IN AT
RISK POPULATIONS TO PARTICIPATE
IN OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS EIGHTY TWO
OH NINE HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
BAD PASSED OUT OF BOTH HOUSES.
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS AMOUNT SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
BUT I FIFTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN. IS A. B. THREE
ONE SEVEN. CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTEEN
BY FAMILY MEMBER DEEP IN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO BE A GOALS. MR
DEEP YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THREE
SEVENTEENTH BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH SENATE AMENDMENTS I ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU BUT I SIXTY
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN. AB THREE THREE EIGHT
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SELLING MEMBER
KANSEN CHU AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE MANUFACTURED
HOUSING MISTER KANSEN CHU YOU
MAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB THREE THREATS THREE THREE
EIGHT IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE THE MEMON NARROWS TO
MATERIAL REQUIRED TO BE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS MATERIAL
RATHER DANDA PARKS SPECIFIC
DOCUMENTS SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING THE COST TO THE STATE.
OTHER AMENDMENT OF OUR
TECHNICAL IN NATURE THIS BILL
WILL. SAVE LIVES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER SHOW
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CORP LIBERAL. SACRAMENTO
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSER ALL TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY NINE KNOWS TEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MEMBERS WERE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN. THAT BRINGS US FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB FOUR TWENTY
SIX CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER A BEFORE
TWENTY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. IN MINUTES TAKEN
THE SENATE BRING THE FORM WHICH
WOULD HAVE BEEN REPEALED BACK
INTO CIRCULATION AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU RESERVATIONS
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK
LIBERAL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF. YOU DESERVE
A. WORK WELL CLOSE ROLE. CALVET
EYES FIFTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PASS RETAIN A FILE AND EIGHTEEN
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NINETEEN THAT'S- JUST TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB FIVE
TWENTY BY MISTER KALRA CLERK
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC WORKS.
MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS PRADA PERCENT
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY BACK FROM
THE SENATE WHICH DEFINES WHEN A
PUBLIC SUBSIDIES TO MINIMUS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF DETERMINING IF
THE PREVAILING WAGE APPLIES TO
PRIVATE PROJECTS USING PUBLIC
FUNDS. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
TERM DE MINIMUS IS NOT DEFINED
IN THE STATUTE SO THERE'S NO
GUIDANCE AS TO THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL PUBLIC SUBSIDY THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED DE MINIMUS
AND THIS IS LEAD TO LITIGATION.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE PUBLIC
SUBS SUBSIDY ON A PRIVATE
PROJECT IS TO MINIMUS SO LONG
AS IT IS LESS THAN HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS AND LESS THAN
2% OF THE TOTAL PROJECT COST.
RECENT AMENDMENTS EXEMPT
CONSTRUCTION OF SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES ON THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD UNDER
CURRENT LAW AND MAINTAIN UNDER
THIS BILL NO DEVELOPER IS
REQUIRED TO TAKE A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY OVER THE DIMINISH
DIMINISH AMOUNT. IF THEY DO NOT
WANT TO PAY THE. PREVAILING
WAGE WHAT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THERE WAS
KALRA SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CORPS CORPORAL. MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF.
IT IS OUT OF. CLICK WELL. CLOSE
ROLE. TELL YOU ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS ELEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. I'M
GONNA LET WOULD KNOW ON ONE ON
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY THREE NINETY SIX TO
WITHDRAW SB SEVEN FOURTEEN PAN
FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
TO TAKE UP THE BILL FOR THIRD
READING TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE. MR FLORA FOR PURPOSE
SIR WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT AS FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
IN THIS CASE ON THE RESERVATION
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS. MEMBERS THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MR FLORA IS ASKING
FOR NO. MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND MR
FLORA NO ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION
. CLICK WELL. CLOSER
ALL TELL VOTE HI THIS FIFTY.
KNOWS FIFTEEN. THE MOTION
CARRIES. MEMBERS THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. SB
SEVEN ONE FOUR CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR PAN AND EXPLAIN TO
PUBLIC HEALTH DOCTOR WOULD YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE 2%
SB SEVEN FOURTEEN. SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN A MEN'S SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX PREVIOUSLY PASSED BY OUR
HOUSE THE AMENDMENTS REQUESTED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND AGREED TO
BY THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS THE
AUTHOR AND I APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN OUR HOUSES
AND THE GOVERNOR THAT HAS
RESULTED IN THIS BILL SO WE CAN
KEEP CHILDREN SAFE FROM
PREVENTABLE DISEASES. SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN MAKES THE FOLLOWING
CHANGES TO SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
FOR STUDENTS WITH MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THIS BILL NO
LONGER REQUIRES THESE
EXEMPTIONS TO BE SUBMITTED TO
THE STATE BUT STUDENTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
IMMUNIZATIONS AT THE NEXT
REQUIRED GRADE SPAN UNLESS A
NEW EXEMPTION THAT COMPLIES
WITH SB TWO SEVENTY SIX. IS
OBTAINED. REVIEW OF EXEMPTIONS
ISSUED BY PHYSICIANS WHO HAVE
ISSUED MORE THAN FIVE ANNIE
YEAR WILL START JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY. IT PROHIBITS DPH
FROM ACCEPTING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS ISSUED BY PHYSICIANS
WHO ARE ON PROBATION FROM
IMMUNIZATION STANDARDS OF CARE.
IT REMOVES THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THIS POSITION CERTIFY UNDER
PART AND PENALTY A PURCHASE SEE
A PERJURY WHEN PROVIDING
INFORMATION IN THE FORM. BILL
STILL PROVIDES A SWORN
DECLARATION FROM THE DOCTOR
THAT THE INFORMATION THE FORM
IS TRUE AND CORRECT. IT
REQUIRES THE APPEALS PROCESS TO
CONSIDER INFORMATION SUBMITTED
BY THE CHILD'S FAMILY AND
ISSUING POSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOOD MISTER MATHIS YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. ONCE AGAIN
COLLEAGUES. WITH SUCH A
CONTROVERSIAL BILL WERE WHARF
IN THIS TO THE FLOOR IN THE
DEAD OF NIGHT. NOT EVEN GIVEN
THE PEOPLE A CHANCE TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND. OR HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD IN A COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS THIS GOES PAST VACCINES
AND IS AGAIN A MAJOR GOVERNMENT
OVER REACH. MEMBERS JUST THIS
MORNING. I WITNESSED THREE
MOTHERS BEING ARRESTED AND
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN
IN FRONT OF OUR CAPITAL. ALL
BECAUSE THEY ONE OF THEIR
VOICES HEARD. PERHAPS IF THIS
WILL HAPPEN AT THE BORDER. THEY
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN ATTENTION FOR
BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN. WE WERE TOLD SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX WAS A CRACKDOWN ON
BAD DOCTORS. NOW WE ARE
REMOVING CRIMINAL LIABILITY
FROM DOCTORS DOES THAT EVEN
SOUND RIGHT. I THINK WE ALL
NEED TO GO BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD. SHE DOWN AT THE TABLE.
AND TALK ABOUT SOLUTIONS. FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS.
MEMBERS ARE MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN ARE WATERED STEAK AT.
I ASK YOU FOR A NO VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE AND I'M DOCTOR
WOULD YOU MAY CLOSE. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE
. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLY THAT EYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE
.
THERE WILL BE ORDER IN THE
CHAMBER THERE WILL BE ORDER IN
THE CHAMBER. WE WOULD ASK OUR
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM ANY OUT FOR. YES
YES IN THE GALLERY TO REFRAIN
.
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS ON THE
CALL OF THE SPEAKER WE ARE
UNDER RECESS. UNDER THE CALL OF
THE SPEAKER
. MEMBERS WE ARE
BACK IN SESSION PLEASE RETURN
TO THE FLOOR AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. SO WE MAY PROCEED
WITH THE BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
WE ARE ON THE CONCURRENCE FILE
.
THERE IS WE'RE GOING TO. PASS A
RETAIN. ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY. ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY TO PASS A
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE. MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB. SEVEN
SEVEN THREE BY MS GONZALEZ THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO VOTER
EDUCATION THIS GONZALEZ YOU
MAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE ALL HELP EQUIP
YOUNG ADULTS BECOME ELECTORALLY
ENGAGE CITIZENS BY REQUIRING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT
VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAM
MEANING. THE MMS. TAKEN THE
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL NATURE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MS HAS ALL SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. IS THERE A VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT.
KNOWS EIGHT SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. WHERE PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE I'M TWENTY FIVE
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX IS AB A
THIRTY FOUR CORKERY AT SOME
LEVEL EIGHT THIRTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK ACTUALLY TO
WATER DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU SPEAKER AB EIGHT
THREE FOUR DIRECTS THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO ESTABLISH A
FRESH FRESH WATER. ESCHEWING
HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOM PROGRAM TO
COORDINATE ACTIONS NECESSARY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT FROM TOXICS
PRODUCED BY THESE BLOOMS A
MEMBERS WERE TAKEN IN THE
CENTER TO REDUCE COSTS BY
REMOVING PROVISIONS RELATED TO
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR THE SAFETY OF
FRESH WATER RECREATIONAL BODIES
RELATED TO HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOMS. THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN SANDMAN MATHS.
THANK YOU FOR SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLICK
LIBERAL. THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLE TIED UP I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. S. RETAIN A FILE
I'M TWENTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT. AB EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
WILL EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER IRWIN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION. IS WHEN
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE WHERE WE
ADDED CO AUTHORS THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED PROPERTY
TAX RELIEF TO VICTIMS OF
NATURAL. DISASTERS WHO BUILT
THEIR HOME IN THE SAME LOCATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR A. THANK
YOU MISTER ONE SENIOR
DISCUSSION TODAY CLUB LIBERAL.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRED ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS FLOW
OR DESIRE TO VOTE CLARK WELL.
ROLLTIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FOLLOWING TWENTY
NINE IS A. B. NINE ONE ONE.
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL NINE ONE
ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
AND ACTUALLY EMERGENCY SERVICES
THIS RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARISE PRISON
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE ELEVEN KNOWN
AS A MANY ALERT ACT WHICH IS
BACKROOM CONCURRENCE THIS
MEASURE DIRECTS COW YES TO
CONDUCT A VISIBILITY STUDY FOR
A SMART NINE ONE ONE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM WHICH WILL ENABLE
PERSONS TO VOLUNTARY CEMENT
BOTTLE HEALTH INFORMATION. TO
BE AVAILABLE FOR ALL FOR
SPONSORS A RESPECT OUT FOR I
WROTE. THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CORP WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP AB EIGHT SEVEN NINE.
CLICK RATE. AS LEGAL EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER
GIPSON AND EXPLAIN FIRE ARMS
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RISE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE WHICH SEEKS TO
CLOSE THE GHOST GUN LOOPHOLE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY MAKES
CLARIFYING CHANGES DELAYS THE
IMPLEMENTATION TO GIVE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TIME TO
THAT THEY NEED TO IMPLEMENT. OF
THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
RESPECTFUL ASPEN AYE VOTE. THEY
WAS GIVE SEND SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK LIBERAL.
OTHERS ARE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS ARTICLE. ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRABLE. CLICK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE FORTY SEVEN
THOSE FIFTEEN SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS BACK
IN FILE ORDER. FILE ITEM THIRTY.
IS AB EIGHT NINE SIXTY BY MR
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SIXTY BY SOME
REMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY THE CAL WORKS MR
MAIENSCHEIN AB NINE SIXTY IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND WILL
PROVIDE IMMEDIATELY RELIEF TO
OUR MOST FORMAL FAMILIES. THANK
YOU RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
EITHER. THING WAS MENTIONED.
SHE NOTICED KASHER BAKER
CALDERON. NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND.
EVERYONE IN THE BACK TO TAKE UP
AN ITEM FOR WHICH WE PASS
TEMPORARILY THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN. AB FOUR FIVE
SIX CROCKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY SIX BY SOMETHING MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AND ACTUALLY A
PUBLIC CONTRACTS MISTER CHAIR.
THANK MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
BACK IN CONCURRENCE AB FOR
FIFTY SIX ADDRESSES THE
INDEFINITE DELAY OF PAYMENT TO
CALIFORNIANS PUBLIC WERE
CONTRACTORS FOR EXTRA WORK
PERFORMED BY EXTENDING THE
SENSITIVE CURRENT LAW CLOSING
THE LOOPHOLE IN PROP PAYMENT
LOW WHEN IT COMES TO RESOLVING
DISPUTES. THIS BILL HAS HAD
ZERO NO VOTES ON EITHER FLOOR
WITH THAT RESPECT WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU RESCUE
SENIOR DISCUSSED BATES CLARK
LIBERAL. THESE ARE NOT ALL
MEMBERS FOR A RESERVE A. ALL
MEMBER SERVICEOUT OF THE PARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED UP AND I
SIXTY ONE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
BACK IN FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY ONE QUICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY PUBLIC CONTRACTS MR
SALAS. THERE IS SPEAKER AB NINE
SEVENTY ONE WILL CREATE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY WAS STATE I. T.
PROJECTS AND AMENDMENTS. RAISE
THE THRESHOLD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THING WE SHALL
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK
WILL OPEN. CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO IS AB NINE
NINE ONE CORPORATION SOME
PEOPLE NINE NINETY ONE BY
FAMILY MEMBER GALLAGHER AND
ACTUALLY TO THE MAINTENANCE OF
CODES. MR GALLAGHER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS RISE
RESENT AB NINE NINE ONE WHICH
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE HI THIS
IS THE ANNUAL CODE MAINTENANCE
BILL THAT. WHERE WE TAKE CARE
OF SOME GRAMMAR REMOVES
DUPLICATIVE CODES STYLISTIC
CHANGES AMBIGUITIES AND IF YOU
COUPLE THINGS I PUT IN THERE
YOU'LL HARDLY EVER NOTICE JUST
KIDDING. BUT AT ANY RATE THIS
IS THE THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
HELPS CLEAN UP OUR CODES. AND
I'M PROUD TO CARRY IT OUT FOR
YOUR AYE THE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANKS CALDERON SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
FOR WHICH WE PASS TEMPORARILY
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR CARPOOL.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY TO STUDENT FINANCIAL
AID DECLARING THEIR TO THEIR UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR
BONTA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT AUTHORIZES THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT IT
COMMISSION TO EXTEND FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION DEADLINES FOR
STUDENTS TO NATURAL DISASTERS
OR EMERGENCIES. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL THE BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK MISS
BARTON SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO DECIDE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
BACK AND FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE AB TEN
THIRTY SIX CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO ELECTIONS
MS AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TEN
THIRTY SIX IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE THAT
OUT OF TRANSPARENCY MEASURES
AND A SUNSET DATE THIS BILL
REDUCE BARRIERS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS BY REQUIRING
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. TO
UPDATE THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE REGULATIONS DIRECTING
COUNTY WAS TO DEVELOP OUTREACH
PROGRAMS AND BY CREATING THE
HIGH SCHOOL VOTER EDUCATION
PILOT PROGRAM IN YELLOW COUNTY
THESE MEASURES WILL SURE THAT
ARE MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS
ARE CAGED. IN THE VOTING
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU MS A YEAR. C.
NOTICE KASHER BATES CLERK WILL
OF THE ROLE MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRABLE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I FIFTY ONE KNOWS ELEVEN
CENTER MA'AM AND SIR CONCURRED
IN MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK
TOWARD THE TOP OF THE FILE THE
TAKE A FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
THIS IS A SEVEN SIXTY ONE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER NAZARIAN AND
ACTUALLY THE HOMELESSNESS
MISSION IS THERE IN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
PRESENTING AB SEVEN SIXTY ONE
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MILITARY TO USE
ARMORIES AS HOMELESS SHELTERS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WHEN THERE
ARE HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS SUCH
AS EXTREME HEAT IN THE SUMMER.
STATE OWN ARMORIES HAVE LONG
PROVIDED A RESOURCE THE
COMMUNITY SEEKING SITES FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTER DURING THE
WINTER THE SITES COULD BE USED
TO SAVE LIVES DURING HAZARDOUS
WEATHER EVENTS IN THE SUMMER
WHEN HOMELESS. INDIVIDUALS ARE
EXPOSED TO DANGEROUS HE
CONDITIONS MEMBERS TAKEN AND
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
CLEAN MY COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISSION IS THERE AND SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE QUIRK
LIBERAL. THAT OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF THAT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN NOW
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN. TO TAKE UP
MS GARCIA'S ITEM THIS IS AB
THREE SIXTY FIVE. COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
EMPLOYMENT. MISTER CS. THANK
YOU EIGHTY THREE SIXTY FIVE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCY AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. REDUCE THE COST
OF THIS BILL BY LIMITING THE
TASK FORCE AB T. SIXTY FIVE
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE. THERE IS CSE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
WORKING HEARD IN BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO READ ASSEMBLY BILL
LEVIN SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY THE SPECIAL EDUCATION.
MR FRAZIER YOU MAY OPEN.
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ADJUSTED THE
OVERSIGHT STRUCTURE AND IMPROVE
THE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR
NON PUBLIC SCHOOL STAFF. THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
BIBLE. THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OF A CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- CONCERNED ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS
ZERO SEVEN MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE IS AB ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BY MR GABRIEL CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SOMETHING OR GABRIEL
AND ACT ON THE RESIDENTIAL
RENTAL PROPERTY. SHE APRIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT IS BACK IN THE
ASSEMBLY ON CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
TENANTS TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THEIR LANDLORD
ALLOWING THEM TO HOUSE A FRIEND
OR FAMILY MEMBER AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. MA'AM IT'S TAKING
IN THE SENATE WERE CLARIFYING
IN NATURE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THEY WAS GABRIEL SING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN. MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF OWN
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THE
CLERK WILL. CULTURAL TITLE BUT
I SIXTY FIVE TWO ZERO CENTER
MEMON CIRCUIT CURTAIN FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX IS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO CORKERY SOME LEGAL THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WALDRON AND ACTUALLY THE MENTAL
HEALTH. MISS WALDRON THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND EXPANDS THE
COMMUNITY IMPACT PERSPECTIVE OF
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH BOARDS WITH
THE ADDED BENEFITS OF EASE
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND MORE INPUT FOR
STAKEHOLDERS AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE SENATE MITIGATE COSTS
AND ALLEVIATE CONCERNS SO THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
ENJOYS BROAD. BOY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I OR TONIGHT. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON SEE NO DISCUSSION
OF A CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOSE. WELL
CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF A. I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. AB FOURTEEN
NINETY THREE CORKERY I SOME
ABLE FOURTEEN NINETY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER TING ACTUALLY
FIREARMS MR J. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FOURTEEN NINETY
THREE A LOSS OF THE SUBJECT OF
A GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER TO SUBMIT A COURT FORMS
THING THAT THEY ARE INTENDING
NOT TO CONTEST THE ORDER. IN
WAVES THE COURT HEARING AB
FORTY NINETY THREE IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENT
SENATE DEMANDS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AT A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR SEPTEMBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY AND.
RESOLVE CHAPTER IN CONFLICTS
OUT OF RESPECT FOR US RIGHT.
THANKS FOR STAYING SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS DESIRE
TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU BUT I FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO A LOT MISTER TEAM TO
TAKE UP A COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
ITEMS FOR WHICH WE PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM. NINE. IS
AB SIXTY ONE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER TING AND ACTUALLY THE
FARMS MISTER TECH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB SIXTY ONE
EXPANDS THE POOL OF PEOPLE WHO
CAN I REQUEST A GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER BY ADDING AN
EMPLOYER A CO WORKER IN
EMPLOYEE OF A HIGH SCHOOL OR
COLLEGE TO REQUEST THE COURT TO
ISSUE A GUN BONTA STRAINING
ORDER. AB SIXTY ONE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE SENATOR BANDS
ADDED A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
AS WELL TO SEPTEMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY MAKING CLARIFYING
CHANGES IN RESOLVING CHAPTER IN
CONFLICT WITHOUT. RESPECT AS
FRONT. THANK YOU MICHELLE. SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS ADAMANT ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE OF. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRABLE. CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ALL TELL YOU BUT I
AS FIFTY ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN AND MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
TWELVE CORPORATION AS A LEGAL
FIVE TWELVE BY SOME REMEMBER
TING ACTUALLY MEDI CAL MISTER
TECH. I THINK IT WOULD SPEAKER
AB FIVE ONE TOO EXPENSIVE
MISSION COLLECTED REPORTED IN
UTILIZING CULTURAL COMPETENCY
PLANS FOR COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS. IT'S BACK FROM
THE SENATE IN THE AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MICHELLE SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS OF. ZACK VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS CERTAIN THE DESIRE
OF THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL
TIE THE- EYES FIFTY NINE KNOWS
THREE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. BACK END FILE
ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
CORPORATION AS A LEGAL FIFTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMIS AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO APPRENTICESHIP MR RONALD TO
MAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
THE SENTIMENTS MAKE NOTES OF
STANCE OF CHANGES AND ADDED CO
AUTHORS. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
ROSSI NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
NUMBER SO THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM. THIRTY
NINE IS AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
OPERATE AS A LEGAL FIFTEEN
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY DID BY MENTAL QUALITY.
THIS FRIEDMAN EMAIL BUT- THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER PASSING THIS
HOUSE IN MAY WITH BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AMENDMENTS
IN THE SENATE CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF BUS RAPID TRANSIT
TO ENSURE IT REPRESENTS THE
HIGHEST QUALITY OF TRANSIT
INCLUDING SIGNAL PRIORITY ALL
DOOR BOARDING FARE COLLECTION
SYSTEMS ARE PROMOTE EFFICIENCY
AND DEFINED STATIONS THIS WILL
ENSURE HOUSING INCENTIVES
APPLIED WAS MUCH HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT AS POSSIBLE AB AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR WITH THIRTY NINE AYE
VOTES. AND I REQUEST FULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU REYES
FREQUENCY NO DISCUSSION OF A
CLUB LEVEL THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS THE- DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF
OUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALTOGETHER
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATOR THEM ANSWER CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FORTY IS AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT CORKERY AS
LEGAL SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT FIVE
FAMILY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
OTHERS AN EXCELLENT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MYSTERY
THIS EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SAID THE BILL SIXTY
TWENTY EIGHT REVISES THE
DEFINITION OF A MATEO OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO
INCLUDE ME FULL INVOLVEMENT TO
SURE THAT IMPACTED THE
COMMUNITIES HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS REVISED THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE REMOVE REFERENCE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT JUST AS BUREAU.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY TWENTY
EIGHT HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECT YOUR QUESTION
CONCURRENT AND SEND AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MS REVERSING THEIR
DISCUSSION BAKER COOPER THE
ROLE. VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF HIS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY NINE NEWS
FOURTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE IS AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE PEOPLE HE. MISTER RAMOS
THE MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
ON CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
MOMENT AMENDMENTS AT CO AUTHORS
AND MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES TO
THE BILL. IN ENSURE SUICIDE
PREVENTION RESOURCES GET TO
MORE STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
RAMOS SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION
OF A CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE TELE
THOUGH. I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY TWO
AB NINE. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY INTO EMPLOYMENT
THIS RACE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB NINE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
ALLOWS VICTIMS OF WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
ADDITIONAL TIME TO SEEK REDRESS
IT EXTENDS THE FILING DEADLINE
FROM ONE YEAR TO THREE YEARS IN
WHICH VICTIMS ARE ABLE TO FILE
A CLAIM WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING.
AMENDMENTS OUR TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ITEM
THANK YOU MS REYES SAY NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF. WAS OUT OF IT
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE
TALIBAN ICE FORTY SIX KNOWS FOR
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE A. B. THIRTY SEVEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. MISTER
JONES SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB THIRTY SEVEN
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND AT
THE REQUESTED DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
THIS POLICY MEMBERS THIS BILL
AS WE SEE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK MISSION SOURCING NOTICE
KASHER DEBATE CLERK WILL OVER
THE ROLL. OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARABLE. KIRK
WELL CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU THE
HIGHS FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR IS AB
ONE TWENTY EIGHT CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DECLINES
MISTER GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT IS BACK IN THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOT. THANK YOU MISS
FLORES KASHER DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. AS ADAM OF ALL
MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. WHO IS OUT OF
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
OF A AYE AYES FIFTY NINE. KNOWS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE. AB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. CLICK RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY FIVE
BY SOME THE MEMBER GIPSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO FOSTER
CARE MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MRS REAGAN MEMBERS AB
ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS BACKING
CONCURRENCE WITH THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ALSO INCLUDING TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING A MEMBERS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
WHEN AB ONE SEVENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MISS GIPSON. SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THIS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRABLE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FORTY
SEVEN OH SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX AB TWO
ELEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
ELEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
CALDERON AND OTHERS ARE NOT
GOING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISTER CALDERON. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO ELEVEN
CREATED TAXES THAT DEDUCTION
FOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO A
SCHOLARSHIP FIVE TWO NINE
ACCOUNT WITH A LIMIT OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SINGLE
FILERS. AND TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR JOINT FILERS SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDED TO RECAPTURE
PROVISION TO FIND A QUALIFIED
EDUCATION EXPENSE ARTICLE
OTHERS MADE SOME TECHNICAL.
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
I RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. IT'S AN. THANK
WAS CALDERON SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLICK OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS SERVICE OUT OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY SEVEN.
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS AGAIN TEMPORARILY ON MR
MCCARTY'S ITEM. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE PURPLE RAIN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY A
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING. MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE VOTE THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT CURRENT CLEAN
AIR AND CLIMATE STANDARDS ARE
ACCOUNTED FOR WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
PASSED THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL WITH AN ASSESSMENT OF
CALTRANS IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN
GOALS AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON HOW TO IMPROVE THE
COORDINATION AN IMPACT A VERY
IS GRANT PROGRAMS WITH OTHER
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING PROGRAMS
OF ALL STATE ORGANIZATIONS A C.
G. C. IS IN THE BEST POSITION
TO COMPREHENSIVELY REVIEW
ENCOURAGE COORDINATION OF THE
STATE'S MANY EXISTING. AND
UNCOORDINATED CLIMATE CHANGE
PROGRAMS THIS BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA MEETS
OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. RAMOS FRIEDMAN
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN. THIS ADVERT ON
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FOURTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN. FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE. IS AB THREE EIGHTEEN
KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
EIGHTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
KANSEN CHU AND ACTUALLY THE
MEDI CAL MR CHIU YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THREE EIGHTEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENT
OUR TECHNICAL AND TERRIFYING IN
NATURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHOOSING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
NUMBERS. THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. CLICK WELL
CLOSER ALL THE TIME ABOUT ICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS THIRTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FIFTY AB THREE
FOUR TWO CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
LANDS THIS MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THREE
FOUR TWO BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE SENATE
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING IN NATURE
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SENIOR DISCUSSION
OF EIGHT. CORPORAL ALL MEMBER
SERVICE ADAMO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
FORTY SEVEN AS FOURTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE AB THREE
EIGHT SIX CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. MR GARCIA
YOU MAY OPEN AB THREE EIGHTY
SIX BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WOULD
SENATE AMENDMENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL. SEEING AND
HEARING NO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
CLICK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS OF.
DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE CLICK WELL. CLOSER
ALL CHILD BUT I SIXTY FIVE
KNOWS ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FIFTY
TWO IS AB FOR SIXTY NINE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE RECORDS MANAGEMENT. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FOR SIXTY NINE IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE I THE AMENDMENTS
SIMPLY DECREASE THE FREQUENCY
OF REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN
THE BELL AND THEREFORE WILL. I
DECREASE COSTS THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND HAS ENJOYED BROAD BI
PARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE IT. THANK YOU
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLICK OVER THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WILL
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU BUT I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
IN THE FILE TO TAKE A MISTER
MCCARTY'S ITEMS. MEMBERS FOR.
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN IN FILE ORDERED
THEM OVERTURNED FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN. AB. TWO SEVEN
EIGHT. CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME
THE MEMBER MCCARTY AND ACTUALLY
THE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
MISTER MCCARTY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OF COURSE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT IT'S A MEASURE TO
ALLOW PEOPLE ON PAROLE TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS WE ASK OUR GUESTS
GALLERY TO REFRAIN FROM OUT
FIRST. WE WILL HAVE A CHAMBER
.
AB ORDER THE CHAMBER
. MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO RECESS RECALL
THE SPEAKER THERE WERE RECESS
AND RECALL OF THE SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
PLEASE RETURN OF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS WE'RE BACK IN SESSION
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THREE.
AB FIVE FORTY FIVE IS GOING ON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS EIGHTY FIVE FORTY IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AB FIVE
FORTY ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA DREAMER SERVICE
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. SACRAMENTO GRAMMAR
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LAMOTTA. YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBER AB
FIVE PARTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT AB FIVE FORTY
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
DREAMER INCENTIVES SERVICE
GRANT PROGRAM AND CALIFORNIA.
MISSION SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT WILL
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE AND GAIN
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR SELECTED
CAREER PATH. THE SERVICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS WILL.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THE
. MEMBERS OF. NICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS LEVINSON YEAH. IN
THE PAST MEDINA. FOR PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM FIFTY
FIVE. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE AB SIX THIRTY EIGHT HI MR
GRAY. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY
AND ACTUALLY THE WATER
RESOURCES. RAY YOU MAY OPEN.
THIS IS BAKER MEMBERS. AB SIX
THIRTY EIGHT REQUIRES BOMBING
ONE RESOURCES TO IDENTIFY THE
CHANGES RELATIVE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE A WATER LINE. THIS IS
BACK ON COMPLIANCE THIS IS A
GREAT BILL WE SPOKE WITH LOW
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
MEMBERS OF THE. MEMBERS MAY.
WELL CLOSING EYES. FIFTY FOUR
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. WELL IN IN FIFTY
SIX IS AB SIX SEVENTY SEVEN BY
DR CHOI. THE BILL SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TOOL IN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE INTER
CLINCHING. CHOI YOU MAIL.
MEMBERS YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
HEAR ABOUT THE HERE IS MY- SIX
SEVEN SEVEN ADOPTION BILL IS A
BAD ONE THE HOME KERR ON SO
FROM THE SENATE. A MAN THE MOST
SO TAKE A NEED THE SENATE
ADDRESS TOMORROW NO REPORTING
NEWS THE WHOLE DEPARTMENTS THE
BILL HAS TO RECEIVE THEIR
UNANIMOUS OF BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN BOTH THE CHAMBERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU THAT.
DISCUSSION TODAY WELL THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WELL.
THREE ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE. SEVEN TWENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND ACTUALLY DO RECYCLING.
CAN'T MAIL FROM THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB SEVEN TWENTY
NIGHTS BACK WILL COME KERN THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL ARE SIMPLE WE
WANT TO GIVE CAL RECYCLED THE
TOOL TO OVERSEE THIS PROGRAM TO
MEET OUR STATE RECYCLING GOAL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA I
WILL. THANK YOU KNOW THE
SPECIAL EVENT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. SIX FORTY ONE. WELL.
CLOSE WAY TIE THAT ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. WHILE
IN FIFTY EIGHT IS AB SEVEN
THIRTY FOR ME. THE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO FOSTER CA.
MAIENSCHEIN AVAILABLE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR IS BACK ON
COMPLIANCE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MAY
NOTICE THAT. WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE FLORIDA VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRABLE.
WELL CLOSE ROOM I SIXTY ONE.
NEWS ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THE PASSWORD IN A
FILE I'M FIFTY NINE. ITEM SIXTY
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX. EIGHT
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WHAT'S IN OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
NOT TAKING THEIR POLLUTION THIS
WEEK'S EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILLS BACK
ON CONCERNS FROM THE SENATE
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
CLARIFYING AND ADDED A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET DATE THIS BILL. HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THE NOTIFICATION MAY HAVE WILL
OPEN ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS OF THE. MEMBERS WHO
HAVE. FIFTY EIGHT DOES. SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. FILE
ITEM SIXTY AND IS AB EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT. EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
BY SOME IMMIGRANT OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL. COMPLIANCE
AND COVERAGE FOR CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS FOR MEDI CAL
PATIENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. WELL ALL MEMBERS. ALL
MEMBERS. WELL CLOSER ALL TIME
THAT I SIXTY TWO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE THIRTY. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN. AB ONE
FORTY TWO. THE BILL ONE FORTY
TO BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND ACTUALLY NO
HAZARDOUS WASTE THE URGENCY
THERE OUGHT TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. THANK YOU THE
SENTIMENTS WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE THE BILL FIFTY
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
SUPPORTED BY THE INDUSTRY AND
BY MENTAL. CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AND I HAVE
A. NO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. ALL MEMBERS TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE. ALL
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE. TAKES
FORTY ONE
. QUESTION MEMBERS
FIFTY FOUR FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS BACK TO THE
. SIX FIFTY
FOUR. THE AIM OF THE CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN FILE
ORDER. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO. AB EIGHT NINETY
FOUR. BEFORE THE MEASURE WILL
CLOSE TO ME. THANK YOU FOR NO
SIXTEEN. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
TEMPERED IN
. OKAY MEMBERS IN
FILE ORDER ONE FINAL ORDER THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO. AB
EIGHT NINETY FOUR. AND THE
CLERK WILL READ. THE BILL EIGHT
NINETY FOUR BY SOMETHING MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MISTER SANTIAGO AB NINETY FOURS
BACK BECAUSE THANK YOU. THE
NOTICE SESSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM FOR GLOBAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS I ARE TO VOTE.
AND MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSER ROADSIDE ON
ICE FORTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARKAN TURNING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY. THREE
EIGHTY NINE TWO NINE. IT'S A
LITTLE NINE TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US
NATURALLY THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. IS RIVAS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB NINE
TWO NINE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT FURTHER
EMPHASIZE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVAL. MAIN ARTICLE OVER THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS FIRM DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS. IS THERE THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE WE WILL TELL
YOU VOTE HI SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS.
CENTER MEMBERS THIRTY. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR A. B. TEN
TWENTY SIX BY DOCTOR WOULD.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD ACTUALLY
TO ELECTRICITY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TEN
TWENTY SIX IS BACK WORKING
PARENTS AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
IN THE SENATE TO ADDRESS A
BURIED APPROACHES OF THE
UTILITIES AND HOW THEY PROCESS
EXTENSION SERVICE PROJECT. GOES
UNIT ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE LOW.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM LOCAL OPENING. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE IS THAT A VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTE. TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE WILL TELL YOU THAT
I SPEAK TO YOU KNOW ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE TEN THIRTY IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE.
AB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN EIGHTY EIGHT PRICE
ONLY MEMBER WOULD ACTUALLY MEDI
CAL. DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY GET
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WILL HELP PREVENT LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE ENROLLED
IN BOTH MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
NOW FROM LOSING THEIR MEDICAL
COVERAGE WHEN THE STATE BEGINS
PAYING THEIR MEDICARE PART A
PART B. PREMIUMS. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS INCORPORATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I ASK YOUR CONCURRENCE
IN A SENATE AMENDMENTS QUICKLY
ANSWER I'M A- GROUP. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE- LOCAL.
ALL MEMBERS THE NEWS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS REYES OUT OF THOSE.
WILL CLOSE RULES I SIXTY SIX
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX EIGHTY
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE. ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER
CANNON OTHERS IN ACTUALLY A
CHILD CUSTODY WAS PARENTING AND
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE SIDE
REDUCE COSTS BY HAVING THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
USING TRAINING MODULES DEVELOP
BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR
IMPLEMENTATION MANDATORY
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS. FOR PAID
VISITATION MONITORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU WAS MARK HANSEN
NOTICE FROM THE BAIT ON THE
ITEM THE FEDERAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOCAL DESIRE TO THE
CLERK WILL. ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY EIGHT ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE HURTING. FILE
ITEMS SIXTY SEVEN AND SIXTY
EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
NINE A. B. FIFTEEN TEN. THE
BILL THIRTEEN TEN BY SOMEONE
NUMBER REYES AND OTHERS AND
HAPPEN TO SEXUAL MISCONDUCT THE
THING THERE IS EITHER UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
GRAYSON MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND HERS. AB FIFTEEN
TEN PROVIDES VICTIMS OF DOCTOR
DO GEORGE. KENDALL ONE YEAR TO
BOTHER CASES IN COURT THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN
BARRED. ALTHOUGH YOU AS HE HAD
BEEN OPPOSE THEIR NOW NEUTRAL
WITH A MEN'S AND AMENDMENTS
TAKEN. SENATE AMENDMENT TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR HOW
VICTIMS MUST FILE THEIR CLAIMS
INCLUDED NO JUST A CLAUSE.
THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
REMOVED. HAD REMOVED MOST OF
THE OPPOSITION THIS BILL IS
CRUCIAL FOR VICTIMS. SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE THE DECISION
GOING FORWARD ON. PURSUING
THEIR CLAIMS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU LIZ
REYES SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE GLOBAL ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
MATTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL. ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FIFTY NINE OH ZERO ON THE
URGENCY EYES FIFTY NINE THERE'S
ZERO ON THE MEASURE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCLUDING. THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY. AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY THE CURTAIN. THE
BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MOAN AND
ACTUALLY THE COASTAL RESOURCES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
EIGHTY WILL ACHIEVE ACOSTA
ACCESS PROGRAM FOR THE PUBLIC
AT HOLLISTER RANCH IN MY
DISTRICT AFTER NEARLY FOUR
DECADES THE DELAY. SENATE
AMENDMENT THAT A CLEAR
DEADLINES FOR ACTS AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THE BACK THIS IS
IN A JEEP WITH A REASONABLE
TIME FRAME THIS WILL RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS SLOW. WHO'S
OUT OF THEM. WORK WELL CLOSER
ROLE. TELL YOU THE. SIZE FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE HEARD IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE ACR NINETY NINE BY
MISTER LOW. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE TO CIVIL RIGHTS. HELLO
YOU MAIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MAN MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR REVENUE WILL
SLOW NO DISCUSSION IN THE BAY.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THEM
ALL MEMBERS VOTE AND DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS CENTERS OUT
OF THE- WELL. BUT I SPEAKING TO
NO SEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
THIRD IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO HA ARE TEN. IT'S ON
THE JOINT RESOLUTION TEN BY
SELLING MEMORIES AND OTHERS
REAL TO THE VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION MISS REYES MEGAN OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
NUMBERS TODAY PRESENT YOU AJ
ARE TEN FOR PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS UPDATE THE
RESOLUTION TO REFLECT THE GO CA
SINCE. BEFORE BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
I NUMEROUS VEHICLE VEHICLE.
MANUFACTURERS ARE STRICTLY OUT
FOR YOUR RIGHT. THANK YOU MS
REYES SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CARPOOL OVER
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS WELL
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL HE'S WILL
TIE THAT ICE BEFORE. HE KNOWS
FOR SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE.
AJ ARE NINETEEN. I SIMPLY DON'T
RESOLUTION NINETEEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO REFUGEES.
GLORIA YOU MAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO ANSWER
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AJ ARE
NINETEEN CONCURRENT WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON BEHALF OF THIS LEGITIMATE
HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE. THANK YOU
MISS LORIA SAYING OUT OF DATE
ON THE ITEM. ALL MEMBERS. HAVE
RESIGNED TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
INSIDE OF THE- PHONE NUMBERS
VOTE SATURDAY. WELL MOST ROLE
TIME THAT ICE WOULD BE THREE
NOS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
PARKING IN FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR IS AB TEN SEVENTY NINE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
MR SANTIAGO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND IT'S A GOOD
BILL PLEASE VOTE FOR. SANTIAGO
SENIOR DISCUSS. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRABLE MEMBERS. ALL
MEMBERS ONE. WELL ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE A. B.
SIXTEEN. THE BILL SIXTEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER THREE OF US
AND OTHERS ENACTED A HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SIXTEEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
AFTER TAKING SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU. MS RULES
SEEING THEIR RECESSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM ON THE RUN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE MEANS THAT A VOTE
ON MEMBERS VETERANS ADDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL WILL TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY
FIVE NEWS ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCERNED. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX IS AB TWO NINETY
SIX. ASSEMBLY BILL TO NINETY
SIX BYTES ONLY MEMBER COOLEY
AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA CLIMATE
CHANGE MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE. COOLEY EMAIL
COLLEAGUES AB TWO NINETY SIX
SCHOOL ESTABLISH THE CLAIM AND
INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN
THE STRATEGIC PROCONSUL
SYNONYMS FOR NON CONTROVERSIAL
I RETURN I WILL. THANK YOU
MISTER. NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ALL MEMBERS. THIS ADDED THE-
PHONE NUMBERS FOR THE SIDE OF
THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT
HER. WELL. HIS ROLE AS FIFTY
FIVE NOSE ONE. AND AMENDMENTS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE OH THREE. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACTUALLY THE MENTAL HEALTH.
THIS CERVANTES CHAU. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS PRESENT
IN ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THREE
FOUR I KNOW. I IN THE SENATE.
THESE AMENDMENTS EARLY RELEASES
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS. BY
PROVIDING STATUTORY GUIDANCE ON
THE PROCEDURES. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU
MISTER RIGHT.SENIOR TO
SPECIALLY MADE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ON MEMBERS WILL RESIGN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRABLE.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIME LOW I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. FILE
ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT IS EIGHTY
FOUR TWENTY. LEGAL FOR TWENTY
BY SOMETHING MEMBER LACKEY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CANNABIS TO KINDA EARNS EITHER
UP TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
EMAIL. THEY BEFORE TWENTY
DESERVES YOUR VOTE GET IT
THANKS. SENIOR DISCUSSION OF
EIGHT ON THE ITEM WELL OVERALL.
ALL MEMBERS SENATORS THAT A
VOTE. MEMBERS THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED.
WELL. LOS RURAL TALLY BUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE FROM KERN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE A. B.
SIX OF ELEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DESIRING ANOTHER'S AND ACTUALLY
THE SEXUAL ABUSE OF ANIMALS THE
SERVICE AREA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SIX ELEVEN IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WILL
EXPANDING CLARIFY CURRENT LINE
PROHIBITS SEXUAL ASSAULT OF
ANIMALS TO SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDING GAUGING AND SEXUAL
CONTACT WITH ANIMALS WITH ANY
PART OF THE BODY OR ANY OBJECT.
THIS BILL ALSO WILL EXPAND THE
INTENT ELEMENT OF THE LAW TO
COVER AN ACT COMMITTED FOR
ABUSE OR FOR FINANCIAL GAIN
THUS PROHIBITING THE SELLING OR
RENTING OF ANIMALS FOR SEX.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASKED
FOR AND I. SEEING THE STATURE.
GLOBAL. ADMINISTRATORS ARE VOTE
WELL DESIGNED. WELL WAS RURAL.
EVEN I SIXTY FIVE NINE ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS PARKING THIRTY
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY.
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE. AS AN
ABLE SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY SOME
THE MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. MISTER KALRA EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SEVEN THIRTY ONE IS
BACK. THE SENATE AMENDMENTS WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
WORKLOAD ABOUT THE HEALTH PLAN
REGULATORS AND HEALTH PLANS
REVIEW THE METHODOLOGY USED TO
THE RIGHT. SPECIFICALLY THE
RATE REVIEW FOR LARGE GROUP
RATES DELAYED UNTIL JANUARY OR
JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
I QUITE SHOOTER BECAUSE A FULL
REVIEW WAS FURTHER LIMITED TO
ADDRESS DEPARTMENT WORKLOAD.
STARTING ON JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THOSE LARGER
PURCHASES WHICH WAS ALSO MORE
COVER LIVES WITHOUT THE ABILITY
TO REQUEST A FULL REVIEW. CHECK
THE PREMIUMS PAID MATCH
UTILIZATION ARE REASONABLE. THE
METHODOLOGY USES GERMAN RESERVE
ARE JUSTIFIED THE EMPLOYER
UNION TRUST LIKE TO SHOP FOR A
BETTER PRICE THE MEMBERS ARE
DISCUSSED READ BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. THE BILL IS NOT
SUPPORTED. BY THE DEPARTMENT
CHURNS. BUCKLEY OSBORNE I BOTH.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
PROBABLY MISTER KALRA. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AND VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. SIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEDICINES ARE VERY
WELL. CLOSE TO ALL THE TIME
ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE NEWS
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CAN PROGRAM. FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE. IS AB NINE FOURTEEN
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FOURTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
HOLDEN AND ACTUALLY THE MEDIC
HOW. THIS MAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. HI RISE 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FOURTEEN
BACK ON CONCURRENT AB NINE
FOURTEEN REQUIRE THE SUSPENSION
OF MEDI CAL BENEFITS EVERY
DETERMINATION OF ELIGIBILITY
THERE A SIMPLIFIED YEARLY
PROCESS FOR MEMBERS OF A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX MINUTES TAKEN IN THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
BILL UNTIL OCTOBER FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS. RED OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AB NINE FOURTEEN WILL
DECREASE RATES OF ILLNESSES
DEATH ANDRECIDIVISM BY
IMPROVING IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
HEALTH SERVICES. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN. ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND ALL COMMITTEES
ASSEMBLY BILL NYE FOURTEEN ALSO
HAS A SUPPORT BY ALL FORTY
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE I THANK
YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE COUPLE OF
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF HIS
OUT OF THEM ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE THOUGH. ALL MEMBERS SMOKE
THE DESIRE TO GO. WORK WILL
CLOSER TIES ABOUT EYES SIXTY
RHINOS ZERO SAN MEMBERS CERTAIN
HEARD IN. MEMBERS WHO WANT TO
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM EIGHTY
TWO. THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE. AB ONE
THOUSAND FOUR. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE THOUSAND FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MR MCCARTY EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS OCCURRENCE
VOTE FOR A MEASURE TO IMPROVE
PERIODIC SCREENING FOR INFANTS
AND TODDLERS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MCCARTY.
EMAIL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM LOCAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS SO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO DECIDE. CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLE TIME OUT I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR. AB TEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY MISTER COOLEY
CARPOOL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY AND EXPLAINED A JUVENILE.
COLLEAGUES AB TENSER CA RELATES
TO. OUR CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
STRENGTH IN DELIVER SERVICES
KIDS SENATE BILL KNOWS THE BILL
FOR COST REASONS. I URGE
CONCURRENT SINCE THEN
AMENDMENTS. SENIOR DISCUSSION
OF A LOCAL OVER THE- ALL
MEMBERS OF. WHO HAD A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIGNED TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REYES ADDED LOW.
WELL CLOSER ALL TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS OUR ROOM. THIS IS
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE AB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALL RAN OTHERS AN ACTION THE
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS TAKING THE SENATE TO AB
LET US TO REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT A LOCAL AGENCIES
PROVIDE NOTICE LOGIC STOP IN
FRONT. OF THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS ORDER A MOVE THE
LOCAL MANDATE OTHER MEMBERS OF
HER BY INTERNAL NATURE SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO IS A LINE WITH
WHAT MANY HOTEL A LODGE STOPS
ALREADY DOING PROVIDES
APPROPRIATE FLEXIBILITY
UNCERTAINTY FOR THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY TO COMPLY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THE GALLERY I
RECOGNIZE. ON THE ITEM THE MORE
BIG GOVERNMENT INTERVENTION
VOTE NO. THANK YOU MISS
GALLAGHER SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. LOCAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. IS ARE THOSE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. TELL YOU
THAT I SPREE THREE NO SEVENTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THANK YOU FOR THE CHANGE OF
PACE FOR GALLAGHER. IN FINAL
ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SIX A. B. TWELVE TWELVE. SOME
PEOPLE TOLD TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT THIS YEAR LIVING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS CALIFORNIA
FORWARD PROJECTS THAT WE NEED
TO INVEST OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN OUR STATES
INFRASTRUCTURE JUST IN THE NEXT
DECADE. ALONE BUT OF COURSE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT TYPE OF MONEY
IN OUR BUDGET EACH YEAR BUT YOU
KNOW WHO DOES CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS SO THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
THAT STATE AGENCIES PROVIDE
THEM. A LIST OF INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP US BUILD
A STRUCTURE THAT OUR STATE
NEEDS IT DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
TYPE OF INVESTMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS LIVING
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE CLERK WILL. CULTURAL
TALLY ABOUT ICE FORTY KNOWS
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN AB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
SALAS AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY MR SALAS
FEMALE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN IS A BILL THAT I HELP OUR
VETERANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
VETERANS RETURNING WITH A
DISABILITY THIS. THIS MEASURE
WILL HELP GREATER CELLS TAX
EXEMPTION ON A DOCTOR THAT A
MOTIVE EQUIPMENT SENATE A
MEMBER TONY INCLUDED. VETERANS
THAT WERE SEVERELY BURNED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MICHELLE SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS
OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLE
TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS. ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY EIGHT. AB TWELVE ANY TO
CORKERY ASSEMBLY WILL TWELVE
EIGHTY TO BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
KALRA AND ACTUALLY IN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT. ALL
RIGHT YOU MAY GET A- THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS FOR THE
OPTION IT WAS ON THIS BILL
TODAY BE TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
PROHIBITS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION FROM
ASSISTING OR ALLOWING PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS TO ARREST.
DETAIN OR OTHERWISE TAKE INTO
CUSTODY INDIVIDUALS AND STATE
CUSTODY FOR IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES. AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE CAUGHT UP I REGULATIONS
ADOPTED BY THE CDC ARE IN TWO
THOUSAND. TO TAKE INDIVIDUALS
INTO CUSTODY AS WE ALL KNOW OUR
FEDERAL MINISTRATIONS
UNDERTAKEN AMASSED ATTENTION
DEPORTATION COVER WHICH
INCLUDES HEAVILY RELYING UPON
USE A PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS
TO ENFORCE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
LAW. THIS IS IN DIRECT
CONTRAVENTION OF ESTABLISH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS WELL AS
WELL ESTABLISH A LEGAL
PRECEDENT. MEMBERS FEDERAL LAW
IS CLEAR UNDER THE FEDERAL
INSPIRATION NATIONALITY ACT AND
ITS IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAW THE BILL IS CO
SPONSORED BY THE BY ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE.
SUPPORT BY THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHE SAYS GEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS KALRA
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ADAM CLICK CLICK ON THE
RIGHT. MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE TELL
ABOUT EYES FIFTY KNOWS FIFTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE AB TWELVE NINETY ONE
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND ACTUALLY
CANNABIS. MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWELVE NINETY ONE MA'AM IT'S
TAKING IN THE SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND IT
ENSURES PROPER IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL. OUR RESPECTIVE
ASTRI AYE VOTE. THANK MISSION
SOURCING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK LOCAL THE ROLE. OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS ERA WORK WELL
CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM NINETY IS A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
BY FAMILY MEMBER THREE OF US
AND ACT ON A STUDENT DEBTS. MS
RIVAS. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AFTER TAKING CLEAR FINE
AMENDMENTS TO THE DEFINITION OF
DATA SO THAT THE BILL APPLIES
TO BOTH DEBTS. TO A SCHOOL AND
ALSO TO PRIVATE SCHOOL LENDERS
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. HE WAS
RENOUNCING THEIR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS OF HIS OUT OF THEM ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF REDDIT IS
OUT OF THOSE. THE CLERK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETY ONE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR BY MR
DAILY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY JUVENILES MR DAILY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
REMEMBERS THIS BILL ELIMINATES
THE FEE FOR PETITIONING A COURT
TO SEAL A JUVENILE RECORD FOR
PERSONS OF ANY AGE SUBMITTED BY
PERSONS OF ANY AGE. I READ THE
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THEY
WERE STEALING SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALMOST ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE THE
ROLE TELL YOU BUT I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS TO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO. FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE. AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL MS
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR CLARIFIES THAT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PERFORMED
OUTSIDE OF A COMMUNITY CLINICS
FOUR WALLS DURING AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION MUST BE REIMBURSABLE
WHETHER IN A SHELTER A
PATIENT'S HOME BY PHONE OR
THROUGH TELEHEALTH SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDED CLARIFYING
DEFINITIONS THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. NO
OPPOSITION I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. OR
CLUB ALL. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE
THOUGH ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIME BUT I SIXTY NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM NINETY
FOUR. IS AB FIFTY NINETY
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY BY SOME THE MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. MS
RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB FIFTY NINETY IS BACKING
CONCURRENCE TODAY THE BILL WILL
CREATE A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR.
TAX CREDIT FOR LOW OR MODERATE
INCOME FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
WORSENING HOUSING CRISIS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS ARE LIMITED DUE TO
THE INCREASING COST ESPECIALLY
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES OF LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME. THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN
THE SENATE SO THAT THERE ARE NO
GEOGRAPHICAL REQUIREMENTS FOR A
TAX CREDIT. THE CREDIT CAN BE
UTILIZED BY LOW OR MODERATE
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS LIVING
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL PROMOTES FINANCIAL
PROSPERITY AND PROVIDES NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS
TO INVEST IN THEIR FUTURE BY
BECOMING FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS. THE BILL IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS RUBIO
SEEM NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO AND
ACTUALLY TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
MISS KOREA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
CREATE A CAREFUL BALANCE OF
ADULT EDUCATORS ADMINISTRATORS
HIGHER EDUCATION
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE ADULT
EDUCATION WORKING GROUP AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS CREEL SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS HAVE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TELL THE VOTE I SEE SEE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEMS NINETY
SIX NINETY SIX. AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO CALGARY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AND
ACTUALLY TO REDEVELOPMENT THE
SHOW FLOOR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO
IS BACK ON CONCURRENT AND
SENTIMENTS OF RESPECT LAST
RIVAL. THINGS FLOOR SINGERS
TURN BAKER BLOOM THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THOSE ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TALK ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A FILE
AND NINETY SEVEN FILE ITEM
NINETY EIGHT AB ONE FORTY THREE
BY MISS QUIRK SILVA CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS AND ARE TRYING
TO HOUSING DECLARING THAT WOULD
SEE THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MISS QUIRK SILVA.
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
ONE FORTY THREE. CREATE
FLEXIBILITY TO X. EXPEDITE THE
CREATION OF SHELTERS AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
SENATE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY. DEVELOPMENT UP TO AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY DAYS TO REVIEW
AS WELL AS ADD CO AUTHORS THIS
BILL WAS ALSO AMENDED TO ADD
EMERGENCY CLAUSE IN ORDER TO
ALLOW. ALAMEDA COUNTY WHO HAS A
PLAN AND FUNDING FOR PROJECT
UNDER THIS BILL READY TO MOVE
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK SILVA SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK LOCAL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
THOUGH. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE
SENATE AMENDMENTS. ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE AB ONE EIGHTY FIVE
CLERK READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTY FIVE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GRAYSON ANOTHER'S AND ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION RESTORATION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT PROMOTES SMARTER
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING ARE
REQUIRED IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO PARTICIPATE IN
JOINT MEETINGS WITH CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD MINUTES
IN THE SENATE WERE TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IBM. THANK YOU MISS
GRAYSON SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLUB LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS. PRESENT A VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED. AB ONE NINETY SEVEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
NINETY SEVEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER WEBER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO KINDERGARTEN DOCTOR
WEBER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB ONE NINE SEVEN
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS ONE NINE
SEVEN REQUIRES THAT EVERY
SCHOOL WITHIN A SCHOOL DISTRICT
OR CHARTER SCHOOL THAT SERVES
PRIMARY GRADES TO IMPLEMENT AT
LEAST ONE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM ON CAMPUS THE MEMBERS
TAKING IN THE SENATE WILL
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER RECESSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I FIFTY
THREE DOES TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM ONE ON ONE IS AB
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS AN
ACT OF THE RETAIL FOOD
FACILITIES GOING THERE TO SEE
THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY MR GARCIA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
A. B. THREE SEVEN SEVEN IS A
CLEAN A BILL TO LAST YEAR'S A.
B. SIX TWO SIX WHICH
ESTABLISHED. MICRO ENTERPRISE
HOME KITCHEN OPERATIONS THIS IS
A CLEAN. A BILL REQUIRES FIFTY
FOUR VOTES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I WILL. THING WAS GARCIA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLICK LOGIN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH THIS TAKES
FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DECIDE ABOUT. CLICK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL CALL VOTE I. SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS OR
CONCURRED IN. PASS RETAIN A
FILE I DON'T WANT TO THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE OH THREE AB THREE
NINETY SEVEN BY MISTER CHILD
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO AND OTHERS AN
ACTION TO DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE MR SHOUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AB
THREE NINETY SEVEN WILL REQUIRE
THE ANNUAL REPORTING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. OF
CONVICTION DATA RELATING TO
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
CANNABIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THINGS SHALL SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE WRONG NUMBER SO. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR. WHAT
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE. BRINGS US FIVE ONE
OF SIX AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
CALDERON AND ACTUALLY TO
INSURANCE MISTER CALDERON THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE TASK FORCE CAN BE
MINE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
SENTIMENTS ADDED SIX ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE TASK FORCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IN CURRENT AND SENTIMENTS.
THINGS CALDERON SENIOR
DISCUSSION BAY CLUB LEVEL THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS AT
A VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
A FATHER ONE OF SEVEN FILE ITEM
ONE OH EIGHT. IS AB SEVEN OH
ONE COVERAGE A SIMPLE SEVEN OH
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY EXONERATED PRISONERS.
DOCTOR WEBER YES MISTER SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS AB SEVEN OH ONE IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO FIND WHAT IS
CALLED REASONABLE HOUSING COSTS
AS UNDER THIS LAW. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENT WITH THE
SENATE AMENDMENT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CAR CLUB THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. ROSARIO
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSER ROLE HI
BUT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. A RESTORED TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE OH
NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE TEN
AB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. CARPOOL
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES AND ACTING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES MS REYES. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN ASSESSING OUR
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE HEALTH
SERVICES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AMENDMENTS TAKEN WERE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING IN NATURE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ADDRESS. SENIOR
DISCUSSION BAIT FOR GLOBAL ROLE
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THEM.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU
WHAT I SIXTY KNOWS ONE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM ONE ELEVEN IS AB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AN ACTUAL
INTO EDUCATION DATA. OUR AB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX IS BACK FROM
CURRENTS WILL HELP TO CLOSE THE
READING IS GAP MANY CHILDREN
DEMONSTRATE UPON AND ROMAN
KINDERGARTEN MEMBERS THE SENATE
WERE TAKEN RESPOND TO FEEDBACK
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
DATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK ABOUT.
THINGS ARE KALRA SENIOR
DISCUSSION BAKER CLUB IN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THERE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE. TELL
YOU WHAT I SEE SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE TWELVE. AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
BY MISTER LEVINE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY TO CANNABIS. THIS WILL
BE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
PROVIDES GREATER DEFINITION TO
THE SPECIALTY COTTAGE LICENSE
FOR CANNABIS GROWERS ARE SPECS
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK LIBERAL.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
OF. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL YOU ABOUT
AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN. AB NINE
THIRTY ONE BY MS
BOERNER HORVATH. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THIRTY ONE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BOARDS
BOERNER HORVATH YES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AS YOU
ALL KNOW WOMEN HAVE FACED
DISCRIMINATION AND POLITICAL
SPACES AND AB NINE THIRTY ONE
IS NARROWLY TAILORED TO ADDRESS
THIS HISTORICAL INEQUITY SENATE
AMENDMENT TO RESTRUCTURE THE
BILL TO PREVENT BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS FROM BEING
COMPRISED EXCLUSIVELY LARGELY
OF ONE GENDER IDENTITY AND IT.
REQUIRES THIS OF NUMBER WOMAN
MEMBERS AND MAKE HIM FORMING
AND TECHNICAL CHANGES EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY ONE OF THE WOMEN'S.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS PRIORITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS BERHARAP.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CLERK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT
ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN I GOT AHEAD OF MYSELF WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK ONE ITEM TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN THAT IS
AB NINE ONE SEVEN BY MISS REYES
CLERK WILL READ AS SOME PEOPLE
NINE SEVENTEEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER REYES AND ACTUALLY THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME THIS RACE YOU
MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL ENSURES A VICTIMS OF A
CRIME FOR THE PURPOSES OF
OBTAINING YOU VISA AND TV'S A
CERT RECEIVE ALL PROPER
DOCUMENTATION WITHIN TIMELY
MANNER THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I MEMBERS
TAKEN SENATE WERE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MS
RAISING THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
NUMBERS. RESERVE A RENTAL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE. ALL
MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE. KIRK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
EYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS THREE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WANNA PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTEEN THROUGH
ONE SEVENTEEN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN. AB FORTINO
SEVEN CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY TO
VEHICLES. MS FREEMAN YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FORTINO SEVEN
STRENGTHENS OUR LAWS GOVERNING
RECKLESS DRIVING AND STREET
RACING WHICH BECOME HUGE AND
GROWING PROBLEMS ALL ACROSS OUR
STATE BY REQUIRING A THIRTY DAY
IMPOUNDED VEHICLE FOR
SUBSEQUENT CONVICTIONS THAT'S
ON THE SECOND CONVICTION. AND
THE REMOVAL OF ALL ILLEGAL
MODIFICATIONS ONCE THAT CAR IS
RELEASED A MOMENT TAKEN IN THE
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AND SIMPLY CLARIFY THE
EMPOWERMENT PROCESS THIS IS A
BALANCED APPROACH TO A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE IT PROTECTS DUE
PROCESS FOR DRIVERS AND
INTEREST FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
COURTS TO WEIGH THE IMPACT THE
BOTTOM HALF. OF EMPOWERMENT ON
A FAMILY. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE THANK YOU. FAMOUS
FREQUENCY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CARPOOL OF THE ROLE
REVERSAL. DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF OUT.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SELLING MEMBER
GLORIA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO BUSINESS. MR GLORIA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AT
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN IS BACK
FROM A SET DOWN CONCURRENCE
SENATE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
NUMBER ONE AUTHORIZING A
COUNTIES THE RECEIPT TO RECEIVE
HALF OF THE WHAT PENALTY AND
UNFAIR COMPETITION CASE IF THEY
PARTICIPATE IN PRE LITIGATION
INVESTIGATIVE SIR OF
INVESTIGATION OF THE CASE
NUMBER TWO DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK I'VE OF.
THINGS WERE IN SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OF A CAR CLUB ON THE
ROLE. THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE. WELL
CLOSER ALL T<c.cyan> WELL AS FIFTY</c>
NO SEVENTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARKAN CURTAIN. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY IS AB FIVE NINETY FOUR
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. MR STYLUS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB FIVE NINE
FOUR DEALS WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE GETTING US BETTER
READY FOR THE FUTURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE OF SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THEY WERE SELL
SENIORS QUESTION OF A LOCAL OF
THE ROLE. IS OUT OF OUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY. QUIRK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT
I SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS AND FOLLOW ORDER THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE AB
SEVEN AWAIT CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY THE TRAFFIC VIOLATORS
SCHOOL MR FRAZIER YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SEVEN A WAYS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE. FROM THE
SENATE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL. THANKS FOR YOUR SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OF A CORE GLOBAL
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO THEM. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. IT IS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL
CLOSER ROLE TELL A VOTE I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARKAN CURTAIN PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE. AB NINE
SIXTY TWO CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO HOSPITALS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB NINE SIXTY TWO IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE MOMENTS
TAKEN THE SENATE ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION UNDER THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT WITH THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING ADVICE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE BEST
METHODS TO INCREASE PROCUREMENT
WITH DIVERSE SUPPLIERS WITH IN
THE- HOSPITAL INDUSTRY. THIS
MET THIS IS A MEASURE THAT WILL
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY REGARDING
HOSPITAL CURRENT PRACTICES
WHILE ALSO PROMOTING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STATE
DIVERSE SUPPLIERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST WE CAN
CURSE SENATE IMMANENCE. FAMOUS
FOR. SENIOR DISCUSSION BAKER
CLUB ROLL. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FORTY
FOUR KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
FOUR. AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND I TRYING TO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MISTER GLORIA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWELVE
THIRTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENT SENATE MINUTES
REMOVED ACQUIREMENT TO MAINTAIN
AFFORDABILITY FOR UP TO TEN
YEARS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. NAME IS GLORIA
ST NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CORD
BLOOD IN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WELL.
CULTURAL TYLER AS FIFTY THREE
KNOWS THREE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FIVE A. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN. APPROPRIATE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER NAZARIAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING DEVELOP PURSUANT TO
EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND FOURTEEN
NINETEEN TO CONSIDER THE MERITS
OF UTILIZING A NOR ON DOOR
SYSTEM FOR ASSESSING OLDER
ADULTS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND CARE GIVERS TO OBTAIN
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND TIMELY
REFERRALS TO COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE CONSIDERATION OF A
UNIVERSAL TOOL AND PROCESS THAT
IS CAPABLE OF ASSESSING
INDIVIDUAL NEED FOR LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK MISSION IN THIS
AREA AND SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE OR CLUB IN THE WRONG.
THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELEPHONE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WARNER PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY. PASS RETAIN A FILE
ON ONE TWENTY EIGHT. DOCTOR
WOULD HAS THREE ITEMS STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE.
AB ONE SEVENTY FOUR CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY FOUR
BY FAMILY MEMBER WOULD ACTUALLY
TO HEALTH CARE. DOCTOR WITH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MEMBERS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WE CREATED
THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE SUBSIDIES
THE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WITH
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES AT OR BELOW
6100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. AB ONE SEVENTY FOUR WILL
ENSURE WE REVIEW THE ENROLLMENT
FIGURES COLLECTED BY COVER
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF THESE
NEW STATE SUBSIDIES BUT ALSO
INCLUDES A TECHNICAL FIX TO RUN
ITS CODE SECTION IN
CORPORATIONS CODA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THE ACT
WOULD SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLICK OVER THE ROLE. IT IS OUR
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
SERVER. KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I SIX FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MR COOLEY IS
READY TO TAKE UP THE FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. AB FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE QUIRK REYES ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN NINETY ONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND I
PLAN TO THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. MR COOLEY COLLARS
AND PLEASE RING BACK A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE WHICH
RELATES TO THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND OVERSIGHT OF
INSURANCE POLICY NATIONWIDE TO
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS. OF THE
SENATE MEMBERS JUST OR MINOR
REMEMBERS FOR FINDING THE
BILL'S COSTS OUR REGION I VOTE.
THANKS MR COOLEY SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A CORPS CORPORAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF. RESERVE AT ALL
MEMBERS UNDESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
THE. IT IS OUT OF THE CLERK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLES HOWEVER I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN
HOUSE RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. I THINK I ALREADY
DID THAT. WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY. THIS IS F. I ONE
THIRTY AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE.
ASSEMBLY WILL LIVE IN SEVENTY
FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL DOCTOR WOULD
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE IS A TWO
PART BILL THAT WOULD IMPROVE
HOW MEDI CAL MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM FUNCTIONS SENATE
AMENDMENTS WOULD IMPROVE CARE
COORDINATION AND TREATMENT BY
REQUIRING THE EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATIONABOUT PEOPLE BEING
TREATED BY SEPARATE PLANS. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH A
TIME FRAME THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ISSUE A DECISION
WHEN THERE IS AN UNRESOLVED
DISPUTE BETWEEN A COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN AND A MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLAN. I ASK YOUR
AYE THOUGH. THANK ADEQUATE
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. SORRY ABOUT.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN AND
FINALLY THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO. ASSEMBLY WILL SIXTEEN
FORTY TWO BY SELLING MEMBER
WOULD ACTUALLY MEDI CAL DOCTOR
WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBER THIS YEAR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR RELEASED TO
CRITICAL OUT ITS OF THE MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ENHANCE THE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BY INCREASING THE
PENALTIES FOR DIFFERENT TYPES
OF MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS.
THEY ALSO REQUIRE DH CS TO
EVALUATE AND DETERMINE WHETHER
PLANS ALTERNATE ACCESS REQUESTS
FOR A LONGER TIME AND DISTANCE
STANDARD IS REASONABLE TO
EXPECT THE A BENEFICIARY TO
TRAVEL IN ADDITION THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE PLANS TO ASSIST
THE PATIENT. TO FIND A CLOSER
PHYSICIAN SPECIALIST WHEN A
PATIENT HAS TO TRAVEL A GREAT
DISTANCE I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE OF THE SENATE MET.
AFTER I VOTE. EIGHT A SENIOR
DISCUSSION BAKER CLUB IN THE
ROLE MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS UNDESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU
WHAT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE TO ALLOW MISS
CARILLO TO TAKE UP A COUPLE OF
ITEMS. STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE. AB FIVE FIVE SIX
CROCKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIVE SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
CARILLO AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES THIS CARILLO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
FIVE FIVE SIX IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKE TAKE IN IN THE SENATE ARE
TO ADD CO AUTHORS TO THE BILL
RESPECT THE REQUEST AND I VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE COR
CLUB IN THE WRONG. DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRED OF
L. CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
WHAT I SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN AND
NOW THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE OH
SEVEN. AB SEVENTY THREE
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT. MISS CARILLO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
SIX SEVEN THREE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCY AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND REINSTATED THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S ALREADY TO
PURSUE A BUREAU. THE FIELD
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION FOR
WHICH WAGE CLAIM PENALTIES
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE WAS CREEL SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF A CORE GLOBAL
ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT EYES
FORTY SIX NEWS SIXTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
IN THE FILE TO MISTER MCCARTY'S
ITEMS. BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO. WHICH IS AB SIX
SIXTY ONE QUICK RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND ACTUALLY IN
A NON VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I STARTED THIS DEBATE
FIVE HOURS AGO BUT HERE WE ARE
NOW THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
RELATED TO OUR AIR QUALITY
AFTER THE NEW NORMAL AND FORCE
ME WITH WILD FIRES ON
CONCURRENCE ASK YOUR I DON'T
THINK YOU. THANKS MISS
REGARDING SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLE TIE THE I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO CENTER MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. AND NOW MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MISTER MCCARTY.
SO DID WE DISPENSE WITH FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN MISTER MAKER
YEAH THE ONE. THIS MCCARTY WE
DO INDEED NEED TO DISPENSE WITH
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN. AB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT CLICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO RESOURCE
CONSERVATION MR MCCARTY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A
CONCURRENT VOTE RELATE TO OUR
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
ENSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS ON
PROBATION AND PAROLE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. AND
RECLAIM THEIR LIVES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE
OH NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
OH NINE AB SEVEN TEN RECOVERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TEN BY SOME
REMEMBER CERVANTES AND ACTUALLY
THE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MR VARGAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB SEVEN
TEN ONE SURE ACCURATE HOUSING
COSTS DATA THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF
THE ACTUAL FOUGHT FINANCIAL
NEED OF THE STUDENT AFTER
INSTITUTION. I MEMBERS TAKING
IN THE SENATE PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR INSTITUTIONS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AIBO ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
RESTAURANT S. C. NO DISCUSSION
OF A CORE GLOBAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESERVE A CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE. TELEPHONE I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT A
RECONSIDERATION. FILE ITEMS.
ONE THIRTY SIX ONE THIRTY SEVEN
AND ONE THIRTY EIGHT. WILL BE
CONTINUED. ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY
NINE. THROUGH ONE FORTY FOUR.
PASS RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY FIVE. HR SIXTY FOUR
BY MISS SMITH CLERK WILL READ
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER SMITH AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CIVIL RIGHTS MISS
SMITH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS HR SIXTY FOUR
RECOGNIZE TAIWAN'S HISTORIC
PASSAGE OF SAME SEX MARRIAGE
LAWS AND RESPECTFULLY URGES THE
RECOGNITION OF HUMAN AND CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
AROUND THE WORLD. PASSED IN MAY
TWENTY NINETEEN TAIWAN'S
LEGISLATION MAKES IT THE FIRST
IN ASIA TO LEGALIZE MARRIAGE
FOR SAME SEX COUPLES TAIWAN HAS
SERVED AS A LEADER IN LGBT Q.
RIGHTS THEIR ANNUAL PRIDE
PARADE IN TAIPEI HAS FOSTERED
AN INTERNATIONAL LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. GLOBALLY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMUNITY CONTINUE TO FACE
LONG STANDING DISCRIMINATION
AND PUNISHMENT H. R. SIXTY FOUR
WITH A FIRM CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AT HOME AND ABROAD.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH MR GLORIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
APPRECIATION OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA CLARITA FOR HER
BRINGING FORWARD THIS ITEM INTO
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION EIGHT A MEASURE THE
KICKED OFF YEARS OF COMPLEX
HEARINGS AND UNWAVERING
ACTIVISM. THAT SAME YEAR
THOUSANDS MARCHED IN SAN DIEGO
FOR MILES TO PROTEST ANTI SAME
SEX MARRIAGE LEGISLATION. I
RAISE THESE STORIES BECAUSE THE
PATH TO MEANINGFUL LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES DIFFICULT AND IT'S
DEMANDING EXPERIENCE AND
WITNESS FIRST HAND MY COMMITTEE
THE STRENGTH IT TAKES TO
ACCOMPLISH THESE HUMAN RIGHTS.
THAT'S WHY WE MUST CELEBRATE
THESE VALUABLE MOMENTS OF
TRANSFORMATION IN OUR COMMUNITY
AT HOME AND OVERSEAS AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF RECOGNIZING.
THIS LANDMARK LEGISLATION
PASSED BY TAIWAN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. FAMOUS
GLORIA. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE H.
R. MS SMITH YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH AND WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHOR SOME FOR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THEY
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FOR SHALL BE ABLE FOR CO
AUTHORS CLICK OPEN RIGHT. THIS
IS FOR TOLL AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLICK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY THREE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. AND
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SIX.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
AND TAKE UP SUPPORT SUPPORT.
MEASURES AGAIN THESE ARE
SUPPORT SUPPORT. AND WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM'S ITEM. ITEM
TWO FIFTY FOUR SB SIX FIFTY ONE.
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR GLAZER AND ACTUALLY TO
DISCOVERY. OKAY AND YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB
SIX FIFTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR GLAZER SB SIX FIFTY ONE
WOULD ALLOW ALL DEFENDANTS
CONVICTED OF SERIOUS VIOLENT
CRIMES AND SENTENCED TO FIFTEEN
YEARS OR MORE TO MAKE A MOTION
FOR DISCOVERY. I PERSONALLY
SPENT YEARS OF MY CAREER
WORKING FOR THE FREEDOM OF A
MAN WHO WAS ON DEATH ROW FOR A
CRIME HE DIDN'T COMMIT HE GOT
THE EVIDENCE THAT LED TO HIS
WALKING FREE BY ACCIDENT. BY
PURE COINCIDENCE SOMEBODY HEARD
HIS STORY ASK FOR THE DOCUMENTS
GOT THEM AND WE WATCHED HIM
WALK OUT A FREE MAN. IT
SHOULDN'T BE IN ACCIDENTS THAT
THOSE THEY DON'T DESERVE TO BE
INCARCERATED REMAIN
INCARCERATED. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
SITTING IN OUR PRESENT THEY
WANT THAT SAME CHANCE TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THE EVIDENCE
WILL EXONERATE THEM. SB SIX
FIFTY ONE RECOGNIZES THIS
JUSTIN DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK THE
FIRST TIME. AND WE AS A
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT'S WHY WE PASSED AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY LAST
YEAR WHICH EXPANDED POST
CONVICTION MOTION TO DISCOVERY
TWO DEFENDANTS CONVICTED OF
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT CRIMES. AND
SENTENCED TO FIFTEEN YEARS OR
MORE BEGINNING ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE BILL
HOWEVER ONLY APPLIED PRO
SPECTER PLEA TO FUTURE CASES.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS MEANT THAT
ANYONE CONVICTED PRIOR TO
TWENTY NINETEEN COULD NOT MAKE
A MOTION FOR DISCOVERY. SB SIX
FIFTY ONE ALLOWS THE PROVISIONS
OF AB NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN TO
APPLY RETROACTIVELY TO CASES
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN. DISCOVERY PROVIDES
DEFENDANTS WITH THE DOCUMENTS
AND MATERIALS RELATING TO THEIR
CASE AFTER THEY HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF A QUALIFYING
CRIME. THIS CAN BE HELPFUL FOR
INNOCENT PEOPLE THAT ARE
SERVING TIME FOR CRIMES THEY
DID NOT COMMIT. I JUDGE STILL
HAS TO GRANT THE MOTION FOR
DISCOVERY AND IF NEEDS MUST
HAVE A STRONG CASE FOR NEEDING
THE INFORMATION. SPECIFICALLY
THE MOST STRAIGHT THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY MADE A GOOD FAITH THAT
TO OBTAIN ALL RELEVANT
DOCUMENTS. THROUGH OTHER
AVENUES. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND YOU KNOW
BUT AS WE KNOW. THE SYSTEM
NEEDS THE TYPE CHECKS AND
BALANCES. THE BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA IN IT. THE
ACLU. CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
GROUPS DEDICATED. TO PROTECTING
THE PARTIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU OKAY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON
THE ROLE. NUMBER SERVICE OUT OF
THEM. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS A
DESIRABLE CLERK WILL. CLOSER
ALL KIND OF A- AYE AYES SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS THERE IS ONE ITEM WE
NEED TO GO BACK AND PICK UP ON
THE CONCURRENCE VIOLENCE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE A. B. EIGHT FORTY
KERKORIAN. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY BY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DALLY AND ACTUALLY THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. MR GRAY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB EIGHT FORTY IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE MEMBERS THIS IS
A BILL RELATED COUNTY RESORT
CASINO IN LAKE TAHOE THE
AMENDMENTS WERE REQUESTED BY
THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
AND- ARE CLARIFYING IN NATURE
AT UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASKS A- FOR YOUR
SUPPORT CONCURRENCE. THANK WAS
GREAT SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE OUT OF COURT
GLOBAL ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIX
NINE OH ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK SENATE
THIRD READING SUPPORT SUPPORT
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE SB THREE OH
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE OH FIVE BY A
CENTER HUESO AND ARE GOING TO
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. MR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE OH FIVE ALSO
KNOWN AS RYAN'S ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HUESO. MEMBERS RYAN
BARTEL WAS JUST FORTY TWO YEARS
OLD WHEN HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
PANCREATIC CANCER HE MERELY
SOUGHT CONVENTIONAL TREATMENTS
OF RADIATION CHEMOTHERAPY BUT
THE CANCER HAD SPREAD
THROUGHOUT HIS ENTIRE BODY.
FINALLY A FAMILY FRIEND
RECOMMENDED MEDICAL CANNABIS
VIS A VIS CVD OIL AND THE
CHANGES WERE REMARKABLE. MINE
WAS ALERT AND SPEAKING WITH HIS
FAMILY AND YOUNG SON HE WAS IN
GOOD SPIRITS HAD AN APPETITE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN WEEKS.
HOWEVER SADLY THIS WAS SHORT
LIVED. TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS
IN DEEP SUFFERING WHO RECEIVED
CARE IN CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES ARE DENIED ACCESS TO
MEDICAL CANNABIS. RIGHTS FAMILY
WAS FORCED TO SEARCH FOR WEEKS
FOR OUR SOCIETY TO WOULD ALLOW
HIM TO USE HIS CBD OIL TO HELP
MANAGE HIS PAIN EFFECTIVELY.
FINALLY AFTER WEEKS OF
SEARCHING A FACILITY IN
WASHINGTON STATE ALLOWED WANTED
TO CONTINUE USING HIS CB THE
OIL. BUT SADLY FINALLY LIVED IF
YOU WILL SHORT MORE WEEKS
DESPITE THE FACT THE
CALIFORNIANS PASSED PROPOSITION
TWO FIFTEEN AUTHORIZING MEDICAL
CANNABIS OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO
HOSPITALS IN THIS STATE DO NOT
ALLOW ITS USE BY PATIENTS ON
HOSPITAL PREMISES. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CLOSE THAT GAP BY
ALLOWING THOSE WHO ARE MOST IN
NEED COMPASSION AT THE END OF
LIFE TO HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS IF THEY POSSESS A
RECOMMENDATION. BY THEIR
PHYSICIAN LIKE TO KNOW THAT
SMOKING OF MARIJUANA IN
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES IS
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED.
COLLEAGUES IF PASSED CALIFORNIA
WILL JOIN CONNECTICUT MAINE NEW
YORK AND NEW YORK AND GRANTING
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CANNABIS AT
MEDICAL FACILITIES. ON BEHALF
OF RYAN AND HIS FAMILY WHO ARE
WATCHING. THIS ONLINE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE-
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS
OUR DEVOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE I
SIXTY SIX NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SB THREE. FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY FOUR SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT
SENATOR DORADO AND ACT IN THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES. THE
STRESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
SB THREE NINETY EIGHT UPDATES
CALIFORNIA LAW REGARDING THE
STATE AGENCY CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING AND ADVOCATING FOR
THE RIGHTS OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES TO REFLECT RECENT
UPDATES TO FEDERAL REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL ALSO SPECIFICALLY
CLARIFIES THAT THE MEANING OF
FACILITY OR PROGRAM INCLUDES A
FACILITY USED TO HOUSE OR
DETAIN NON CITIZENS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF SUCH CIVIL
IMMIGRATION CUSTODY. SUSTAINING
THIS ACCESS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN LIGHT OF THE
REPORT FROM EARLIER THIS YEAR I
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
REGARDING THE TREATMENT OF
PERSONS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND
OTHER DISABILITIES IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION. AMONG
OTHER FINDINGS THAT REPORT
FOUND INADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND MEDICAL CARE FOR
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES MADE
ALL THE WORSE BY THE FACILITIES
COUNTER THERAPEUTIC CONDITIONS
AND PRACTICES. IT ALSO FOUND
SIGNIFICANT UNDER REPORTING OF
THE NUMBER OF SUICIDE ATTEMPTS
THAT OCCUR AT ADELANTO. THIS
MEASURES UNOPPOSED AND HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THROUGH THE SENATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER AS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROOM. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SB THREE FIFTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY EIGHT
BY THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION AND ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION MISTER FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB THREE
FIFTY EIGHT. IS THE ANNUAL
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE ON
THIS BILL. THIS BILL MAKES NON
CONTROVERSIAL AND NON POLICY
CHANGES TO THE SECTIONS OF LARA
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION HE
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. THANK YOU
MISTER FRAZIER SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALENT
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES BY LIGHT IN
ONE SEVENTY TWO SB THREE NINETY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN
BY SENATOR GLAZER ACTUALLY THE
TRANSIT OPERATORS MISS SMITH
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN
BY SENATOR GLAZER WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE A PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATOR TO ALLOW PASSENGERS TO
BOARD A TRANSIT VEHICLE WITH
THEIR PETS WHEN EVACUATION
ORDER IS ISSUED. IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE IN CONSULTATION
WITH PUBLIC TRANSIT OPERATORS
AND COUNTY EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
OFFICIALS TO DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES FOR ALLOWING PETS ON
A PUBLIC TRANSIT VEHICLE IN AN
EVACUATION SITUATION THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
SMITH SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE. TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN HOW YOU VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY THREE SB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ. A FOUR
EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR UMBERG
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE MILITARY
BASE EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAN SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I PERCENT SB
EIGHT FORTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR UMBERG THE BILL MAKES
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
INVESTIGATOR. PROCESS WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO STREAMLINE
COMPLAINT. WHISTLE BLOWING AND
PREVENT REPRISALS AND
RETALIATION AGAINST
WHISTLEBLOWERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL SPONSORED BY THE NATIONAL
GUARD WITHOUT ANY OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL LOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT SB SIX THIRTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TAXATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR. MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER EACH YEAR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS IN OUR
SHELTERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
EXPERTS AGREE THAT SPAY AND
NEUTER PROGRAMS ARE AMONG THE
MOST EFFECTIVE METHODS FOR
REDUCING ANIMAL HOMELESSNESS
AND PAT OVERPOPULATION SB SIX
THIRTY ONE WILL CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE AND LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO THE FUND
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THAT WILL OPEN THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY ONE SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AND ACTUALLY TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE MR QUIRK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX. WILL ALLOW HAZARDOUS WASTE
TO BE RE USED THIS BILL HAD HAS
HAD UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED A PAST IN
BERLIN FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED
FILE ITEM TWO OH NINE SB ONE
FIFTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY MEDI
CAL STAR MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THE MENACE BEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE PRESENT SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY FOUR AUTHORED BY
SENATOR PAN. SB ONE FIVE FOUR
WILL MAKE SILVER DIME IN
FLORIDA STF AND AVAILABLE
DENTAL TREATMENT FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN. PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES IN ADULTS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
RECEIVING SERVICES UNDER
MEDICARE. STF IS A TOPICAL
MEDICATION USE A SLOW DOWN OR
STOP DOWN THE QUE IN BOTH BABY
A PERMANENT TEETH THE SERVER
KILL THE BACTERIA STOPS THE
BACK HERE FROM GROWING. THE
FLUORIDE RE MINERALIZED AS OUR
HEARTS TO STRUCTURE SB ONE
FIFTY FOUR IS RECEIVED BY
PARTISAN SUPPORTERS RECEIVE NO
NO VOTES ASK YOUR RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER MAYES SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS SO
TWO THIRDS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
EYES SIXTY SEVEN NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES. THE RIVER FILE
ITEM NUMBER TO TWENTY EIGHT SP
THREE NINETY THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
BY SENATOR UMBERG ACTUALLY
SCHOOL SAFETY THIS RODRIGUEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY BY OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA ANA. THROUGH FOURTEEN
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED. UNDER CURRENT
LAW ONLY SCHOOL SECURITY
PERSONNEL THAT WORK MORE THAN
TWENTY HOURS PER WEEK RECEIVE
TRAINING DEVELOPED BY THE
STATE. AS A RESULT THOUSANDS OF
PART TIME SCHOOL SECURITY
EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY DO NOT
RECEIVE THE TRAINING. THE
TRAINING QUESTION PROVIDES AN
OVERVIEW OF SEVERAL CRITICAL
AREAS SUCH AS ROTH BOTH AND
RESPONSIBILITIES LAWS AND
LIABILITY SECURITY AWARENESS
MEDIATION CONFLICT RESOLUTION.
DISASTERS AND EMERGENCIES AND
STUDENT BEHAVIOR. THIS BROWN'S
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AND NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION. RESPECT US
RIVAL THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES BY LIGHT IN
TWO THIRTY SEVEN SB FIVE
NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ACTUALLY
TO HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES. DOCTOR
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
REMEMBERS SB FIVE NINETEEN
ALLOWS THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
DISTRIBUTE FUNDS FROM THE SITE
CLEANUP. SUB ACCOUNT PROGRAM TO
WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICTS
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL. THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION I ASK YOU
ARRIVE A. THANK YOU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
I SIXTY SEVEN NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
FORTY FIVE SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACTUALLY IN
CLINICAL TRIALS MISTER WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE PERCENT SB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE BY SENATOR JACKSON OF THE
BILL THAT CONFORMS CALIFORNIA
LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW PERTAINING
TO HEALTHCARE CVERAGE FOR
ROUTINE PATIENT COSTS RELATED
TO CLINICAL TRIALS. THE IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TOOK PROACTIVE STEPS
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE SERVICES BY
INCLUDING COVERAGE OF CLINICAL
TRIAL PARTICIPATION COSTS. IN
FEDERAL STATUTE THIS EXPANSION
OF THE FEDERAL STATUTES CREATED
KEY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW. SB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE ADDRESSES THESE
DIFFERENCES BY INCORPORATING
PROTECTIONS FROM THE FEDERAL
LAW WHILE STILL RETAINING
EXISTING CRITICAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ALREADY IN STATE
LAW. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
EXPANDS COVERAGE OF CLINICAL
TRIALS PARTICIPATION COSTS.
FROM BERMAN CANCER JUST CANCER
TO INCLUDE OTHER LIFE
THREATENING DISEASES LIKE
DIABETES PROHIBITS CARRIES FROM
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST DID NINE
LIMITING OR IMPOSING ADDITIONAL
CONDITIONS ON COVERAGE FOR
POKE. ABOUT PEOPLE ELIGIBLE.
AND STILL PRESERVING THE
ACQUIREMENT THE CLINICAL TRIALS
FROM NON PARTICIPATING
PROVIDERS BE COVERED.
COLLEAGUES IS COMMONSENSE
CONSUMER THE COME SINCE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS MEASURE IS
REDUCE RECEIVE NO NO VOTES
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
TWO FIFTY EIGHT SB SEVEN NINETY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY ONE BUT THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT AND
FINANCE AN ACTOR IN A TAXATION
OCCURRING THERE AND SEE THEIR
UP TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISS BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
HERE MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
OF THE LAST THIRTY YEARS THE
COUNTY ASSESSORS AND AIRLINES
HAVE FOUGHT CONSTANTLY OVER.
COMMERCIAL AIRCRAFT PROPERTY
TAX ASSESSMENTS SB SEVEN NINETY
ONE AN AXE A NEW CONSENSUS
SOLUTION DEVELOP BY BOTH
ASSESSORS AND AIRLINES. AS PART
OF THE SOLUTION THE BILL
CREATES A NEW FORMULA THAT
MEASURES ALL OF THE TIME
AIRCRAFT SPENDS IN THE STATE
DURING THE ENTIRE YOU'RE- NOT
JUST ONE WEEK UNDER CURRENT
LAW. SB SEVEN NINETY ONE THEN
ALLOCATES AIRCRAFT I YOU TO
EACH COUNTY WHERE AIRCRAFT COME
AND GO BY MEASURING THE TIME ON
THE GROUND AND EACH AIRPORT.
INCOMING AND OUTGOING FLIGHT
TIMES AND NUMBER OF DEPARTURES
THE BILL ALSO IMPROVED
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN AIRLINES
IN ASSESSORS. ALLOWS AIRLINES
TO FILE A SINGLE PROPERTY
STATEMENT WITH THE LEAD
ASSESSOR AND BRINGS MORE
CERTAINTY TO THE AUDIT PROCESS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISS BURKE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NEWS THERE
ON THE URGENCY EYES SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS THERE ON THE BILL THIS
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY TWO SB SEVENTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR UMBERG AND
ACTUALLY THE CIVIL ACTIONS MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB SEVENTEEN
BY SENATOR UMBERG WHICH AIMS TO
AND ABUSIVE PRACTICES IN CIVIL
DISCOVERY THAT BOG DOWN OUR
STATE COURTS THIS BILL ALLOWS
FOR PARTIES TO HAVE AN EARLY
EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION IF THEY
STIPULATE TO SUCH A
REQUIREMENT. PARTY'S ROUGH TO
UPDATE DISCLOSURES IN ANY
DISCOVERY RESPONSES WITH NEWLY
OBTAINED OR INADVERTENTLY
ADMITTED INFORMATION IF THE
PARTIES STIPULATE TO THE FIRST
PROVISION OF THIS SPELL THE
ROLE TWENTY SIX PROVISION. THE
SECOND REVISION REQUIRE COURTS
PURSUANT TO A PARTY'S MOTION TO
OPPOSE A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR SANCTION ON A PARTY
PERSON OR ATTORNEY WHO FAIL TO
ACT IN GOOD FAITH WITH RESPONSE
TO A REQUEST FOR DOCUMENTS. THE
COURT MAKES USE SANCTIONS OF
THE COURT MAKES WRITTEN
FINDINGS THAT THE PARTY ACTED
WITH SUBSTANTIAL JUSTIFICATION
OR THE OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE MAKES
THE IMPOSITION OF THE SANCTIONS
ON JUST. MEMBERS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL AND
SOME OF THE DISCOVERY
GAMESMANSHIP THAT IS CLOGGING
UP OUR STATE COURT SYSTEM THIS
BILL HAS NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY ONE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
BY LED HIM TO SIXTY NINE S.
OAK. VIOLATED TO SIXTY FIVE SB
THIRTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR CHIANG AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AGAIN. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR CHIANG WHICH WILL RE
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE. TO COMBAT TRACK
TRAFFICKING AND SLAVERY IN
ORDER TO FIND A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO PREVENT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. CALIFORNIA WITH
ITS PORTS AIRPORTS IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO INTERNATIONAL
BORDERS UNFORTUNATELY HAS HIGH
RATES OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ACTIVITY. DESPITE YEARS OF
DETERMINED EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND SLAVERY
THERE ARE STILL A CRIME IN OUR
STATE STRUGGLES WITH. SB THIRTY
FIVE WILL RECONVENE THIS TASK
FORCE STOP ADVANCE THE STATE'S
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SUPPRESSION
STRATEGY. THIS TASK FORCE WILL
LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR A
PREVALENCE STE STUDY FOR OUR
STATE AND WE CAN USE THIS DATA
TO CREATE INNOVATIVE AND
EFFECTIVE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SUPPRESSION STRATEGIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND JOIN ME IN VOTING
AYE ON SB THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MR GABRIEL SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO THE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY KNOWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY NINE SB SIXTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ACTUALLY TAXATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER STUDENTS WHO WERE
ATTENDED FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
WHO HAVE CLOSER DOORS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED WITH LITTLE TO NO
WARNING OF THE IMPENDING
CLOSURES LEAVING THEM NO TIME
TO MAKE ANY FORM OF
ACCOMMODATIONS THEY'VE SPENT
YEARS OF THEIR LIVES WORKING
TOWARDS A DEGREE. PLACING
THEMSELVES IN DEBT. X. SB SIXTY
THREE WOULD REMOVE TAX
LIABILITY PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF TO STUDENTS OR NO FAULT
FOR THE FAMILIES OF THEIR
COLLEGE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALENT
BY VOTE I SEVENTY KNOWS THERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES BY LEADING
TO SEVENTY FOUR SB ONE THIRTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION. MYSTERY OF US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SO SB ONE THIRTY
SEVEN REDUCES THE DUPLICATIVE
FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES BY
EXPANDING CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
PROGRAM TO EXCHANGE. FEDERAL
SERVICE TRANSPORTATION REVENUES
FOR STATE TRANSPORTATION
REVENUES SPECIFICALLY THIS
LEGISLATION EXPANDS THE MATCH
EXCHANGE PROGRAM TO OTHER THE
FEDERAL SERVICE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS WHERE THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED TO LOCAL
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE HIGHWAY
SAFETY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
LOCAL BRIDGE PROJECTS. THIS
THIS BILL SAVE TIME SAVE MONEY
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RESPECT
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER INVESTING IN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRED. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY NINE NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES BY LEADING TO
SEVENTY SEVEN SB ONE FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY BY SENATOR PELL AND
ACTUALLY STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOU MADAM SPEAKER
TODAY PRESENT SB ONE FIFTY BY
SENATOR BALLOT THIS BILL WILL
IMPROVE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH BY EXPANDING
THEIR- ACCESS TO IT. JP GRANT.
IT WILL ALSO REPLACE THE
EXISTING S. A. P. REQUIREMENT
WITH MORE FLEXIBLE STANDARDS
AND REQUIRE EACH SCHOOL TO
OFFER AN APPEALS PROCESS. IT'S
A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT WILL
HELP FOSTER YOU SUCCEED IN
COLLEGE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I'VE- THANK YOU
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
GO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. BY LATE IN TWO
EIGHTY FOUR SB ONE EIGHTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MORE LOCK AND ACTUALLY THE
JUDGES RETIREMENT MAKING
PREPARATION THERE FOR MISTER
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. YES
COLLEAGUES AND DELIGHTED BRING
THIS BILL TO YOU THIS DEALS
WITH A DEFERRAL OPTION FOR
JUDGES. JUDGES OF COURSE IN
RENDERING OPINIONS THAT'S
THERE'S A LOT OF STRESS AND
STRAIN THERE. UNDER THAT OF THE
KERR RETIREMENT SYSTEM IF A
JUDGE DECIDES FOR PERSONAL OR
HEALTH REASONS TO RETIRE EARLY.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE OPTION
MOST EMPLOYEES HAVE OF
DIFFERING THEIR RETIREMENT.
THIS SIMPLY CREATES A DEFERRAL
OPTION FOR JUDGES AS A PART OF
THEIR PUBLIC SERVICE
COMPENSATION PACKAGE. A GREAT
BILL ARE CHEN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER COOLEY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
BY LEADING TO EIGHTY EIGHT SB
TWO OWN NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL TWO OH NINE
BY SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY
THE WILDFIRES MR MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THE MENACE BEACON
MEMBERS SB TWO NINE BY SENATOR
DODD WOULD ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE FORECAST
AND THREAT INTELLIGENCE
INTEGRATION CENTER TO CONDUCT
FIRE WEATHER. FORECASTING
ALLOWS FOR ACCURATE WILD FIRE
RISK ASSESSMENT THREAT WARNING
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
WILDFIRE CHALLENGING
CALIFORNIA'S NECESSARY TO
DEVELOP BETTER FIRE WEATHER
FORECASTING AND WHILE FOR A
THREAT ASSESSMENT CAPABILITIES
AND CLEVERLY PREPARE INTEGRATED
STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH SUCH
THREATS THE SCRIPT IS WAY TOO
LONG SOME TO GO TO THE BOTTOM.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE IT IS SUPPORTED BY
FIRST RESPONDERS UTILITIES AND
MORE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR RIVAL. WE APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT HE DESIRED TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO NINETY ONE SB TWO
TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR JACKSON AND
ACTUALLY TO AGING THIS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER NUMBERS. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB ARE SORRY SB TWO
TWENTY EIGHT FOR SENATOR
JACKSON THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
FRAMEWORK FOR A MASTER PLAN ON
AGING. THAT EMPOWERS ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO AGE WITH
DIGNITY CHOICE AND
INDEPENDENCE. CURRENTLY 20% OF
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULTS LIVE
IN POVERTY. AND THAT POPULATION
WILL NEARLY DOUBLE BY TWENTY
THIRTY IN RESPONSE TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
ESTABLISH A MASTER PLAN ON
AGING SB TWO TWENTY EIGHT WILL
CONVENE A WORKING GROUP. IN
COORDINATION WITH VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS TO DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR JACKSON'S
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RAY S.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. THIRD WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE AYE SIXTY
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO NINETY TWO SB TWO
THIRTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT MISTER
GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB TWO THIRTY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR CABALLERO. WHICH WAS
SET THE FOUNDATION TO IMPROVE
TRAINING STANDARDS AND POLICIES
REGARDING POLICE OFFICERS USE
OF FORCE. AS A FORMER POLICE
OFFICER WHICH MANY OF YOU KNOW
MANY YOU MAY NOT KNOW THAT I
LOST MY PARTNER. OF IN THE LINE
OF DUTY. HE WAS KILLED. IN THE
LINE OF DUTY. HE WAS NOT ONLY
MY FRIEND. NOT ONLY MY PARTNER.
BUT HE WAS OUR BIG BROTHER OUR
STATION. AND HE WAS. TAKEN AWAY
FROM US. IN UNIFORM AS ALSO THE
FATHER OF TWO YOUNG MALES TO
AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUNG MALES I
WORRY DALY ABOUT THEIR SAFETY.
I WORRY ABOUT WHERE THEY GO THE
CONTACT IN WHICH THEY COME IN
CONTACT WITH YES ANYONE. THOSE
ARE REAL FEARS I LOVE MY VOICE
JUST LIKE. IT'S A WHICH ONE OF
YOU LOVE YOUR CHILDREN. WE MUST
BE ABLE TO COME TOGETHER. AND
FOCUS ON THE TRUE INTENT OF
THIS BILL TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF DAILY USE OF FORCE INCIDENTS
IN THIS STATE. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THE NATION
AND SET PRECEDENTS THAT X. STAB
US THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION. TWO ONE
THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUES FACING.
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA THIS COUNTRY
NEEDS REAL LEADERSHIP. ON THIS
ISSUE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO STAND
TOGETHER AND LEAD THE WAY BOTH
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
OFFICERS AND THEY THAT HAVE
TAKEN US OFFICE TO SERVE AND
PROTECT THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER
IS THAT WE KNOW THAT PLEASE
AGENCIES AND OFFICERS HAVE TO
DO A BETTER JOB. IN OUR
COMMUNITY. OFFICERS IN THEIR
SUPERVISORS NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
MINIMIZE LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN
MINIMIZE THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE. AND THAT THOSE OFFICERS
WHO CONTINUE. TO USE
UNNECESSARILY DEADLY FORCE. WE
HOPE THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
WEEDED OUT OF THIS PROFESSION
WE CAN NOT PAY THIS PROFESSION
WITH A BROAD BRUSH NO MORE CAN
WE PAINT THE BROAD BRUSH WOULD
BACK TEACHERS OR OR BUT PASTORS
OR DOCTORS OR LAWYERS. WE
CANNOT PAY THIS PROFESSION WITH
THAT SAME BRUSH. WE HAVE
RESEARCHED AND SURVEYED THE
MOSTEFFECTIVE METHODS PROVEN
TO REDUCE DEADLY FORCE SB TWO
THIRTY IS A EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH THAT FOCUS. THAT FOCUS
ON ADOPTING A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AND BEST PRACTICES
THAT HAS A PROVEN RESULTS. WE
TALK ABOUT WHAT SB TWO THIRTY
ACTUALLY DOES IT ECSTATIC THE
FIRST STATEWIDE GUIDELINES TO
CLEARLY IDENTIFY WHAT OFFICERS
AUTHORIZED TO USE FORCE. TO
REQUIRES THAT EVERY POLICE
OFFICER. EVERY SHERIFF DEPUTY.
EVERY PLEASE PERSON WHO PUT ON
A UNIFORM AND A BADGE RECEIVE
THE MOST ROBUST TRAINING IN THE
NATION STRICTLY DESIGNATED TO
REDUCE THE USE OF FORCE THREE
SET SPECIFIC POLICIES REQUIRED
TO DE ESCALATE. REPORTER
INTERPERSONAL COMMUNICATION
TRAINING AND TACTICAL METHODS
THAT USE TIME DISTANCE COVER
AND CONCEALMENT. NUMBER FOUR
REQUIRES IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT
BIASES AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAININGS. ESTABLISH A DETAIL
STAND RISE REQUIREMENTS FOR
REPORTING ALL INCIDENTS NGUYEN
USE OF FORCE IS USED. SPECIFIED
THAT USE OF FORCE POLICIES AND
TRAININGS ARE TO BE CONSIDERED
IN A COURT OF LAW. I'M US PAUSE
HERE AND APPRECIATE EVERY MAN
AND WOMAN IN UNIFORM.
INDIVIDUALS PUT ON A UNIFORM TO
SERVER PROTECT. THEY KISSED
THEIR CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES
GO BY AND SOMETIMES THAT MAY BE
THE VERY LAST TIME THAT THEY
SEE THEIR LOVED ONES EVER
THIRTY SECONDS. BECAUSE THEY DO
A HARD JOB. THEIR OFFICERS WHO
GO THROUGH THEIR ENTIRE CAREER
NOT EVEN FIRING THEIR WEAPONS.
TODAY SB TWO THIRTY. WE'LL
CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE IN
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS ALSO WANT
TO THANK DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER
THE AUTHOR OF A TWO NINETY
THREE ONE BECAUSE SHE HAVE
BROUGHT US INTO A CONVERSATION
THERE WE HAVE HAD ON THIS FLOOR
I DON'T WANT ALSO THINKS
THERE'S A COP RURAL FOR
BRINGING US TO THIS POINT
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT
I VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU MISTER GIPSON MISTER RAMOS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I CONCUR. WITH
THE- MY GENTLEMAN FROM THAT
JUST SPOKE RIGHT NOW BUT HE SAN
MARINO COUNTY WE JUST SEEN A
DEPUTY. GET INVOLVED AS SHE
RESPONDED TO A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CALL AND THEN WAS
ATTACKED WHILE SHE GOT THERE SO
WE SEE THAT THE PENDULUM HAS TO
BE AN AREA THAT WE TALK ABOUT
HERE ON THIS FLOOR. A FLOOR
THAT TALKS ABOUT TRAINING OF A
FLOOR THAT TALKS ABOUT
REASONABLE FORCE IN THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS BUT LET'S NOT FORGET
THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE OUT
THERE PROTECTING US DAY IN AND
DAY OUT. AB SB TWO THIRTY I'M A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE DISCUSSION
HERE ON THE FLOOR. NOT TO GO
TOO FAR ONE WAY OR TOO FAR THE
OTHER WAY WHEN WE SEE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS RESPONDING
TO CALLS AND THEN GETTING.
ASSAULTED WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT WE BELIEVE
IN WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
PROTECTING OUR CONSTITUENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL GOES TO THE TRAINING THE
TRAINING THAT'S OUT THERE BUT
LET'S NOT FORGET. THE TRAINING
THAT ALSO HAS TO BE DONE FOR
THE EDUCATIONAL PROCESSES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES TO SHOW THAT
WHEN WE CALL NINE ONE ONE AND
THOSE FIRST RESPONDERS IT
RESPOND THAT WE ARE STANDING UP
ALSO FOR THEM. AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEIR VOICE COUNTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I URGE YOU
TO VOTE ON SB TWO THIRTY. THANK
YOU MISTER ROBERTS TO RODRIGUEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ALSO RISE
OF THE CALL WHAT THE SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY I WANT TO THANK. OUR
BIRTH I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING AUTHOR NEVER PERSON
WHO WORKED. THIS BILL IS NOW.
THREE TO THIRTY WILL PROVIDE.
NEITHER SOURCES. REPORTER FOR
AGENTS. WILL PAVE MAINTAINING
PUBLIC TRUST AND THE MUTUAL
RESPECT THAT IS NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ARE SPECTROSCOPY.
I'M SB TWO THIRTY. THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER GIBSON YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABOUT A SPEAKER MEMBERS A LOT.
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHAT I VOTE. AND ASKED THAT
THIS ITEM BEACH MERELY
TRANSMITTED TO THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIVE SEND
THINK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS. ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
GO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
OH TWO SB THREE SEVENTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THREE SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE
. MR GRAYSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. ADAM SPEAKER I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB THREE
SEVENTEEN ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
CAFIERO AT WHICH I AM ALSO A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR WHICH WOULD
BAN THE SALE OF CERTAIN TOXIC
CHEMICALS USED AN RV WASTE
WATER TANKS WHICH CAUSE
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION
RECREATIONAL VEHICLE OWNERS USE
CHEMICAL DEODORANTS TO REDUCE
ORDERS FROM THE BLACKWATER AND
GRAYWATER TANKS IN THERE ARE
VIS THESE DEODORANTS CONTAIN
TOXIC CHEMICALS LIKE
FORMALDEHYDE WHICH REDUCE
ORDERS BY KILLING THE BACTERIA.
THAT LIVE IN THE TANK TO
PRODUCE THE ORDERS WHEN RV
OWNERS HOOK UP THERE TAKES THE
RV PARK'S SEPTIC TANK THEY
DEPOSIT THE CONTENTS OF THE
TANKS INTO THE AND THE TOXIC
CHEMICALS INTO THE SYSTEM ONCE
IN THE PARK'S SEPTIC TANK THESE
CHEMICALS KILL THE BACTERIA
NEEDED TO TREAT THE PARKS WASTE
WHICH CAUSES SYSTEM FAILURE OF
THE SENATE THIS INCREASES THE
RISK THAT UNTREATED WASTE AND
ALSO TOXIC CHEMICALS WILL MAKE
THEIR WAY INTO THE GROUNDWATER.
WHICH THREATENS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF PARK VISITORS THE
OWNERS AND NEIGHBORS AND THESE
MOSTLY RURAL COMMUNITIES IN AN
EFFORT TO PROTECT GROUNDWATER
AND ENCOURAGE THE USE OF SAFE
ALTERNATIVES SB THREE SEVENTEEN
WILL BAN THE SALE AND THE USE
OF TOXIC CHEMICALS AS WELL AS
REQUIRE RV PARTS TO FORM THEIR
CUSTOMERS OF THE BAND WAS
SIGNAGE REQUIREMENTS THIS WILL
BE GROUND WATER SPUR. AND THE
WORRY OF RV PARK SURROUNDED
COMMUNITY IS RECEIVED THE TOXIC
CHEMICAL COMPANIES ALSO HAVE A
GREEN ALTERNATIVE THAT IS
READILY AVAILABLE SO ACCESS IS
ASSURED THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A THANK
YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK. WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
HELLO. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WILL LOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY NEWS HERE THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM THREE OH FIVE
SB THREE SIXTY FIVE A CIRCLE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
FIVE BY SENATOR ALSO AN ACTOR
AND CALL WORKS MR MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. SB THREE SIXTY
FIVE INSURERS THAT. APPARENTLY
ELIGIBLE PARENTS WHO REQUIRE
CHILD CARE IN ORDER TO WORK OR
PARTICIPATE IN AN EDUCATIONAL
OR TRAINING ACTIVITY ARE ABLE
TO RECEIVE. CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE IN THE MOST TIMELY
S. MANNER LOW INCOME PARENTS
OFTEN FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
AS THEY LOOK FOR WORK. OR IN
THE EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THEIR
EDUCATION OR JOB SKILLS. THIS
MEASURE SIMPLY IS DESIGNED TO
BREAK THE BARRIERS AND HELP
THEM GET THOSE BENEFITS FASTER
AND GET THEM WORKING FASTER
MEMBERS I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM THREE
OH SIX SB THREE EIGHTY TWO
PURPLE RAIN. SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR NIELSEN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI
CAL. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS RECENT
NATURAL DISASTERS OF CREATING A
TREMENDOUS STRAIN ON OUR
HOSPITALS WE HAVE STEPPED UP
SERVE AN INFLUX OF PATIENTS IN
NEED. MOST HEALTH PLANS PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO HOSPITALS IN
MANAGING THESE PATIENTS BY
HELPING TO MOVE THEM TO A LOWER
LEVEL OF CARE WHEN ACUTE
HOSPITAL CARE IS NO LONGER
NECESSARY. HOWEVER THERE HAVE
BEEN INSTANCES WHERE SOME
PLANTS HAVE USED LOOPHOLES TO
AVOID THEIR EXISTING
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE PATIENT
IN THE HOSPITAL. SB THREE
EIGHTY TWO WILL ENSURE THE
PATIENTS ARE CARED FOR DURING
THESE EXTREME SITUATIONS BY
CLARIFYIN EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH PLANS
TO ASSIST HOSPITALS AND
IDENTIFYING ENTRANCE RING
PATIENTS. IF THERE'S NO AVAIL
AVAILABILITY FOR A LOWER LOWER
LEVEL OF CARE THE BILL THEN
REQUIRE THE HEALTH PLAN TO
REIMBURSE THE HOSPITAL AT A
MODEST RATE FOR CARE PROVIDED
TO THE PATIENTS AWAITING
PLACEMENT. THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE EXTENDED
CARE FOR PATIENTS REMAIN IN
HOSPITAL BED FALLING AT THIRTY
MERCHANTS THE I ASKED FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU THANK YOU CURRY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS TO THEIR TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS
THERE THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM THREE TEN SP FOUR FIFTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR ARE TADO ACTUALLY THE
OLDER ADULTS STERN IS ARIAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. SB FOUR FIFTY THREE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WHO ARE TODD
WILL HELP INCREASE OLDER ADULTS
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ACCESS TO LONG
TERM SUPPORT SERVICES THEY
NEED. IT DOES THIS BY
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING AGING DISABILITY
RESOURCE CONNECTION PROGRAMS
INCREASING THE QUALITY OF
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE
ENCOURAGING THE EXPANSION OF
THE E. D. R. C. PROGRAMS AND
TAKING STEPS TOWARDS CALIFORNIA
BECOMING A NO WRONG DOOR STATE.
A NO WRONG DOOR MODEL IS A
SYSTEM THAT ENABLES CONSUMERS
TO ACCESS ALL LONG TERM SOCIAL
SERVICES OPTIONS THROUGH ONE
AGENCY ORGANIZATION COORDINATED
NETWORK OR PORTAL. IT'S THROUGH
THE A. B. OR C. PROGRAMS THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE CONNECTED TO
SUPPORT SERVICES NEEDED TO KEEP
THEM SAFELY LIVING IN THEIR
HOME AND HAVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES THEY NEED. WITH THAT I
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRED.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIRD WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SIX NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THREE
TWELVE SB FOUR SIXTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ. THE BILL FOR
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR MITCHELL
AND ACTUALLY THE MATERNAL
HEALTH. SECOND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT SB FOUR SIXTY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DIGNITY IN PREGNANCY
AND CHILDBIRTH ACT WHICH
CREATES AWARENESS AND ACTIVELY
FIGHTS THE BLACK MATERNAL
MORTALITY DISPARITY IN
CALIFORNIA. IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE AT THE
RATE OF WOMEN DYING IN
CHILDBIRTH OR DUE TO PREGNANCY
RELATED CAUSES WAS AMONG THE
HIGHEST IN THE NATION AND BEGAN
AGGRESSIVELY TARGETING THOSE
HIGH RATES. TODAY DESPITE A 55%
DECLINE AND MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATES THE NUMBERS FOR BLACK
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA REMAIN
THREE TO FOUR TIMES HIGHER THAN
THOSE OF OTHER RACIAL AND
ETHNIC GROUPS. UNLIKE OTHER
DISPARITIES THIS CANNOT BE
EXPLAINED AWAY BY SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS. EDUCATIONAL LEVEL RISKY
HEALTH BEHAVIORS OR OTHER
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
INSTEAD EVIDENCE POINTS TO AN
IMPLICIT BIAS AS ONE OF THE
CAUSES FOR THE DISPARITIES. SB
FOUR SIXTY FOUR CALLS FOR
THOROUGH INTERSECTIONAL
EXAMINATION OF SUCH BASIS. BY
REQUIRING IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAININGS FOR ALL PRENATAL
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND BY
REQUIRING THE- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH TO
RESUME TRACKING AND PUBLISHING
MATERNAL MORTALITY AND
MORBIDITY DATA. SB FOUR SIXTY
FOUR ASSURES EQUITY WITHIN
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE.
CALIFORNIA HAS PLENTY OF REASON
TO CELEBRATE THE DOWNWARD TREND
IN THE MATERNAL DEATHS BUT WE
CANNT AFFORD TO CELEBRATE THAT
TREND AND TO ALL WOMEN ARE
BENEFITING EQUALLY FROM THE
IMPORTANT CHANGES IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SEGMENTS SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE THE- ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY NINE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES BYLINE
THREE TWENTY NINE SB SIX NINETY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY
THE HEALING ARTS THREE MEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY 2% SB SIX NINETY SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR CAFIERO OF
WHICH I AM A CO AUTHOR WHICH
WILL MODERNIZE THE POSITION
ASSIST IN PRACTICE TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
CALIFORNIA IS EXPECTED TO FACE
A SHORTFALL OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS WITH ACUTE SHORTAGES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY CENTRAL
COAST AND SOUTHERN BORDER AREAS
THIS IS DUE TO THE UNEVEN
DISTRIBUTION OF CARE ACROSS THE
STATE AS WELL AS A LACK OF A
SUPPLY OF CLINICIANS. TO COMBAT
THE SHORTAGE SB SIX NINETY
SEVEN FOCUSES ON EXPANDING
POSITION UTILIZATION A POSITION
ASSISTANCE OR P. A.'S
REGULATION P. A.'S ARE SUBJECT.
TO RULES WRITTEN DECADES AGO
AND HAVE NOT PROGRESSED THE WAY
PRACTICING MEDICINE HAVE THEY
IMPOSE A BURDEN UPON BOTH THE
PA AND THE POSITION.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS CREATED A
DISINCENTIVE TO HIRE. WHICH
LIMITS ACCESS TO MEDICAL
SERVICES AND IS HURT RURAL
COMMUNITIES. SB SIX NINETY
SEVEN WOULD ELIMINATE THIS
OUTMODED REQUIREMENT THAT EACH
PA WORK WITH A SINGLE POSITION
AND THE DISPARITIES BETWEEN
PA'S AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WITH SIMILAR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE PROFESSIONAL
REGULATIONS. WITHOUT EXPANDING
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE. BY
MODERNIZING THE OPERATIONAL
PRACTICE OF P. A.'S AND
CREATING A MORE FLEXIBLE WORK
ARRANGEMENTS. THIS BILL WERE
INCENTIVIZE POSITION TO UTILIZE
USED TO THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL. WHICH WILL EXPAND
HEALTHCARE ACCESS AND UNDER
DESERVED UNDERSERVED AREAS
THANK YOU I READ AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT
NOTES HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THREE THIRTY ONE SB
SEVEN NO SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL SEVEN OH SIX
BY SENATOR GALGIANI AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH MR
FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER SB SEVEN OH
SIX WILL ESTABLISH A PULMONARY
HYPERTENSION TASK FORCE TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS DIAGNOSED. WITH
PULMONARY HYPERTENSION ALTHOUGH
PULMONARY HYPERTENSION IS A
DANGEROUS AND LIFE THREATENING
MEDICAL CONDITION TOO LITTLE IS
KNOWN ABOUT HOW TO IDENTIFY IN
TREATED IN A TIMELY MATTER THE
TASK FORCE WILL BE REQUIRED TO
REPORT ITS RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WILL
SUNSET BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE RESPECT LAST
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER FLORA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE TOP OF THE
THIRD READING FILE OF SENATE
BILLS. FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SEVEN SB TO TWENTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
TWO TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR ALSO
AND ACTUALLY IN THE CITIZENS OF
THE STATE. THREE CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB TWO TWO FIVE WOULD
ENSURE THAT ALL QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS MAY BE
APPOINTED TO SERVE ON
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IS THE
POLICY OF OUR STATE THAT OUR
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
PROBABLY REFLECT THE GENERAL
PUBLIC BY INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS
OUR BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS CAN
MORE CLOSELY REFLECT OUR PUBLIC
AND BRING MORE DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES TO INFORM POLICY
DECISIONS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WILL BE REMOVED AN
OBSOLETE CODE SECTION THAT WAS
WRITTEN IN THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES TO EXCLUDE IMMIGRANTS
FROM CIVIL PARTICIPATION
ALIGNING OUR STATE'S DEFINITION
OF A CITIZEN WITH THE
DEFINITION FOUND IN THE
CITIZENSHIP CLAUSE OF THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT WHICH PUTS
TO AN END OLD LANGUAGE THAT WAS
MEANT TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CHINESE IMMIGRANTS IN THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL%
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY
THREE NO SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES. WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
AND FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY EIGHT.
THROUGH ONE FIFTY FIVE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX SB
TO AWAIT THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TILL EIGHT BY
SENATOR HUESO AND OTHERS AND I
TWENTY COMMUNICATIONS MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB TWO OH
EIGHT EIGHT CONSUMER PROTECTION
BILL AIMED AT PREVENTING REBEL
CALL SCAMS. SPOOFING ESPECIALLY
NEIGHBORS PROOFING IS KEY TO
MAKING THE SCAMS WORK THE
VOLUME OF SPOOFED CALLS IS
INCREASING EXPERTS ESTIMATE THE
BY 202040% OF ALL CALLS
RECEIVED UNITED STATES WILL BE
FRAUDULENT CALLS. THIS BILL
SETS A JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DEADLINE FOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
IMPLEMENT CALLER ID
AUTHENTICATION MEASURES. WHICH
CAN HELP IDENTIFY ILLEGAL
ROBOCALLS AND PREVENTS
CONSUMERS FROM BEING SCAMMED.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND C. P. UC'S
AUTHORITY AND NARROWLY ALLOWS
THE CPUC TO WORK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO TAKE ACTION
AGAINST ILLEGAL REBEL CALLERS.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE CALL
BLOCKING WOULD NOT RESULT IN
REAL BECAUSE BEING BLOCKED AND
DOES NOT CREATE SIGNIFICANT NEW
LIABILITIES FOR TELECOMS. THESE
AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTEEN T. AND
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
THIS BILL WILL HELP RESTORE
CONSUMERS CONFIDENCE IN USING
THEIR PHONES WITHOUT BEING
SCAMMED I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I FIFTY NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THE FILE. AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BREAK FOR DINNER SO
THAT WE CAN GET OUR WORK DONE
AND GET OUT OF HERE BUT DINNER
IS AVAILABLE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS IN THE LOUNGE AND FOR
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE
RULES ROOM BUT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK THE FILE SO. WE
APPRECIATE THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE NOT HUNGRY STAYING. WILL
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
ONE FIFTY SEVEN THROUGH ONE
FIFTY NINE. AND MEMBERS JUST TO
BE CLEAR. WE ARE WORKING IN THE
ENTIRE FILE RIGHT NOW SO THESE
ARE NOT ALL SUPPORT SUPPORTS I
KNOW AND MR MULLIN HEN AUS
WORKING SPORTS SPORTS WE MOVED
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE FILE. WE
WILL PASS ENTERTAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE SIXTY FILE ITEMS ONE
SIXTY TWO FOR ONE SIXTY FOUR
WILL PASS AND RETAIN. ASCERTAIN
ON FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX.
VIOLATE ONE SIXTY SEVEN SB TO
TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO TWELVE BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS. MISTER DAVID CHIU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES SB TWO
TWELVE AUTHORIZES GENERAL US
CITIES COUNTIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO UTILIZE TO
MAJORITY WINNER VOTING METHODS
FOR LOCAL ELECTIONS TOP TWO
PRIMARY AND RAIN CHOICE VOTING.
UNDER CURRENT LAW VOTERS IN
GENERAL ARE CITIES MUST ELECT
THEIR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
USING PLURALITY WINNER VOTING
BUT CHARTER CITIES HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ADOPT MAJORITY
WINNER VOTING METHODS LIKE TOP
TWO OR RENT CHOICE VOTING. THIS
BILL WOULD SIMPLY GIVE GENERAL
US CITIES A SAME OPTIONS A
CHARTER CITIES CURRENTLY HAVE
TODAY I IN ORDER TO ADOPT THESE
VOTING METHODS MAJORITY VOTERS
MUST APPROVE THE CHANGE AT A
REGULARLY SCHEDULED ELECTION.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPOSE ANY
CHANGE ON LOCALITIES IS SIMPLY
PROVIDES COMMUNITIES WITH MORE
OPTIONS MORE LOCAL CONTROL TO
BETTER SELECT AND ELECTION
METHODS THAT MATCHES THEIR
NEEDS AND CIRCUMSTANCES AND
WITH THAT I REFER. A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER TO
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY ONE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. PASS TEMPORARILY AND
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE AND
ONE SEVENTY ONE ASCERTAIN ON
FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTY FOUR
THREE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE
SB SIX THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY EIGHT I SENATOR ALLEN
AND ACTUALLY TO TENNESSEE MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SO I RISE PRESENT SB SIX THIRTY
EIGHT ON HAVE SENATOR ALAN.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE BARRIERS
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLE ADOPTION BY
REFORMING EVEY CHARGING STATION
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS THAT
CURRENTLY BURDEN CALIFORNIA
TENANTS ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
VERIFY. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE BETTER. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FIFTY FIVE NEW ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES
. WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK UP TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS A RICE PRISON
CHOPPING AMENDMENTS TO SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR DODD. ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE CURRY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT BACK TO FILE. FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY SB SEVEN FORTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE.
BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR CAFIERO ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING. IT'S UST SALAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. YOU HAVE
SPEAKER I RISE RESENT SB SEVEN
FOUR FOUR ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
COPY AT ALL AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA FACES A DUAL CRISIS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WITH THE
RESULTING BURDENS FALLING
PARTICULARLY HARD ON PEOPLE
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ABOUT A THIRD OF
THOSE ARE ESTIMATED TO BE
LIVING WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE KNOW THAT HAVING PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS
LIVING ON SHELTERED OR CYCLING
IN AND OUT OF HOSPITALS AND
INCARCERATION IS COSTLY TO THE
PUBLIC AND RESULTS OF NEEDLESS
SUFFERING. FOR THE HOMELESS AND
THEIR FAMILIES LAST FALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY APPROVED
PROPOSITION TWO. THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME INITIATIVE WHICH
AUTHORIZES STATE ISSUE TO BE
BILLION AND BONDS TO CREATE
TWENTY THOUSAND UNITS OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY FOUR HELPS TO FILL THE
INTENT OF VOTERS BY CLARIFYING
AND STREAMLINING THE LOCAL
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND ASSOCIATED
SERVICES. LIKE THOSE THAT NO
PLACE LIKE HOME BONDS ARE
FUNDED CALIFORNIA'S MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THEY WANT PEOPLE
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS IN
OUR HOMES TO BE SHELTERED AND
CARED FOR. NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROPOSITION TWO GOT MORE VOTES
THAN ANY OTHER MEASURE ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR SENATE BILL SEVEN FOUR
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER SALAS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALENTED AYE AYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS WHEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY ONE AND
WHAT DO YOU TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY THREE SB FOUR FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
FOR FIFTY BY SENATOR UMBERG AND
ACTUALLY THE BY MENTAL QUALITY
MR. DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ROSS
OUR STATE THEIR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES LIVING IN MOTELS
BECAUSE FOR ONE REASON OR
ANOTHER THEY CAN'T GET THEIR
OWN APARTMENT. THIS BILL WILL
HELP CITIES OR NONPROFIT
SERVICE PROVIDERS ACQUIRE THOSE
MOTELS THESE MOTELS. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONVERTING THEM INTO
TRANSITIONAL OR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING. SOMETIMES THE MERE
THREAT OF SEQUEL IT LITIGATION
CAN MAKE SUCH CONVERSIONS COST
PROHIBITIVE THIS BILL TARGETS
ONLY THE MINOR ALTERATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE ADDING A SMALL KITCHEN
UNIT TO BE ADDED TO A MOTEL
ROOM AS PART OF A CONVERSION
PROJECT IT'S SUPPORTED BY THE
THIRTEEN BIG CITY MAYORS.
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE URBAN COUNTIES
ASSOCIATION AND MANY OTHERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DALY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER OF THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY VOTE AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS THE RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
ONE EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH ONE
NINETY PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEMS ONE NINETY TWO THROUGH
ONE NINETY NINE PASS RETAIN
FILE ITEM TWO OH ONE. WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS TO
INTO A THREE PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS TO FOUR THREE TWO OH
SIX MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWO OH
SEVEN. SB SEVENTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL SEVENTY
TWO BY SENATOR UMBERG AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS. MISS CONSOLIDATE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MADAM SPEAKER
I'M SORRY. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SEVENTY TWO ON BEHALF OF CENTER
BURKE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE ALL
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE CONDITIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION. AT EVERY
SINGLE POLLING PLACE LAST YEAR
MARKED THE FIRST TIME
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF SAME
DAY VOTER REGISTRATION WAS
AVAILABLE FOR STATEWIDE
ELECTIONS. HOWEVER SAME DAY
VOTING WAS NOT OFFERED IN
NEARLY ENOUGH LOCATIONS AS
RESULT MANY VOTERS WERE FORCED
TO WAIT HOURS IN LINE AND
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES WHICH IS
AN UNACCEPTABLE. STARTING AT
TWENTY TWENTY SB SEVENTY TWO
WILL EXPAND ACCESS FOR SAME DAY
VOTER REGISTRATION AND VOTING
TO ALL ELIGIBLE VOTERS. IN
CALIFORNIA BY MAKING
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
AVAILABLE AT EVERY VOTING
LOCATION I RESPECT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS GONZALES SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE BOTH THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOSE GUYS FORTY THREE
KNOWS TENNIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM WHICH TO EIGHT TO TEN
AND TWO ELEVEN WE PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING TO FILE AND TWO
TWELVE SP TWO OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL TWO OH
FIVE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
ACTUALLY BUSINESS. MISTER WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
AS SPEAKERS SORRY WE JUST LOOK
AT THE WHEEL. PRESENT SB TWO OH
FIVE INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES ARE
OFTEN EXPOSED TO BE OUTDOORS
ALLOWING RAIN TO PICK UP A
POLLUTANTS AND WATCH THEM
DIRECTLY IN OUR WATERWAYS.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES TO OBTAIN
AN INDUSTRIAL GENERAL PERMIT TO
COMPLY WITH NATIONAL WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS. CURRENTLY
BUSINESSES MYSELF REGISTER
THROUGH THE STATE WATER BOARD
ONLINE PERMITTING PLATFORM TO
OBTAIN COVERAGE AS A RESULT
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
WATER QUALITY REQUIREMENTS BUT
HAVE NOT SIGNED UP. SB TWO OH
FIVE ENCOURAGES UNIFORMITY WITH
WATER QUALITY REQUIREMENTS IT
WILL PREVENT THE PROLIFERATION
OF HARMFUL POLLUTANTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRECIOUS WATER
RESOURCES ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM
BY REQUIRED INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES TO DEMONSTRATE
COVERAGE UNDER THE IGP WHEN
APPLYING FOR A FREE NEW IN
THEIR BUSINESS LICENSE THIS
BILL DOES NOT INTRODUCE ANY NEW
REGULATION. INSTEAD CREATES A
PROCESS THAT REINFORCES THE
EXISTING LAW. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER WOULD SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I CITY FOR NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
. FILE
ITEM WE ARE GOING TO FILE ITEM
THREE SEVENTEEN SB FIVE OH
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH THREE BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY MEDI
CAL MISTER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB FIVE OH THREE WOULD
STRENGTHEN OVERSIGHT WHEN MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS
SUBCONTRACTS SERVICES AND
DELEGATE RESPONSIBILITIES. THE
LAYERS OF SUBCONTRACTING CAN
OFTEN BE COMPLEX AND LACK
TRANSPARENCY SB FIVE OH THREE
WILL HELP TO IMPROVE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN PLAN
SUBCONTRACT. BY ONE REQUIRING
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO ANNUALLY
AUDIT THEIR SUB GRANT
CONTRACTORS ESTABLISHING
UNIFORM AUDIT AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND MAKING CLEAR
THAT MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED TO
BENEFICIARIES. REGARDLESS OF
ANY SUBCONTRACTING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE ICE FIFTY SIX
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK UP TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS SB SEVEN
FIFTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
WITH THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING OR
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AT. SB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR FOR
PURPOSES OF NON SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS. THESE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES
WITH SB THREE TWENTY THREE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE THAT.
THANK YOU MISS PETRI NORRIS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK
TO FILE. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE
SB THREE TEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL THREE TEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND I TWENTY
JURIES MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SENATE BILL THREE TEN
SIX TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS
TO BE TRIEDBY A CHIU JURY OF
THEIR PEERS BY ALLOWING PEOPLE
WITH PRIOR CONVICTIONS A SERVE
ON  JURY. JURIES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
THE CONCEPT THAT PEOPLE CAN
HAVE THEIR CASES HEARD BY THEIR
PEERS AS A PRIMARY SOURCE OF
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEMS LEGITIMACY.
OUR CONSTITUTION GIVES US THE
RIGHT TO A JURY OF OUR PEERS
YET OUR BLANKET BAN TOWARDS
THOSE OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
PERSONS WITH A FORMER FELONY
CONVICTION PREVENTS DIVERSITY
IN OUR JURIES AND UNFAIRLY DENY
SOMEONE THE ABILITY TO TAKE
PART IN CIVIC LIFE. ENSURING
JURIES TRULY REPRESENT OUR
DIVERSITY IS VITAL TO OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM YET THE BAN
AGAINST FORMER FELONS
EFFECTIVELY EXCLUDES 30% OF
CALIFORNIA'S BLACK MALE
RESIDENTS FROM EVER SERVING. ON
THE JURY. SB THREE TEN LIST AS
BATTLE LINES CALIFORNIA JR
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS CLOSER
TO SET TO MANY OTHER STATES.
AND WORKING WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IS OF THE AUTHOR TOOK
AMENDMENTS THAT PROHIBIT A
PERSON FROM SERVING ON A JURY
IF THEY'RE ON PAROLE FELONY
PROBATION OR ANY MANDATED
SUPERVISION DUE TO A FELONY
CONVICTION AS WELL AS
PROHIBITING ANYONE WHO IS A
REGISTERED FELONY SEX OFFENDER.
SB THREE TEN IS NOT SUPPORTED
BY THE LA DISTRICT BY
BIOLOGISTS RETURNEE LACI THE
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
ASSOCIATION THE POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION ARE NOW NEUTRAL AND
THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
IS NO NEUTRAL. AS A FORMER
PUBLIC DEFENDER I KNOW JUDGES
AND BOTH SIDES HAVE AMPLE
ABILITY TO FERRET OUT JUROR
BIAS IN FACT I HAD A JURY
SELECTION BILL. THAT HAS BEEN
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR TO ALLOW
MORE TIME FOR PARTIES TO
QUESTION POTENTIAL JURORS FOR
BIAS. UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT LAW THE
LINES ARE STATE WITH ARKANSAS
GEORGIA KENTUCKY IN OKLAHOMA IN
A LIFETIME BAN FOR PEOPLE WITH
FELONY CONVICTIONS FROM EVER
SERVING ON JURY GUESTS. OVER
TWENTY STATES ALLOW PEOPLE WITH
PRIOR FELONY CONVICTIONS IN
SOME FORM TO SERVE ON A JURY
COLORADO ILLINOIS MAINE IN
OREGON ALLOW PEOPLE TO SERVE
WITHOUT RESTRICTIONS I ASKED
THAT WE JOIN THESE FORWARD
THINKING STATES. AND ALLOW
THOSE THAT ARE TRYING TO GET
BACK ON TRACK AND DO RIGHT BY
THE LIFE AND COMPLETED THE
PAROLE AND PROBATION TO BE PART
OF A JURY OF ONE'S PEERS BUT BE
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE. COM MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE
. YEAH NUMBER ONE
I. THE. MISTER KALRA MOVE THE
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM TO SB FORTY FOUR CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FORTY
FOUR I SENATOR SKINNER AND
ACTUALLY THE VEHICULAR
POLLUTION MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB FORTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR SKINNER WHO IS HERE ON
OUR FLOOR GOODS MOVEMENT IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY BUT IS ALSO A LARGE
CONTRIBUTOR TO AIR POLLUTION IN
OUR STATE. 33% OF CALIFORNIA
SUB SMOG CAUSING POLLUTION AND
25% OF CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS COME FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER HAVE SERIOUS
HEALTH IMPACTS AND IS LINKED TO
AN INCREASED RISK OF ASTHMA
LUNG DISEASE AND HEART DISEASE.
THIS BILL DIRECTS CARP TO
UPDATE THE STATE'S MOBILE
SOURCE STRATEGY BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND EVERY TWO YEARS
THERE AFTER TO INCLUDE A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY ON HOW
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE SECTORS CAN REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND MOVE TOWARDS
CLEANER TECHNOLOGY. THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND IS
SUPPORTED BY CAL CHAMBER THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
THE SIERRA CLUB I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. MR
GABRIEL SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOUGH HIS ART OF AT
THIS PRICE FORTY ONE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
TENNIS MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN SB TWO
ELEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO ELEVEN BY
SENATOR PELL AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE THE STATE HIGHWAYS
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I AM. VERY HAPPY TO
PRESENT SB TWO ELEVEN IT IS
ANOTHER BILL THAT WILL SUPPORT.
IT IS ANOTHER BILL THAT WILL
SUPPORT OF THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THIS BILL BY
SENATOR BELL AS BE TO ELEVEN
WILL ALLOW CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO LEASE ON USE CALTRANS
PROPERTY FOR A DOLLAR A MONTH.
IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH A BURDEN
SEE SHELTER OR FEEDING PROGRAMS
MEMBER CALTRANS ALREADY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO ENTER INTO DOLLAR
LEASES IN A NUMBER OF
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES SAN JOSE STOCKTON AND
SAN FRANCISCO. THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN A MAJOR HELP FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND THEY
ARE RECEIVING SERVICES THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER X.
OVERSEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM TO NINETEEN
SB THREE THIRTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTEEN BY SIR HUESO ACKLEY TO
ANIMALS. MR GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB THREE THIRTEEN
PROTECTS WILDER EXOTIC ANIMALS
BY PROHIBITING ANY PERSON FROM
SPONSORING CONDUCTING OPERATING
OR PARTICIPATING IN A CIRCUS
THAT USES ANY ANIMAL OTHER THAN
THE DOMESTIC DOG DOMESTIC CAT
OR DOMESTICATED HORSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK REVIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA S. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR DEVOTE.
YEAH. REQUIRES FORTY ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERT ABOUT
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
FIRES FORTY ONE
. ALL MEMBERS
BETTER DESERT ABOUT THIS FIRST
FORTY ONE
. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE ITALIAN VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY TWO NO SEVEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND JOIN
REAL SIXTY TWO HEY THE FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB SIX EIGHTEEN JONES SAWYER ON
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH AT
NINE AM IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. SB SOON TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO
I'M REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TO AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
ME MON TO LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT.
AND ITEM NUMBERTWO OH FIVE SB
FIFTY FOUR TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
YEAH WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM TO TEN SB ONE NINETY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR HILL AND ACCOLADES THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION MR
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SP ONE
NINETY NINE EXTENDS THE OFFICE.
OF SAFETY ADVOCATES OR AT O. S.
A. AT THE CPUC BY FIVE YEARS.
ESSAY WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. AND IS SET TO EXPIRE
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR. FOR
THE PAST TWO YEARS ESSAY HAS
WORKED TOWARD ADVOCATING
IMPROVING UTILITY SAFETY AND
IMPROVING THE SAFETY CULTURE AT
THE C. P. U. C. MEMBERS ESSAY
ROLE HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
CRITICAL. AS WE URGENTLY NEED
SAFE UTILITY SERVICES. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE EYES FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE
ITEM. ONE SIXTY FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS SB THREE TWENTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY THREE
WITH A MEMBERS BY SOME REMEMBER
KALRA. MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THESE MEMBERS ADDRESS
CHAPARRAL THIS IS THE SB
SEVENTY FOUR US RILED BUT I BET
ON THIS MINUTES THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE
AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK
TO FILE. FILE ITEM TO THIRTY SB
FOUR OH SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL FOUR OH SEVEN
BY SANTA MONICA BACK LATER
MEDICARE SIR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER RECENTLY INSURERS HAVE
BEEN BEEN AT BEGUN ADDING NON
MEDICAL INNOVATIVE BENEFITS TO
THE MOST POPULAR MEDIGAP
PACKAGE IN AN ATTEMPT TO
DISTINGUISH THEIR PRODUCTS FROM
OTHERS IN THE MARKETPLACE.
WHILE THESE BENEFITS VISION
DENTAL AND HEARING TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL COVERAGE THE
INCLUSION OF THESE NON STANDARD
BENEFITS INSIDE THAN STANDARD
MEDIGAP BRACKETS IN IT HINDERS
THE ABILITY OF CONSUMERS TO
MAKE MEANINGFUL COMPARISONS
BETWEEN NON MEDICAL BENEFITS DO
THE VARIATIONS OFFERED BY
INSURERS. SB PORRO SEVEN
EXPANDS THE MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENTAL OPEN AND ROPE AND
MET PERIOD TO A MINIMUM OF
SIXTY DAYS REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND APARTMENT
INSURANCE TO COLLABORATE WITH
SPECIALISTS BUT THE SPECIFIED
INDIVIDUALS AND ENTITIES. TO
DEVELOP A DISPLAY
STANDARDIZATION OF INNOVATION
INNOVATIVE PLANS AND MANDATES
INSURERS TO NOTIFY TO ROLLY OF
THEIR OPEN THEM PEARL I'M
ENROLLMENT RIGHTS THE BILL SAYS
CONSUMER FOCUS REGULATIONS
WHICH ALLOW SENIORS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND ALL ASPECTS. OF THE
END OF INNOVATIVE PLAN THEY
SEEK TO PURCHASE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER WOODS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
OF. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALENT VOTE ICE FORTY
NINE NO SEVEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES. US AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS TO THIRTY ONE IN TWO
THIRTY TO PASS TEMPORARILY AND
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY THREE. FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY SIX SB FIVE
EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN BY
CENTER RIGHT CAL SKINNER
RELATING CIVIL ACTIONS MISTER
DAVID CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES SB FIVE EIGHTEEN
SIMPLY CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
ON THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT THE COURT SHALL
AWARD COURT COSTS AND
REASONABLE ATTORNEY FEES TO
REQUEST OR SHOULD THE REQUEST
PREVAIL IN COURT. IF YOU PUBLIC
AGENCIES HAVE TRIED TO
CIRCUMVENT THIS LAW BY USING A
TYPE OF SETTLEMENT OFFER KNOWN
AS A NINE NINE EIGHT OFFER THAT
PREVENT THE RELEASE OF
DISPOSABLE DOCUMENTS AND SHIFT
POST OFFER COSTS ONTO THE
RECORDS REQUEST HER THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT OUR PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT IS BEING USED THE
WAY IT WAS INTENDED. AS A WAY
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO GET
INFORMATION FROM THEIR
GOVERNMENT WITHOUT THE FEAR OF
BEING BURNED BY FEES AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
CHIU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS.
WHERE'S FORTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY SEVEN NEWS EIGHT
THIS MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ALL THE FOODS THE
LOUNGE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
BIPARTISAN DINNER AS BOTH
CAUCUSES ORDERED PIZZA FOR YOUR
DINING PLEASURE THIS EVENING.
AND TO BE. THE RULES COMMITTEE
WILL MEET SOON I WILL LET YOU
KNOW WHEN THE RULES COMMITTEE
CONVENES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TO FORTY THREE SB FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
BY CENTER BRADFORD ACCOLADE CAL
GRANTS. THIS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I'M A LITTLE **** MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS WE ASK OUR SELF WE
TRULY VALUE EVERY STUDENT EVEN
IF THE STUDENT WHO HAPPENS TO
BE INCARCERATED AT THE POLICY
MAKERS THE ANSWER SHOULD BE YES
AND IF THE ANSWER IS YES THEN
WE MUST AGAIN ASK WHY THERE IS
A BAN ON CAL GRANT. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED.
INCARCERATIONS TO NOT
AUTOMATICALLY DISQUALIFY
STUDENTS FROM A CAL GRANT
PROGRAM SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
REMOVES OUTDATED BARRIERS AND
EXPENSE ACCESS TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR INCARCERATED
STUDENTS THROUGH SECOND CHANCE
CAL GRANTS WHILE SUPPORTING
EFFECTIVE REHABILITATE
REHABILITATE EFFORTS WITHIN OUR
CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
MEMBERS I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
PROVIDING FINANCIAL AID TO
INCARCERATED STUDENTS IT'S NOT
A NEW CONCEPT. THE HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE. FIRST AUTHORIZED THOSE
WERE INCARCERATED TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE. PELL
GRANTS BUT WERE UNFORTUNATELY
BAND DURING THE TOUGH ON CRIME
ERA. THE WHY IS CALIFORNIA NOT
DOING THIS WHEN THE BENEFITS
ARE CLEAR. STUDENTS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN PARTICIPATING
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION HAVE A
43% LOWER RECIDIVISM RATE. FOR
EVERY ONE DOLLAR INVESTED IN A
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THERE
IS A RETURN OF FOUR TO FIVE
DOLLARS. CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
SPEND AN AVERAGE OF EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
INCARCERATING ONE INDIVIDUAL
YET THE REVENUE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT ONE FULL TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT IS SLIGHTLY
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR. WELL EDUCATION ALONE
DOES NOT SOLVE ALL OF THE
ISSUES OF INCARCERATION AND
RECIDIVISM IT IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT. THE ABILITY TO HAVE
A SECOND CHANCE IS FUNDAMENTAL
NOT ONLY TO OUR STATE BUT THIS
NATION IT IS JUST FAIR IT IS
JUST UNFAIR TO PASS THIS BILL.
INSTEAD INSTITUTING THE SECOND
CHANCE CAL GRANTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I'D
VOTE FOR SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS FOR
THIS MEASURE PASSES. MISTER
KALRA IS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
THREE SB THREE TIMES TEN THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED ABOUT
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY TWO NEWS TWENTY THIS
MEASURE PASSES. YEAH THAT ONE
NINETY
. IN A FILE ITEM CHIU
FORTY SEVEN SB SIX HUNDRED THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SIX HUNDRED BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO ACCOLADE HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE THIS WEEK'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR PORTANTINO
THE PURPOSE OF SB SIX HUNDRED
IS TO CONFIRM ONCE AND FOR ALL
THAT ALL PATIENTS WHO MUST
UNDERGO MEDICALLY NECESSARY
TREATMENTS SUCH AS
CHEMOTHERAPY. RADIATION CERTAIN
SURGERIES TO TREAT THEIR
MEDICAL CONDITION ARE YOU ABLE
TO FIRST ACCESS STANDARD
FERTILITY PRESERVATION
TREATMENTS IN ORDER PART TO
PROTECT THEIR FUTURE ABILITY TO
HAVE BIOLOGICAL CHILDREN.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT EXPRESSLY
SPELL OUT EACH AND EVERY
COVERED SERVICE AND THERE'S
CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT FERTILITY
PRESERVATION IS MANY PATIENTS
HAVE BEEN RIGHT WRONGFULLY
DENIED COVERAGE. SB SIX CENTER
WILL CONFIRM PURSUANT TO
CURRENT LAW THE FERTILITY
PRESERVATION IS EXISTING
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WORK
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER OF THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE
. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. THIS
WITNESS A CALL. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SB SIX TWENTY BY LINE TO
FIFTY THREE SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SIX TWENTY EIGHT BY CENTER
CABALLERO ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE
A TRANSPORTATION. MR REEVE US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MADAM
SPEAKER THANK YOU SENATE BILL
SIX TWO EIGHT SIX TO ADDRESS
CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION NEEDS
BY REDIRECTING PROCEEDS FROM
THE SALE SURPLUS PROPERTY TO
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY. RE DIRECTED
FUNDS A PROPOSED TO BE USED FOR
IMPORTANT SHOVEL READY
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS ALONG THE HIGHWAY ONE
A ONE CORRIDOR LOCATED IN THE
COUNTY MONTEREY. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD HALT WOULD
ALSO OFFER AUTHORIZE THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO RELINQUISH
PORTION OF STATE ROUTE ONE
EIGHT. ONE EIGHTY THREE TO THE
CITY OF. SALINAS IF IT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO DO SO. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER RIVAS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
TODAY WE'D LIKE TO. GET A BIG
MODEL TOUGH TO THE LEVINE
FAMILY ON THE BAR MITZVAH OF
THEIR SON THIS PAST SATURDAY.
WHITE LEVINE BECAME APARTMENTS
FOR A AND- HALF THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY I WELCOME HIM. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY SIX SB
SIX NINETY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL SIX NINETY
FIVE BY CENTER PORTANTINO WHEN
ACTUALLY THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
THIS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TO DAMPERS I AM
PRESENTING SENATE BILL SIX NINE
FIVE. ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO. SB SIX NINE FIVE
REQUIRES A LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY. TO PROVIDE A STUDENT'S
PARENT WITH A TRANSLATED COPY
OF THE COMPLETED INDIVIDUAL
EDUCATION PLAN IN ONE OF THE
EIGHT MOST COMMONLY SPOKEN
LANGUAGES. IN THAT DISTRICT
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF BEING
REQUESTED. AS WELL AS REQUIRED
THE I EP TO BE TRANSLATED BY A
QUALIFIED TRANSLATOR. THIS BILL
ALSO REQUIRES CD EITHER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO REVISE ITS NOTICE
OF PROCEDURAL SAFEGUARDS IN
ORDER TO INFORM PARENTS OF
THEIR RIGHT TO REQUEST THE
TRANSLATION OF DOCUMENTS. THE I
EP PROCESS CAN BE VERY
OVERWHELMING AND INTIMIDATING
FOR SOMEONE WHO IS NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROCESS OR THE
TERMINOLOGY. ESPECIALLY THAT
PERSON'S PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS
NOT ENGLISH. THE LACK OF HAVING
A TIMELY AND ACCURATELY
TRANSLATED I EAT P. DOES A
GREAT DISSERVICE TO BOTH THE
PARENT AND THE STUDENT. THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS FOR THE
PARENTS TO HAVE MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION OF THE IEP
PROCESS WHICH IS REQUIRED BY
CURRENT LAW BUT THIS BILL ALSO
GOES ONE STEP FURTHER AND
PROVIDES THAT PARENTS BE GIVEN
A TRANSLATED COPY OF THE I. E.
P. WITHIN A CERTAIN TIME FRAME.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
REST SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY
SIX KNOWS THREE THIS MEASURE
PASSES. ME FILE ITEM TWO
SEVENTY FIVE SB ONE THIRTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY NINE BY CENTER
ALLEN ACRYLATE TO ELECTIONS MR
SOLACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PRESENT
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY NINE
REQUIRES COUNTIES WITH MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
RESIDENTS TO ESTABLISH AN
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION ENSURING A MORE FAIR
NONPARTISAN SYSTEM FOR DRAWING
LINES. OF KELLY SUPERMAJORITY
DISTRICTS CURRENTLY OUR STATE
ASSEMBLY SENATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICTS ARE DRAWN BY
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSIONS THE STATE
LEGISLATURES PASSED PRIOR BILLS
A REQUIRE LOS ANGELES AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES TO ADOPT
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS.
NOW'S THE TIME TO REQUIRED THAT
OTHER LARGE COUNTIES JOINS THE
LATEST LEGISLATURE IN CONGRESS
AND TAKE GERRYMANDERING OUT OF
REDISTRICTING RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I'VE- THANK YOU MISTER
CELIS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE EYES FORTY NINE NEWS
SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
HIGHLIGHT IN TWO EIGHTY SB ONE
SIXTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE. BILL ONE SIXTY THREE BY
CENTER PORTANTINO WHEN ACTUALLY
TO HEALTHCARE COVERAGE MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. SENATE
BILL ONE SIXTY THREE BY CENTER
PORTANTINO WILL ELIMINATE
SIGNIFICAN ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS
IMPOSED BY HEALTH PLANS THAT
ARE PREVENTING FAMILIES FROM
ACCESSING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM RESEARCH HAS CLEARLY
SHOWN THAT CHILDREN WITH AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDER WHO RECEIVE
BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT HEALTH
TREATMENT EARLY. CAN SHOW
REMARKABLE PROGRESS. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED UP
LEGISLATION EIGHT YEARS AGO TO
PROVIDE HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM MANY INDIVIDUALS HAVE
STILL BEEN PREVENTED FROM
RECEIVING CARE CURRENTLY
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING DENIED COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBED EVIDENCE BASED CARE
THIS IS COVERAGE THEY OR THEIR
EMPLOYERS HAVE ALREADY PAID
FOR. BUT IN TOO MANY CASES THE
PARENTS OF OR THE STATE ARE
LEFT TO COVER THE COSTS OF THIS
CRITICAL CARE OF I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THOSE
GUYS FIFTY ONE KNOWS THREE THIS
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN SB TWO OH SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ. THE BILL TWO
OH SIX BY SENATOR SKINNER AN
ACCOLADE INTERCOLLEGIATE
ATHLETICS COM LONGER TO HAVE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
GOOD EVENING MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB TWO ZERO SIX GIVES
CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGE ATHLETES
THE SAME RIGHTS AS OLYMPIC
ATHLETES. AND RIGHTS THAT ARE
ENJOYED BY EVERY OTHER
CALIFORNIA THE RIGHT TO ONE'S
OWN NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS
COLLEGE ATHLETES NOW HAVE TO
WAIVE THAT RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE
IN COLLEGE SPORTS ENFORCEMENT
OF THAT RULE RESULTS IN
ABSURDITY SUCH AS MEMBERS OF
THE SWIM TEAM NOT BEING ALLOWED
TO TEACH SWIMMING LESSONS.
WE'VE ALL HEARD ABOUT ATHLETES
LIKE UCLA'S ED O'BANNON MORE U.
N. L. V.'S GREG ANTHONY AND BAN
AND SAW HIMSELF FEATURED IN A
BASKETBALL VIDEO GAME WITHOUT
HIS PERMISSION WITHOUT ANY
PAYMENT OR SHARE OF THE PROFITS
AND THIS WAS A YOUNG MAN WITH A
STELLAR COLLEGIATE CAREER BUT A
VERY SHORT PROFESSIONAL CAREER
BECAUSE OF INJURIES SUSTAINED
WHILE HE WAS IN COLLEGE. SB TWO
OH SIX WOULD ALLOW COLLEGE
ATHLETES TO MONETIZE THEIR
YOUTUBE VIDEOS AND PURSUE
SPONSORSHIPS AND ENDORSEMENTS
SB TWO OH SIX DOES NOT REQUIRE
THAT SCHOOLS PAID THEIR
ATHLETES. ALSO SB TWO OH SIX
PER BATES COLLEGE ATHLETES FROM
SIGNING DEALS THAT UNDERMINE
THEIR SCHOOLS EXISTING
CONTRACTS. FEMALE COLLEGE
ATHLETES TESTIFIED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE COMMITTEES
THAT THEY BELIEVE SB TWO OH SIX
WOULD BE ESPECIALLY BENEFICIAL
TO THEM WITH FEW OPPORTUNITIES
TO GO PRO. COLLEGE MAY BE THE
ONLY TIME THAT THESE FEMALE
ATHLETES HAVE TO MONETIZE THEIR
ATHLETIC SKILL. LET'S BE CLEAR.
COLLEGE SPORTS IS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY WITH
THE NC DOUBLE A MEDIA COLLEGES
COACHES IN ALL OTHERS MAKING
MONEY OFF THE TALENT AND HARD
WORK OF STUDENT ATHLETES.
DESPITE WHAT MANY BELIEVE MOST
COLLEGE ATHLETES DON'T RECEIVE
FULL SCHOLARSHIPS IF YOU HAVE
TIME FOR AN OUTSIDE JOB DUE TO
SPENDING UP TO FORTY HOURS PER
WEEK ON ATHLETICS WHICH IS
THEIR JOB. CBSSPORTS PULLED ONE
HUNDRED COLLEGE COACHES
NATIONWIDE WHEN ASKED IF THEY
SUPPORT ALLOWING COLLEGE
ATHLETES TO THE RIGHT TO THEIR
OWN NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS 77%
SUPPORTED THIS. DANIEL BARGAIN
FORMAL SEE FORMER C. O. O. OF
THE NC DOUBLE A SUPPORTS SB TWO
OH SIX SAYING THE MISTREATMENT
OF STUDENT ATHLETES AS A LONG
STANDING AND WELL KNOWN ISSUE
THAT IS ATTRACTING NATIONWIDE
ATTENTION. IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
TWO OH SIX IS SET FOR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO GIVE SCHOOLS
THE NC DOUBLE A OTHER STATES
AND CONGRESS THE TIME TO ACT SO
THAT ALL COLLEGE ATHLETES MIGHT
GAIN THE RIGHTS PROVIDED BY SB
TWO OH SIX. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS COME
LONGER DOES MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES LET ME
JUST VALIDATE SOME OF THE
REMARKS IT WAS JUST THE WERE
JUST STATED I'M CLEARLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE ALSO. A
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES THERE ARE
NO RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT A
STUDENT MAY DO WHAT THEIR
TALENTS. EXCEPT FOR ONE.
STUDENT ATHLETES. AN ORDERS
CONSEILLER PAINTINGS. AN
ENGINEER CAN DEVELOP ROBOTICS.
SCIENTISTS CAN DEVELOP A
MILLION DOLLAR APPLICATION. THE
COLLEGE ATHLETE CAN'T CANNOT
CANNOT HAVE A YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
SCHOOLS TO PAY THE ATHLETES
DIRECTLY INSTEAD THIS BILL GIVE
STUDENT ATHLETES THE SAME
RIGHTS AS OLYMPIC ATHLETES.
ALLOWS ATHLETES TO MAKE MONEY
FROM THEIR NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS. APPLE. ABOUT WHICH
WILL ACTUALLY OBTAIN LARGE
ENDORSEMENT DEALS AT GET MOSTLY
ATTENTION LIKE NIKE AND
GATORADE AND THE LIKE. MOST OF
THESE ATHLETES UNDER THIS BILL
WE USE IT TO MAKE EXTRA MONEY
TO HOST CAPS FOR. YOUTH SUMMER
PROGRAMS AND A VAST MAJORITY OF
ATHLETES ARE NOT AS WAS STATED
BY PREVIOUSLY THEY'RE NOT ON A
FULL SCHOLARSHIP. THESE
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF MAKING
INCOME WILL HELP THE ATHLETES
STAY IN SCHOOL. A PARTIAL
SCHOLARSHIP ATHLETES MAKE ENDS
MEET WITH TUITION FOOD BOOKS
HOUSING RECEPTOR AND I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU. SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE FAIRNESS THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY MISTER PATTERSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS
THAT. MAN SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU I WRI SADLY TO.
INTERJECT A NOTE OF CAUTION
HERE. AND I WANT TO SUGGEST
FIRST OF ALL THAT I AM VERY
SYMPATHETIC. OF WHAT THE
ATTEMPT HERE IS. HOWEVER THERE
IS A THERE IS A CIRCUMSTANCE
HERE THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THIS IS ABOUT. SOME
UNIVERSITIES INCLUDING FRESNO
STATE I WOULD SUGGEST SAN DIEGO
STATE SAN JOSE STATE SACRAMENTO
SAN LUIS OBISPO KALPANA EIGHT
AND OTHERS. PUT US AT A VERY
DFFICULT RECRUITING
DISADVANTAGE. AND THE REASON
THAT I ARE THESE UNIVERSITIES
ARE CONCERNED AND HAVE RAISED
THIS CONCERN WITH ME IS THAT
ALL MARKET PLACES ARE NOT.
EQUAL IN OTHER WORDS THE
ATHLETES THAT ARE LOOKING AT
FRESNO STATE PRESENTLY WILL NOT
LOOK AT FRESNO STATE IN THE
FUTURE. BECAUSE OF THE MARKET
FORCES THAT WILL BE WELL THAT
WILL PLAY OUT IN THE BIG
MARKETS AND IN IN A SAN
FRANCISCO LA OTHER PLACES I DID
NOTHING THINK ABOUT IT FOR JUST
A MINUTE. IT IS THE RECRUITING
LEVEL FIELD WE PRESENTLY HAVE
ARE UNABLE STE FRESNO STATE
QUITE FRANKLY TO BE COMPETITIVE
WE WERE COMPETITIVE WE WITH U.
S. C. NOT LONG AGO WE WERE
COMPETITIVE WITH ABOUT. WITH
THE MINNESOTA NOT LONG AGO. THE
CONCERN THAT THAT OUR ATHLETIC
DIRECTOR HANDS IS A SYMPATHY
FORCE FOR STUDENTS. A HOPE THAT
THE NC TWO WAY WILL WORK
THROUGH THIS. BUT IN THE
MEANTIME IF THERE IS NOT A
SIGNIFICANT. FAIRNESS THAT IS
ALLOCATED IN THIS THERE WILL BE
A RECRUITING UP. BLOOM WITH
SCHOOLS LIKE FRESNO STATE. I
WANT TO REITERATE WHY WOULD
THAT BE. IT WOULD BE BECAUSE
THE VALUE OF BEING IN A BIG
MARKET. IN A MEDIA MARKET. WILL
BE A DISADVANTAGE TO FRESNO
STATE IN ITS RECRUITING. THE
CASE IS MADE THAT WELL. THE
STUDENT ATHLETES WILL HELP YOU
KNOW CLOSE THE GAP ON SOME OF
THEIR EXPENSES AND THE LIKE IN
A SMALLER VERSION OF A OF A
FREE MARKET. THE FOR THE I
THINK THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT IF A STUDENT ATHLETE FOR
EXAMPLE WANTED TO BE. HIRED IN
UTILIZED FOR A SPOKESPERSON FOR
LET'S SAY A CAR DEALERSHIP.
FRESNO HAS X. NUMBER OF CAR
DEALERSHIPS THE MARKET PLACE
ABOUT USC OR UCLA OR STANFORD
OR OTHER PLACES WILL HAVE A
HUGE SMS A STATISTICAL
MEASURING AREA AND WILL HAVE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES. THAT
WILL GO TO STUDENTS EVEN FOR
WHAT WE CONSIDER TO BE THESE
THESE SORT OF LESSER THINGS
LIKE NIKE AND ARE UNDERNEATH
THE BIG GAP. CONTRACTS THAT
WOULD THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
THINK ABOUT IT I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO LAY OFF ON THIS. BUT I
THINK WE HAVE TO THINK
SERIOUSLY ABOUT THIS KIND OF
CONSEQUENCE WHERE. UNDER
PRESENT CIRCUMSTANCES THERE IS
SOME DEGREE OF FAIRNESS IN
RECRUITING. AND OUR RECRUITING
IS SUCCESSFUL IN PART BECAUSE
WE HAVE HAD REALLY FANTASTIC
STUDENTS WHO HAVE COME TO US
BECAUSE THEY CAN PLAY LIKE
DEREK CARR AND FIND THEIR WAY.
INTO BIG CONTRACTS IN THE NFL.
OUR. EIGHTY OUR BULLDOG
FOUNDATION AND OTHERS ARE VERY
VERY CONCERNED THAT IF THIS
WERE TO BE ESTABLISHED AS THE
BILL SUGGESTS AN ABSENCE OF THE
NC TO A AND IT. ENGAGING IN
THIS AND RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
IS SOME FAIRNESS WITH RESPECT
TO RECRUITING THAT I'VE JUST
MENTIONED. I AM SYMPATHETIC TO
THE STUDENTS I LAID OFF IN
THIRTY SEVEN ANDERSON AND I'VE
DONE A LOT OF HOMEWORK AND IT
HAD TO COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
PICKING SOME WINNERS AND SOME
LOSERS ACT AS A RESULT OF THE
MARKET PLACES THAT THESE FOLKS
NOW HAVE A CHOICE TO GO INTO.
TO EARN BIG BOX IN BIG MARKET
AND FRESNO AND OTHER SMALLER
MARKETS WITH WITH COMPETITIVE
FOOTBALL TEAMS IN SPORTS
PROGRAMS I THINK WE'LL BE PUT
IT ON THE NECESSARY
DISADVANTAGE SO WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO LAY OFF I HOPE THAT
THIS BILL GIVES SOME TIME FOR
THE NC TWO EIGHT TO REALLY KIND
OF COME TO ITS SENSES AND
FRANKLY HELP. MAKE IT HAPPEN
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. APPRECIATE
MEMBERS THANK YOU. MR KILEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO OH SIX. THE COUNTRY OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS PARTICIPATE IN
INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETICS TENS
OF THOUSANDS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. COLLEGE SPORTS ARE
A CENTRAL PART OF UNIVERSITY
LIFE AND NOT JUST FOR THE
ATHLETES SPORTING EVENTS
PROVIDE ENTERTAINMENT INSPIRE
PRIDE AND FROM A COMMUNITY FOR
STUDENTS ALUMNI SOMETIMES WHOLE
CITIES. THIS IS TRUE EVEN
THOUGH PROFESSIONAL LEAGUES
EXIST FOR MOST OF THE TWENTY
FOUR SPORTS OFFERED BY THE
NCAA. THERE'S A DISTINCTIVE
APPEAL TO INTERCOLLEGIATE
ATHLETICS A SPECIAL PLACE IN
THE WORLD OF SPORTS AND OUR
BROADER SOCIETY FOR HONORING
THE ATHLETIC EXCELLENCE OF
STUDENTS. THAT'S WHY NO LESS
AUTHORITY THAN THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT HAS LONG
SPOKEN OF THE REVERE TRADITION
OF AMATEURISM. IN COLLEGE
SPORTS. CONTRARY TO THE
ASSERTIONS OF CRITICS TODAY'S
BILL IT DOES NOT END THAT
REVERED TRADITION OF
AMATEURISM. IT DOESN'T
INTRODUCED SALARIES FOR STUDENT
ATHLETES IT IS NOT COMMODIFIED
ATHLETIC PERFORMANCE AS SUCH.
RATHER SB TWO OH SIX RENEWS
THIS PROUD AMERICAN TRADITION
WITH A GREATER MEASURE OF
RESPECT FOR THE STUDENT ATHLETE.
SOMETHING THAT THE NCAA HAS
REFUSED TO DO. AS NATIONAL
INTEREST IN ITS PRODUCT HAS
GROWN AND REVENUES HAVE
SKYROCKETED THE NCAA HAS BARELY
EVEN ACKNOWLEDGED THE TENSION
INHERENT IN ITS BUSINESS MODEL.
A HEAVILY COMMERCIALIZED
ENTERPRISE WHOSE PRIMARY
ATTRACTION THE STUDENT ATHLETES
ARE PERMITTED IT FORBIDDEN FROM
ANYTHING RESEMBLING COMMERCE OF
THEIR OWN. IN FACT THE NCAA HAS
MANAGED THIS TENSION IN THE
WORST POSSIBLE WAY. THE MORE
COMMERCIALIZED COLLEGE SPORTS
TO BECOME THE MORE AGGRESSIVELY
IT IS EXCLUDED STUDENT ATHLETES
FROM ANY SHARE OF THE BENEFITS
FORGET SHOE DEALS IN VIDEO
GAMES AND CA ATHLETES CAN'T
MAKE A LITTLE MONEY OVER THE
SUMMER COACHING YOUTH SPORTS
CAN'T PROMOTE THEIR SOCIAL
MEDIA CAN'T MODEL ATHLETIC WEAR
CAN'T ACCEPT GROCERIES OR HELP
WITH RENT. OR EQUIPMENT
CONSIDER ERIN EIGHT IN A TAUGHT
BASEBALL RECRUIT WHO WAS BANNED
FROM COMPETITION BECAUSE HE
USED HIS NAME AND IMAGE TO
PROMOTE AN INSPIRATIONAL BOOK
HE WROTE ABOUT SURVIVING
CANCER. OR THE YOU TALK
BASKETBALL COACH WHO IS SAYING
XIN FOR OCCASIONALLY BUYING
PIZZA FOR PLAYERS OR THE OHIO
STATE FOOTBALL PLAYERS WHO WERE
DECLARED INELIGIBLE BECAUSE
THEY COULD EXCHANGE TEAM
PARAPHERNALIA THEY OWNED. FOR A
DISCOUNT ON TASK TO TATTOOS.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE NCAA
INITIALLY FOR BAIT MARYLAND
STUDENTS FROM PROMOTING A
FUNDRAISER HONORING A FORMER
TEAMMATE WHO DIED TRAGICALLY
DURING A TEAM WORK OUT. ONE
PLAYER SAID AT THE TIME OUR
TEAM IT PASSES AWAY DURING AN
NCAA SANCTIONED WORK OUT. BUT
NOW AS AN NCAA STUDENT ATHLETE
I AM NOT ALLOWED TO PROMOTE A
FUND RAISER WE'RE HAVING FOR
HIS PARENTS FOUNDATION I CAN'T
EVEN TWEET THE FLYER. WHEN A
LINE IN THE SAND IS ENFORCED
OBSESSIVELY EXCESSIVELY AND TO
THE POINT OF ABSURDITY. THAT'S
USUALLY A SIGN THAT IT DOESN'T
BELONG THERE. AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE. THIS DRACONIAN
ENFORCEMENT AND THE OPPOSITION
TO TODAY'S BILL ARE ABOUT
PRESERVING NOT A TRADITION OF
THEM AMATEURISM BUT ECONOMIC
MONOPOLY. IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
NCAA HAS OVERSTEPPED ITS ROLE
AS GUARDIAN OF AMATEURISM TO
THE DETRIMENT OF THE AMATEUR
ATHLETES THEMSELVES. TODAY'S
BILL IS A NEEDED CORRECTIVE
PROVIDING NCAA LEADERS A CALL
TO ACTION AND RESTORING TO
STUDENT ATHLETES A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT. CONTROL OVER THEIR OWN
NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS THIS IS
A UNIQUELY PERSONAL RIGHT AN
EXTENSION OF ONE'S VERY
PERSONHOOD AN INDIVIDUAL'S
IDENTITY. IT'S FORCED TO
SURRENDER IS UNUSUAL AND I'M
JUST PLAYING COLLEGE SPORTS
SHOULD NOT HAVETO COME AT THE
COST OF PERSONAL LIBERTY
DIGNITY SELF EXPRESSION OR ANY
OTHER VALUE THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE IS CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING. SO LET'S PASS THIS
BILL TODAY. WHAT DO SO
UNANIMOUSLY WHAT SEND A LOUD
AND CLEAR MESSAGE THE NCAA AND
LET'S ALSO SEND A MESSAGE TO
OUR TALENTED HARDWORKING
AMAZING STUDENT ATHLETES TO OUR
SKIERS AND SWIMMERS RUSTLERS
AND ROWERS RUNNERS AND JUMPERS
BOWLERS AND VOLLEY BALLERS
SHOOTERS INVENTORS ARE INACTION
OFFERS. TO THOSE THE PLAY
SOCCER LACROSSE TENNIS WATER
POLO AND FIELD HOCKEY YES IT
DOES WE SEE ON TV COMPETING
INSIDE ICE RINKS ACROSS
DIAMONDS ATOP HARDWOOD IN
BETWEEN PILOTS LET'S SEND A
MESSAGE TO ALL OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES THE CALIFORNIA HAS
YOUR BACK I THINK THE SENATOR.
FROM BERKELEY FOR TAKING ON
THIS ISSUE AND I ASKED FOR AND
I THAT. THANK YOU MISTER KILEY
MISTER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES MINUTES SPEAKER I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THE S. B. TWO OH
SIX UNLIKE SOME OTHER STUDENTS
ATHLETES JUST CAN'T GAIN ANY
INCOME FROM THEIR TALENT. MUSIC
MUSIC PERFORMERS GET OUR MUSIC
PROGRAM PEOPLE CAN GET MUSIC
BAR OF MONEY FROM PERFORMING
COMPUTER SCIENCES. STUDENTS CAN
DEVELOP AN APT A FILM STUDENTS
COULD MAKE A FILM BUT ONLY
COLLEGE ATHLETES ARE BARRED I
REALIZE THAT ALLOWING STUDENT
ATHLETES TO EARN MONEY
COMPLICATES THE CURRENT BALANCE
OF POWER IN THE NC DOUBLE A-
AND IT WILL OPEN THE DOOR FOR
BOOSTERS AND WEALTHY DONORS TO
RECRUIT. OR ENTICE OR HAVE
IMPROVE IT HEAVEN FORBID PAY
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN TO COME TO
THEIR FAVORITE SCHOOLS. AND
THIS MAY GIVE SOME SCHOOLS AN
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE. NOTE THAT IT
LEE EIGHT OF THE LAST TEN NC
DOUBLE A FOOTBALL CHAMPIONSHIPS
WERE WON BY TWO TEAMS ALABAMA
AND CLEMSON. THE CURRENT FREE
FRAMEWORK IS NOT EXACTLY A
PICTURE OF PARITY. WELL WELL
NOW YOU KNOW WHAT THE NC DOUBLE
A IS A ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY THEY CAN FIGURE
IT OUT. MEMBERS SOME OF OUR
MOST TALENTED STUDENT STUDENT
MEN MEN AND MEN AND WOMEN
STUDENTS ATHLETES ARE BEING
ROBBED BY THE NC DOUBLE A- THIS
BILL IS NOT THE ENTIRE SOLUTION
BUT IT'S A GOOD BILL AND IT
SENDS A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TIRED OF SEEING
OUR YOUNG THAT. ATHLETES BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE BUT UP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD. DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MADAM
SPEAKER THE MEMBERS I TO RISE
AS THEY PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SB
TWO OH SIX. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
I SPENT FORTY YEARS OF MY LIFE
AT THE UNIVERSITY. AND DURING
THAT TIME FRAME I HAD A LOT OF
INTERACTION WITH STUDENT
ATHLETES. AND WE SOMETIMES
THINK THAT STUDENT ATHLETES
LIVE IS REALLY WONDERFUL LIFE
WITH THEY HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES
pAND TO AND TO DO THE THINGS
THAT THAT OTHER STUDENTS CAN'T
DO. AND THE REALITY IS I'VE
SEEN MORE STUDENT ATHLETES IN
POVERTY. BARELY MAKING IT NOT
ABLE TO WORK BECAUSE OF THE
HEAVY WORK SCHEDULE THE
ATHLETIC SCHEDULE THAT THE
ENGAGE IN. HAVING REAL
LIMITATIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN
DO HAVING TO WORK HARD IN THE
SUMMER EVEN PRACTICING AND
CAMPS. AND STILL NOT ABLE TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AND THEY DON'T
BENEFIT AT ALL. AT ALL FROM
THERE FROM WHO THEY ARE FROM
THE IMAGE OF THEM AND THEY HAVE
NO VERY LITTLE RESOURCES THAT
COME IN. IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT
ALL THE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED OVER THE YEARS
REGARDING STUDENT ATHLETES HAVE
BENEFITTED THE UNIVERSITIES.
WHETHER IT'S OF BEING ON
TELEVISION OR HAVING CERTAIN
KINDS OF SWAG THAT PEOPLE CAN
BY THE NAMES OF ATHLETES. THOSE
THINGS BENEFIT THE UNIVERSITY
AND THEY HAVE MADE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AND THOSE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS DO NOT ALWAYS GO BACK
INTO THOSE ATHLETES. THEY HAVE
GIVEN MUCH OF THEIR LIVES SOME
OF THEM DON'T GO PRO I'VE HAD
PROBABLY VERY FEW STUDENTS. TO
ACTUALLY WILL BECOME PRO
ATHLETES OVER THE LAST FORTY
YEARS I DON'T THINK I'VE HAD
FORTY STUDENTS WILL BECOME PRO
ATHLETES IN A FORTY YEAR
CAREER. BECAUSE THEY DON'T. BUT
THAT NONE THE LESS THEY MAKE
THE SCHOOL GREAT. THEY WORK
HARD THEY DO ALL KINDS OF
THINGS AND THEY DON'T BENEFIT
NECESSARY FROM THE MONEY THAT
COMES IN. AND IT'S A TRAGEDY
THAT THE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN USE
AND REGARDLESS OF WHAT. THINGS
THEY TALK ABOUT IN TERMS OF
RECRUITMENT AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON. OUR ATHLETES ARE OFTEN USE
THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES TO CREATE
THE ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO DO OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS THAT IS SO WE SENT TO
THAT THE UNIVERSITY BELIEVES IN
TERMS OF ITS IMAGE. SO I REALLY
AM VERY PLEASE WITH THIS I'M
GLAD THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE BERKELEY. THIS. I TO
INTRODUCE ISRAEL. IT IS A MAJOR
PIECE IF YOU BEEN READING ANY
OF THE BLOGS WITH REGARDS TO
THE PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES WHO
SPENT. TIME IT ON CAMPUSES YOU
KNOW THAT THEY ARE ALL IN
SUPPORT OF IT SB TWO OH SIX.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO THEM AS ATHLETES AND EVEN
THOUGH THEY BECAME%
PROFESSIONALS. MANY OF THEIR
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES DID NOT.
AND AS A RESULT THEY DESERVE TO
HAVE. THIS SOME JUSTICE AND
HAVE SOME PARTICIPATION IN
CONTROL OF THEIR OWN LIFE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I WILL
FOR SB TWO OH SIX. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISS COME OVER TO HAVE YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK MY- COLLEAGUES FROM
FRESNO EL DORADO SAN DIEGO. THE
NORTH COAST NOT I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT NOT SO MANY PEOPLE WERE
INTERESTED IN THIS BILL. RIGHT
I WHAT I WANT TO CLOSE THAT WAS
A JOKE THAT WASN'T TOO I
ACTUALLY WANT TO CLOSE WITH THE
STORY OF GREG ANTHONY SO GREG
ANTHONY I WAS ONE OF THE
RUNNING REBELS HE PLAYED AT U.
N. L. V. I THINK IT WAS IN THE
NINETIES HE WAS A STAR POINT
GUARD. HE ALSO ATTENDED THE
WORLD ECONOMIC SUMMIT AND LO
AND BEHOLD. HE INTERNED ON
CAPITOL HILL FOR A REPUBLICAN.
HE HAD A VISION FOR HIS FUTURE.
WHILE HE ATTENDED U. N. L. V.
HE ALSO WORKED IN TRIED TO
SUPPORT HIS FAMILY HIS MOTHER
HAD UNDER UNDERGONE SURGERY FOR
CANCER AND HIS SISTER WAS A
HEMOPHILIAC. SO HE CREATED A
TEE SHIRT BUSINESS WITH A
COUPLE OF HIS COLLEAGUES. SO
THAT HE COULD PAY HIS OWN
TUITION AND NOT BE DEPENDENT ON
THE SCHOLARSHIPS. HE DID NOT
WANT THEM. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED. LET ME TELL YOU THE
NC DOUBLE A STEPPED IN AND SAID
OH NO GREG ANTHONY NOT YOU.
THEIR RESPONSE WAS GIVE UP YOUR
BUSINESS ENTIRELY GIVE UP
SELLING THESE T. SHIRTS TO HELP
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR MOTHER AND
YOUR SISTER ARE OKAY OR YOU
MUST RECUSE YOURSELF FROM THE
GAME AND STOP PLAYING ENTIRELY.
THAT WAS THEIR RESPONSE. IT'S
LIKE A CARTEL PROPOSITION. MADE
BY THE NC DOUBLE A. WHO WELL
WHO HAS CONTINUED TO MAKE
BILLIONS WITH THE BE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON THE BACKS OF
YOUNG ATHLETES. AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO I SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO SAY BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THIS
TO BE TRUE IS THAT MANY OF
THESE YOUNG ATHLETES WHO ARE
EARNING TOP TOP DOLLAR FOR THE
NC DOUBLE A OUR YOUNG BLACK
MEN. AND WE KNOW. THAT BLACK
PEOPLE IN THE USE OF THEIR
LABOR FOR FREE HAS BEEN
INGRAINED IN THE FABRIC OF THIS
COUNTRY. THIS BILL IS TURNING
AND IDEA THAT IDEA THAT HAS
BEEN IN BED IT. AND IS PRETTY
UNSHAKEABLE. INTO A NEW IDEA
THAT SAYS THESE ATHLETES
DESERVE COMPENSATION. SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
CONDITIONAL SCHOLARSHIPS THAT
SAY I'LL GIVE YOU THE
SCHOLARSHIP IF YOU SHOW UP FOR
WORK IF YOU SHOW UP FOR
PRACTICE IF YOU PERFORM ON THE
BASKETBALL COURT OR WHATEVER
OTHER ATHLETIC COURT THERE IS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE DOING A JOB
LIKE ED O'BANNON SAID. AND I
JUST WANNA SAY IN SEE DOUBLE
WAY. DON'T THREATEN CALIFORNIA.
DON'T THREATEN US BECAUSE WE
HAVE FORMIDABLE SCHOOLS WE HAVE
FORMIDABLE ALUMNI WE HAVE
FORMIDABLE VIEWERSHIP AND WE
CAN LEVERAGE THOSE THINGS UP
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE WHEN
THIS BILL TAKES A FACT. BUT I'M
SICK OF BEING LEVERAGED BY THE
NC DOUBLE A ON THE BACKS OF
ATHLETES WHO HAVE THE RIGHT. TO
THEIR OWN LIKENESS AN IMAGE
THIS IS ABOUT FAIRNESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB TWO OH SIX THANK YOU
MISS COM LONGER DOUBT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES. WOULD
RAINY. I WAS GOING TO MENTION.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE RULES
COMMITTEE WILL MEET NOW OFF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR FLOOR SESSION
WILL CONTINUE MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE SHOULD REPORT
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. CASE YOU MISSED IT
THE RULES COMMITTEE IS CAN
MEANING NOW IN THE RULES ROOM
.
FILE ITEM TO NINETY THREE SB
TWO FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR DODD ACTUALLY
TO WILDLAND FIRE PROTECTION.
MISTER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB TWO
FORTY SEVEN PERTAINING TO
UTILITY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
FOR SENATOR DODD. EXTREME
WEATHER HAS INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES IN THE LENGTH OF THE
WILDFIRE SEASON ACCORDING TO
CAL FIRE TWELVE OR THE
CALIFORNIA FIRES. BUT WILD
FIRES WERE RECENTLY BECAUSE BY
ELECTRICAL POWER DISTRIBUTION
LINES CAL FIRE STUDY TREES ARE
PARTS OF TREES FALLING ON THE
POWER LINES AS SPECIFIC CAUSE
OF THE FIRE. EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES UTILITIES TO MAINTAIN
MINIMUM COME CLEARANCES BETWEEN
VEGETATION ELECTRIC LINES
REMOVE DEAD AND DYING TREES
THAT COULD FALL ON LINES RECENT
EVENTS HAVE SHOWN THAT UTILITY
SELF AUDITING OF THEIR OWN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT DOESN'T
WORK. RECENTLY THE JUDGE
OVERSEEING P. GENIES PROBATION
IN THE SAN BRUNO CASE SAID P.
JEANNIE HASN'T CUT THE RIGHT
TREES IN MANAGING VEGETATION IN
AND NEAR ITS POWER LINES
UTILITIES NEED OUTSIDE AUDITS
FOR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. SB
TWO FORTY SEVEN WILL REQUIRE
THE NEW WILD FIRE SAFETY
DIVISION CREATED BY AB ONE
ELEVEN TWO I DID TAKE AUDIT
EACH UTILITIES VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORK THE AUDIT WOULD
IDENTIFY YOU FAILURES TO COMPLY
WITH VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS IN ITS WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN AND UTILITY
WOULD HAVE TO CORRECT THOSE
DEFICIENCIES. IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT TREE TRIMMING IS VERY
DANGEROUS WORK SB TWO FORTY
SEVEN WERE ALSO REQUIRE A
MINIMUM WORKFORCE
WORK FORCE PERFORMING THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK.
THAT THE BILL HAS WREAKED
RECEIVE YOU NEARLY UNANIMOUS
VOTES AT EVERY STAGE IN THE
SUPPORT OF MY COUNTIES LABOR
FIVE FIRST RESPONDERS AND
OTHERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
WOULD SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY EIGHT NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
NINETY FOUR SB TWO FIFTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTY FIVE BY CENTER
RADFORD ACCOLADE TO ENERGY IS
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
SECURE VETERANS SPEAKER SB TWO
FIFTY FIVE UPDATES ARE THIRTY
YEAR OLD UTILITY SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY PROGRAM. TO REFLECT
TODAY'S ELECTRIC GRID. WHAT ARE
PROGRAM STARTED NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX UTILITIES SPENT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND A YEAR WITH
DIVERSE BUSINESSES LAST YEAR
DIVERSE SPENDING AND
SUBCONTRACTING EXCUSE HE
SUCCEEDED FOURTEEN BILLION. BUT
OUR ELECTRIC GRID HAS ALSO
EVOLVED OVER THE PAST THREE
DECADES NEW PLAYERS ON THE
GREAT ARE TAKING A BIGGER
RESPONSIBILITIES. IT'S TIME TO
ENSURE THAT DIVERSITY IS ONE OF
THEM THIS BILL HAS NO MEANING
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WITH
EGGMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MAP. IN
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS ERICA. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY FIVE NEWS
HERE IS MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TO NINETY EIGHT SB
TWO SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
EIGHT BY CENTER WE'RE ACTUALLY
TWO ELECTIONS. MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND AN MEMBERS CURRENT
LAW WHEN IT COMES TO PUTTING A
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT A BOND OR
A TAX HAS REQUIRES THAT WE PUT
A GREAT DEAL OF INFORMATION IN
THE SEVENTY FIVE WORDS
STATEMENTS. THE RECENT LAW THAT
THAT HAD BEEN PASSED THAT IS
PUSHING TRYING TO PUSH TOWARDS
WAR TRANSPARENCY WAS WAS A GOOD
TRY BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
REQUIREMENT TO PUT SO MUCH
INFORMATION IN THAT SEVENTY
FIVE WORDS STATEMENT. IT
BECOMES IMPOSSIBLE TO DO IT
WITHOUT REALLY MISLEADING
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT THAT
STATEMENT IS. WHAT SENATOR
WAITERS BILL SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY EIGHT DOES IS CLEAN THIS
UP BY ENSURING THAT IN THAT
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD STATEMENT WE
ARE POINTING TO EXACTLY WHERE
A- PROPERTY OWNER TAXPAYER CAN
FIND THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
NEED. CALCULATE WHAT THE IMPACT
IS ON THEM. BY NOT PUTTING A
OVERLY SIMPLIFIED STATEMENT
WITHIN THE SEVENTY FIVE WORDS
THAT THEN BECOMES MISLEADING.
SIMPLE TAXES LIKE A. SIMPLE
SALES TAX INCREASE PRETTY EASY
TO UNDERSTAND PARCEL TAX WHERE
YOU MAY HAVE EXEMPTIONS TAXES
THAT ARE TIERED WHICH ARE
FAVORED WHERE YOU MIGHT HAVE
SOME COMPLICATED WAY OF TRYING
TO EXPLAIN IT. FOR EXEMPTING
SENIORS OR EXEMPTING DISABLED
IS EXEMPTING OTHERS FROM THE
TAX CAN'T BE CAPTURED IN THAT
ONE SIMPLE STATEMENT THIS BILL
IT CLEANS UP THAT EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES FOR TRANSPARENCY AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER SINISTER OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
ALWAYS IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT I HAVE A
LONG HISTORY WITH THIS AREA OF
THE STATE CODE. FOUR YEARS AGO
I AUTHORED AB EIGHT OH NINE
WHICH CREATES THE REQUIREMENT
THAT TAX INCREASES THAT VOTERS
VOTE ON MUST INCLUDE ON THE
BALLOT LABEL RIGHT WHERE YOU
VOTE. THE FACT THAT IT'S A TAX
INCREASE AND THE RATE AND
DURATION OF THE TAX. TWO YEARS
AGO I AUTHORED AB ONE NINETY
FIVE WHICH CLARIFIES THAT THAT
REQUIREMENT EXTENDS TO BONDS IF
THEY INCREASE PROPERTY TAXES TO
REPAIR THOSE BONDS. THOSE BILLS
PASSED WITH BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THIS CHAMBER VOTED FOR THEM.
FOR EXAMPLE QUESTIONS HAVE
ARISEN ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IF A
BOND DOESN'T HAVE A FIXED
DURATION WHATEVER HAPPENS OF A
INTEREST RATE. HOW SHOULD THAT
BE HANDLED RIGHT NOW THEY JUST
USE ESTIMATES. I HAVE TRIED
COLLEAGUES OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS. TWO DIFFERENT BILLS TO
TRYING CLEAN THIS UP BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL REFUSED TO NEGOTIATE
BECAUSE WHAT THEY REALLY WANT.
IS TO HIDE FROM VOTERS THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE VOTING ON A TAX
INCREASE AND IN FACT THE BILL
IN FRONT OF YOU WOULD REMOVE
COMPLETELY OF THE REQUIREMENT.
THAT THE TO DO THAT THE TAX
INCREASE BIZ MENTIONED ON THE
BALLOT STATEMENT AND INSTEAD
JUST INSERT THE WORDS. SEE
VOTER GUIDE FOR INFORMATION AND
WE ALL KNOW THAT MOST VOTERS
NEVER OPEN THE VOTER GUIDE SO
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY HIDING FOR
VOTERS THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
VOTING ON A TAX INCREASE. I AND
IF YOU WANT PROOF OF THE BAD
FAITH THAT THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL HAVE SHOWN JUST LOOK AT
THE- TRANSCRIPTS OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT THIS
BILL WAS HEARD IN. A WE OFFERED
A COMPROMISE. THAT SAID OKAY
WE'LL JUST SAY THIS. THIS
MEASURE INCREASES PROPERTY
TAXES AND SEE VOTER GUIDE. AND
THEY REJECTED IT BECAUSE WHAT
THEY REALLY WANT TO DO IS HIDE
THE FACT IT'S A TAX INCREASE
BUT LOOK DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR
IT. EDITORIAL BOARDS OF ALL
POLITICAL STRIPES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE HAVE WEIGHED IN ON
THIS MEASURE. I DON'T LIKE TO
SHARE THOSE WORDS WITH YOU OR
WITH YOUR PERMISSION TO READ
MISTER SPEAKER. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SO HERE'S THE LA
TIMES EDITORIAL BOARD IF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE WORRIED THAT
THEY CAN'T SELL VOTERS ON
COMPLICATED NEW TAX SCHEMES AND
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS OR LESS.
THAN THEY NEED TO WORK ON THEIR
COMMUNICATION SKILLS. HERE'S
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
POLITICIANS GIVE VOTERS A
DOUBLE DOSE OF SNEAKING THIS.
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER GIVEN
THEIR DRUTHERS MANY GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WOULD PREFER TO DO
THEIR BUSINESS OUR BUSINESS
ACTUALLY BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
AND PROVIDE SANITIZED SO
SERVING VERSIONS OF THEIR
ACTIONS AFTER THE FACT. NEWS
GROUP EDITORIAL BOARD THIS BILL
IS A CYNICAL PLOY INTENDED TO
INCREASE THE CHANCES OF PASSAGE
BY KEEPING VOTERS IN THE DARK.
CAL MATTERS A NEW LAW THAT
PURPORTS TO GIVE VOTERS VITAL
INFORMATION ABOUT TAX AND BOND
MEASURES BUT INSURERS THAT THE
DATA WILL BE BURIED IN OFFICIAL
PAPERWORK IN THAT FAILURE TO
PROVIDE IT. WILL BE PENALIZED.
I AM FINE THE SAN JOSE MERCURY
NEWS A NEEDS TO FAIL BAY TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARDS. THE DECEIT OF
THE BOND LOBBY AND ITS ALLIES
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
IS DESPICABLE. I COLLEAGUES ONE
MORE POINT THAT I LIKE TO MAKE
ABOUT THIS IS THAT THIS IS
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY I LOOKED
OVER THE LAST TWO YEAR ELECTION
CYCLE AT ALL OF THE BOND
MEASURE STATEWIDE. THERE WERE
ON BALLOTS THAT COMPLIED WITH
THE EXISTING LANGUAGE. YOU WITH
THE PASSAGE RATE WAS OVER
EIGHTY TWO PERCENT. SO IT IS
CLEAR TO ME THAT VOTERS ARE NOT
CONFUSED SO I WOULD URGE A NO
VOTE OR IF YOU CAN'T GET THERE
RIGHT NOW MEMBERS. I REQUEST
THAT YOU JUST MERELY LAY OFF ON
THIS AND IF THIS BILL DOES NOT
PASSED TODAY. HI WILL CERTAINLY
REINTRODUCE LEGISLATION IN
JANUARY. TO TRY AND CLARIFY
SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS AND
HOPEFULLY THIS TIME THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WERE WORK
WITH ME INSTEAD OF WORKING
AROUND. A DECREASING VOTER
TRANSPARENCY BUT I WILL
CERTAINLY NOT VOTE. TO KEEP
VOTERS IN THE DARK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE VOTING ON A
TAX INCREASE AND NEITHER SHOULD
YOU I ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER STONE YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. UNFORTUNATELY
BY JUST PUTTING A BLANK
STATEMENT ON WITHIN THAT
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO INCREASE YOUR TAXES.
IS IN FACT MISLEADING. A RENTER
ISN'T NECESSARILY GOING TO BE
PAYING THE PROPERTY TAX AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS EXEMPTED IN A
TIERED SYSTEM. IS NOT
NECESSARILY GOING TO BE PAYING
THE PROPERTY TAX IF WE PUT THAT
STATEMENT THERE. THAT IS I
THINK INTENDED TO BE MISLEADING
TO SCARE PEOPLE IN VOTING NO.
ON A MEASURE THAT WOULD.
ACTUALLY BE TO THEIR BENEFIT
THAT THEY MAY NOT BE PAYING.
THIS IS NOT THAT SIMPLE TO DO
TO START TO SING TO ME. TO
THINK THAT THERE'S A CRITICISM
OF LAYING OUT. IN THE VOTER
GUIDE. EXACTLY HOW A- PROPERTY
OWNER OR A TAXPAYER CAN
CALCULATE FOR THEMSELVES WHAT
THEIR TAX MAY OR MAY NOT BE. IS
MISLEADING WHAT'S MISLEADING IS
TRYING TO FORCE JURISDICTIONS
IN PUTTING. AN OVERLY
SIMPLIFIED STATEMENT IN THAT
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS THAT IS
GOING TO LEAD A VOTER TO THE
WRONG CONCLUSION. BECAUSE IT
CANNOT BE ADEQUATELY EXPLAINED.
AND EACH VOTERS ARE GOING TO BE
IN A POTENTIALLY DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCE WITHOUT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE. THE SYSTEM IS A CALL. YES
WICKS IS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM TO FORTY
SEVEN SB SIX HUNDRED THE CLERK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE FIRES FORTY ONE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY FIVE NEWS
ONES MEASURE PASSES. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THERE
IS A RULES COMMITTEE RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK RELATIVE TO
SUSPENDING THE JOINT RULES. I
ASK THAT WE GO TO THAT ITEM
NOW. CLERK WILL READ THE RULES
COMMITTEE RESOLUTION THE JOINT
RULE SIXTY ONE A FOURTEEN BE
SUSPENDED TO PERFECT
CONSIDERATION OF AMENDMENTS TO
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY TWO AND
THE JOINT WILL SIXTY ONE AB
SUSPENDED TO PERMIT SENATE BILL
ONE TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
FURTHER ACTION. MR FLORA. WE'RE
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. OKAY
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE TO SUSPEND RULE SIXTY ONE.
IT TAKES FIFTY FOUR VOTES IT IS
NOT DEBATABLE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESERTED VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR HIS ASKING
FOR NO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE AS FAR
AS FIFTY FOUR MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. THIS REQUIRES FIFTY
FOUR MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER FLOOR IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THOSE GUYS FIFTY SIX KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED
.
MR STONE IS PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM TO NINETY
EIGHT SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A
. MR
STONE PLACE CALL THIS CALL.
FILE ITEM TO NINETY NINE SB TWO
SIXTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY NINE BY
CENTER BRADFORD OTHERS
INOCULATED REMOVED FROM THE
PROCEDURE DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS ARE RISE AND BEHALF OF
SENATOR BRADFORD TO PRESENT TO
YOU SB TWO SIX NINE THIS BILL
WOULD EXTEND THE DEADLINE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED. TO SEEK COMPENSATION
FROM TWO YEARS TO TEN YEARS
UNDER CURRENT LAW AN INDIVIDUAL
MUST PETITION THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS COMPENSATION WHAT
WITHIN TWO YEARS OF THEIR
RELEASE TO RECEIVE COMPENSATION
THIS CLAIM PROCESS TAKES YEARS
TO COMPLETE EVEN AFTER THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
FOUND INNOCENT BY THE COURTS.
NOTHING CAN MAKE UP FOR THE
TIME AND FREEDOM THESE
INDIVIDUALS OF LOS BUT THIS
BILL TAKES A STEP FOR PROVIDING
JUSTICE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED THIS BILL
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE HAS
ENJOYED OF BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IT HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YEAH I
BILL. SB. TWO SIX NINE. THANK
DOCTOR WEBER SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRED VOTE. WHERE WILL
FLOWS THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
AYES SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THREE ELEVEN SB FOUR SIXTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR STERN ACKLEY NATURAL
GAS STORAGE WELLS. MISS SMITH
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THE MASS OF GAS
LEAK FROM A STORAGE WEALTHY
ELITE SO CANYON GAS STORAGE
FACILITY THREE YEARS AGO HAD A
PROFOUND AND DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON MY DISTRICT AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES. LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AN AIR QUALITY
REGULATORS RECEIVED THOUSANDS
OF COMPLAINTS REGARDING THE
SMELL FROM THE ODORANTS THE
OILY MIST EJECTED
INTERMITTENTLY FROM THE WELL
AND NUMEROUS ELEMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LEAK
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES RELOCATED
AND TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS WERE
CLOSED FOR THE DURATION OF THE
LEAK AFTER THE LEAK WAS STOPPED
AND PEOPLE RETURN TO THEIR
HOMES HEALTH COMPLAINTS
CONTINUED. RESEARCHERS FOUND
NUMEROUS CHEMICALS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE LEAGUE AND THE
OPERATIONS TO STOP THE LEAK IN
HOMES NEIGHBORING THE STORAGE
FACILITY SB FOUR SIX THREE SIX
TO IMPROVE THE ASSESSMENT OF
THE RISKS TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
FROM GAS STORAGE WELL LEAKS IN
THE FUTURE BY REQUIRING A MORE
THOROUGH DISCLOSURE OF THE
CHEMICALS PRESENT AND USED A
GAS STORAGE FACILITIES. WE WANT
TO BE SURE THAT REGULATORS AND
THE PUBLIC KNOW WHAT MATERIALS
ARE BEING INJECTED INTO A WELL
AND WHAT MATERIALS OCCUR
NATURALLY IN THE RESERVOIR AND
MAY COME OUT WHEN THERE IS A
LEAK THIS BILL ALSO NOW
RESPONSE TO THE INDEPENDENT
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS OF THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN LAKE THAT WAS
RECENTLY RELEASED DOGGER IS
REQUIRED TO REVIEW ITS NEW
REGULATIONS TO SEE IF THEY ARE
ADEQUATE GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
NOW. IF NOT DOCTORS TO UPDATE
THEM IT IS THE LEAST WE CAN DO
FOR THE COMMUNITY. NUMBERS OF
THE A LOT OF CANNING FACILITY
WILL NEVER KNOW EVERYTHING THEY
WERE EXPOSED TO DURING THE LEAK
THE PRESSURES REQUIRED BY SB
FOUR SIXTY THREE PREPARE US TO
EVALUATE AND UNDERSTAND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS FROM FUTURE
LAKES AND ENSURE THAT
REGULATORS AND THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION NAME TO ASSESS
HEALTH RISKS AND RESPOND. THIS
HAS BEEN A DID SEVERAL TIMES
THE DRESS OPPOSITION CONCERNS
AND AVOID DUPLICATE OF EFFORTS
THERE IS NOW NO NO OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL SB FOUR SIX THREE
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN.
SUPPORT BOTH HOUSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALENTED ICE FIFTY THREE KNOWS
TWELVE THIS MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK
UP TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. MR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO. ARE
YOU MISTER GLORIA THE CLERK
WILL READ BEFORE YOU OPEN
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY TWO THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA. NOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MISTER WHERE I APOLOGIZE A
MODEL OF GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY TWO FOR
THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT I DID
THEM ITS CRACKED CHAPPED ANY
ISSUES WITH OTHER BILLS MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU MISTER WHERE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL. BE SPENT ON
THESE MOMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY NO. THE
AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO BRING HIM BACK
TO FILE. WE ARE MOVING A FILE
ITEM THREE FIFTEEN SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR BY
CENTER PORTANTINO AN ACCOLADE
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
MYSTERY OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY AND
PRESENTING SENATE BILL FORTY
FOUR ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHICH WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY SIMPLIFY THE
TRANSFER PROCESS FROM
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE AND
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE EARNED AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER SB FORTY
FOUR WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO IDENTIFY EDT STUDENTS AWARD
THEM WITH THEIR DEGREE AND ADAM
TWENTY A DEDICATION SYSTEM THAT
IS ELECTRONICALLY AVAILABLE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA YES STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND THE UC'S
DESPITE THE SIMPLE FINE EFFORTS
OF THE LEGISLATURE THE TRANSFER
PROCESS SEES FROM THE
TO THE CSU WHEN YOU SEE REMAIN
COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT FOR
STUDENTS THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS WEB EARNED
IN AT T. RECEIVE THEIR DEGREE
AND ARE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF ITS BENEFITS. SB FORTY FOUR
HAS BI PARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS RIVAS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
THE. WHERE WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZEROS MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THREE THIRTY FIVE
SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN BY CENTER RUBIO
ACCOLADE HOMELESSNESS. MYSTERY
OF US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AGAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR RUBIO I
PRESENT SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
WHICH WILL ADD A HIGHER
EDUCATION REPRESENTATIVE TO THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL AS
HOMELESSNESS GROWS AMONG HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENTS IT'S
IMPORTANT THEY MAY THAT THEY BE
PART OF A CONVERSATION. SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS RIVAS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESERTED THE- ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THE- ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS THERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. LUNA FILE
ITEM TO NINETY SIX SB TWO SIXTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY FIVE BY
CENTER HERTZBERG AN UGLY PEOPLE
MULES AND CLEARLY YOUR SENIOR
OF TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE WILL ENSURE THAT SCHOOL
OFFICIALS DO NOT ENFORCE
POLICIES THAT THAT THE NIGHT
FOOD OR PUNISH STUDENTS BY ANY.
FOR ANY REASON TWO YEARS AGO WE
PASSED A MEASURE WHICH SOUGHT
TO BAN THIS PRACTICE OF SCHOOL
LUNCH SHAMING HOWEVER
UNFORTUNATELY MANY DISTRICTS
ARE STILL. DOING THIS HOWEVER A
DIFFERENT FORM OFFERING
ALTERNATIVE MEALS CREATING
POLICIES WHICH FRANKLY THEN I
STUDENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO EAT
WHILE IN SCHOOL AND FRANKLY
BRING ABOUT A LOT OF OTHER
NEGATIVE ISSUES DEALING WITH
THEIR- SELF ESTEEM RELATED TO
THEIR PARENTS POVERTY. THIS IS
A MEASURE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK ME
BUT I THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX
NO THEIR THIS MEASURE PASSES. I
SIXTY SIX IS THERE ON THE
URGENCY AS WELL
. MR STONE IS
FOR HER TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM TO NINETY EIGHT SB
TWO SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE A. PRICE FORTY
ONE. THERE. CLAIRE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE.
LEADING CAUSE OF FAST ENOUGH.
WE'RE BACK TO FORTY. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY TWO NEWS TWENTY
ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
A VOTE AT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEMS THREE THIRTY EIGHT
THREE THREE FIFTY. I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR PLUS. THIS DOES
ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AWARENESS MONTH BURKE
WILL OPEN THEIR ON THE- COUNTER
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO. BURKE
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO I SEVENTY
NO ZERO HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY
FIVE SEVENTY NEWS AND CURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR FIVE
SEVEN IS THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY SEVEN I MEAN
AS- IMMIGRANT RESOLUTION SIXTY
THREE I SEVENTY KNOWS. CURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY FIVE SEVENTY
NO ZERO THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY TWO HI SEVENTY KNOWS
THE CURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
THREE I SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SO BEFORE
I SEVENTY KNOWS RESOLUTION
SEVENTY FIVE I SEVEN NOTES HERE
AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SIX I
SEVENTY KNOWS ZERO. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
SEPTEMBER TENTH. FLOOR SESSION
AT TEN AM UNTIL SIX PM.
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH
FLOOR SESSION AT TEN AM TILL
SIX PM I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
CLOSING TIME I DOUBT MISTER
CALDERON WILL FOLLOW THAT.
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER TWELFTH
FLOOR SESSION FROM TEN AM TO
SIX PM AND FRIDAY SEPTEMBER
THIRTEENTH FLOOR SESSION
CONTAINING AM TO SIX PM. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION. THE FORM
CALL IS LIFTED WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. MEMBERS WE LIVE TO THE
QUORUM CALL PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY MR
KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ON AUGUST TWENTY
FIRST THE CITY OF ROOSEVELT
LOST ONE OF ITS FINEST CITIZENS.
JIM GRAY WAS A FORMER MAYOR AND
INCOMPARABLE COMMUNITY LEADER
AND A FRIEND AND MENTOR TO SO
MANY OF US IN ROSEVILLE AND
BEYOND. BORN IN NINETEEN FORTY
ONE JIM GRADUATED FROM THE
VALUE IN HIGH SCHOOL AND THEN
ATTENDED SIERRA COLLEGE
SACRAMENTO STATE AND GOLDEN
STATE UNIVERSITY WHERE HE
RECEIVED A MASTER'S IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION. JIM'S LOVE FOR
THE CITY OF ROSEVILLE WAS
EVIDENT TO ALL WHO KNEW HIM.
HIS DEDICATED SERVICE SPANNED
DECADES INCLUDING TWELVE YEARS
ON THE PLANNING COMMISSION SIX
YEARS ON THE PARKS AND
RECREATION COMMISSION THREE
YEARS ON THE GRANT ADVISORY
COMMISSION AND FOR YEARS ON THE
ROSEVILLE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORP. HE ALSO SERVED NINE YEARS
ON THE CITY COUNCIL INCLUDING
TWO AS THE MAYOR OF ROSEDALE.
UPON BECOMING MAYOR IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HE SAID WE HAVE
GREAT THINGS AHEAD OF US AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING
HARD TO SUSTAIN THE AMAZING
QUALITY OF LIFE. ROSE BILL IS
KNOWN FOR. BEYOND HIS WORK FOR
THE CITY JIM WAS A LEADER IN
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS OF ALL
KINDS ROSE BILLS ROTARY CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE MUSIC IN THE PARK
AND FIREFIGHTERS CHARITY GOLF
TOURNAMENT. PLASTERS COUNTY
FAIR IN AS PCA. HE COACHED
YOUTH SPORTS AND CO FOUNDED THE
SIERRA COLLEGE WOLVERINE
ATHLETIC ASSOCIATION SERVING
TEN YEARS IT'S PRESIDENT. HE
RECEIVED THE SIERRA COLLEGE
ALUMNI LEGACY AWARD IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. AND WAS CHOSEN
FOR THE X. SIERRA COLLEGE
ATHLETIC HALL OF FAME IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN. ROSE BILL HAS
BEEN RATED THE BEST PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA TO RAISE A FAMILY.
AND THIS IS THAT THIS IS THANKS
IN NO SMALL PART. TO THE LIFE'S
WORK OF JIM GRAY. JIM IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JUDY A
FIFTY TWO YEARS HIS DAUGHTER
KRISTIN AND HER HUSBAND SCOTT.
HIS BROTHER BILL THE BILL'S
WIFE CAROL. HIS BROTHER
MICHAEL. HIS NEPHEW JASON AND
JASON'S WIFE DENISE AND ON
THEIR DAUGHTERS KENDALL AND
CATHERINE. MADAM SPEAKER I ASK
THE TODAY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF JIM WRIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MAN SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
WITH A HEAVY HEART TALK ABOUT A
FRIEND OF MINE. A FRIEND OF
MINE WHO MOST OF OUR DISTRICT
NEW. DEAN MUCH ABOUT HOW SHE-
HE LED THE LITTLE TOKYO SERVICE
CENTER. BUT I THINK WHAT WE
WHAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE ABOUT HIM
IS THAT THERE WAS NO TWO SMALL.
OR NO OBSTACLE TO BIG WHEN IT
CAME TO HELPING PEOPLE. DEAN
WAS THE KIND OF GUY THAT ALWAYS
HAD A SMILE ON HIS FACE WAS
ALWAYS PACKED THE BOWL OF
PRACTICAL ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND
ALWAYS DRAW FOR TRYING TO HELP
FOLKS. WHETHER IT WAS SENIOR
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
DEFENSE OF LITTLE TOKYO IT'S
RESIDENTS WHETHER PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS. HE WAS ALWAYS THERE
TO HELP FOLKS. HEY. LAST WEEK
ON SEPTEMBER FOURTH DEAN PASSED.
HE PASSED AFTER FIFTEEN MONTH
BATTLE WITH THE TUMOR. HE LEFT
BEHIND A BEAUTIFUL WIFE. AND
LET BEHIND CHILDREN. BUT EVEN
WHEN HE FOUND OUT THAT HE HAD A
TUMOR I REMEMBER HE MADE HIS
ROUND OF CALLS ANY HOLDOVERS
SAID LOOK I'VE GOT A TUMOR I
DON'T THINK IT'S LOOKING GOOD
BUT I PLAN TO WORK AS HARD AS I
CAN TO GET TERM PROJECTS DONE.
AND I PLAN TO SERVE MY
COMMUNITY MY NEIGHBORHOOD I
PLAN TO BE THE VERY BEST FATHER
THAT I POSSIBLY CAN UNTIL THE
VERY END. AND I PLAN TO BE THE
VERY BEST HUSBAND THAT I CAN.
UNTIL THE END. AND. EVEN THOUGH
HE'S PASSED WE KNOW WE KNOW
THAT HIS PRESENCE WAS MADE FELT
I WITHIN OUR SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE FIFTY
THIRD ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ACROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I'VE I'VE
NEVER KNOWN A PERSON. TO BE SO
HAPPY TO BE SO STRONG TO BE SO
DEDICATED AND HAVE SUCH AN
ENORMOUS HEART FOR THE WORK
THAT HE'S DONE. FROM THE BUDDHA
CON RECREATIONAL CENTER THAT IS
THAT WE'RE STILL WORKING ON OUR
DISTRICT WHICH HE STARTED. THE
DEFENSE THAT EVERY SINGLE
SENIOR IN OUR COMMUNITY. IT
DIDN'T MATTER WHERE YOU WERE
FROM WHAT YOU BELIEVED IN OR
WHO YOU MARRY. DEAN WAS ALWAYS
THERE AND WILL NEVER FORGET HIM.
GOD BLESS HIS SOUL. WE KNOW
THAT IT'S THE THAT HIS LEGACY
WILL STILL LIVE AMONGST US. IN
THE GOOD LORD PROTECT HIS
FAMILY HIS CHILDREN AND ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT HE'S DONE. WHAT
THE HEAVY HEART OTHER **** THIS
ASSEMBLY TO JOIN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO MR
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE SAID GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO
JOIN MY- COLLEAGUE WHO
REPRESENTS LITTLE TOKYO. IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES. TO ASK
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF OUR GOOD FRIEND
DEMOTES BY AYE SHE- DEAN WAS
TAKEN MUCH TOO YOUNG. AT THE
AGE OF FORTY NINE. LEAVING A
DAUGHTER OF TEN YEARS OLD AND A
SON OF FIVE YEARS OLD. DEAN
DEDICATED HIS LIFE. TO BUILDING
COMMUNITIES AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LITTLE TOO OKAY
SERVICE CENTER. HE WAS A SON OF
A PROMINENT BUDDHIST PRIEST.
AND THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. ANY HAD A REPUTATION
AS A KID. OF BEING A LITTLE BIT
OF A TROUBLE MAKER BACK IN AS
YOU. BUT LIKE SO MANY JAPANESE
AMERICAN YOUTH HE DEVOTED HIS.
YOUNG DAYS TO HIS FIRST LOVE OF
BASKETBALL. AND EVEN THOUGH I
THINK DEAN WAS PROBABLY NOT
MUCH TALLER THAN FIVE FEET BY
FEET MORE TO BE GENEROUS. HE
PLAYED FOR THREE YEARS ON THE
VARSITY SQUAD OF VENICE HIGH
SCHOOL. AND HE WENT ON TO
PURSUE HIS LOVE OF COMMUNITY BY
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILDING CASA HEY WERE THE
MULTICULTURAL COMMUNITY CENTER
IN LITTLE TOKYO. AND HE WAS A
LEADER. AND SO MANY IN CIRCLES
AND THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY.
BUT IT WAS HIS LOVE FOR HIS
FIRST LOVE A BASKETBALL THAT
EVENTUALLY CAME BACK TO AND
WORKING ON THIS DREAM THAT MANY
PEOPLE IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA JAPANESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HAVE THAT FOR DECADES
A DREAM TO BUILD A COMMUNITY
GYMNASIUM IN LITTLE TOKYO SO
THAT WE CAN BRING THE KIDS
BACK. TO LITTLE TOKYO. FOR IT
IS. SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW. WHAT
A BIG DEAL JAPANESE AMERICAN
YOUTH BASKETBALL AS- DEAN KNEW
THAT THERE WAS NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT TO. BUILD AND TO
BRING BACK THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY THEN TO
BUILD THE LITTLE TOKYO BOTTLE
CON COMMUNITY NAY CM. THANKS TO
DEAN'S LEADERSHIP AND SO MANY
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
HAVE WORKED FOR DECADES ON THIS
PROJECT. THE GROUND BREAKING.
FOR THE TERRACE SAKE BORDER
CON. COMMUNITIES IN THE
GYMNASIUM AT LOW TELL KILL A
SCHEDULE FOR THIS DECEMBER. YOU
KNOW I FIRST LEARNED ABOUT.
DEAN'S PASSING. WHEN I GOT IN
ANGUISH CALL FROM AND YOU WAY
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. YOU
KNOW DEAN HAS TOUCHED THE LIVES
OF SO MANY PEOPLE HE WAS ONE OF
AND SHE'S BEST FRIENDS. AND SHE
TALKED ABOUT HOW. IT WAS HER
DREAM THAT DEAN WOULD BE ABLE
TO HOLD ON UNTIL THE GROUND
BREAKING THE BORDER KANA
DECEMBER. HE WAS TAKEN MUCH TOO
YOUNG. JUST WANT TO THANK DEAN.
FOR ALL THE GREAT WORK THAT IS
DONE FOR THE COMMUNITY. AND FOR
MAKING THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
I'M JOINED BY. MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING. AND ASKING THAT
THIS ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES THE DESI PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
IN THE JOURNAL OF OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
ENTERTAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS. I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR LACKEY MOVES IN MR SALAS
SECOND THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY
SEPTEMBER TENTH AT TEN AM
. YEAH.
ALRIGHT BUT CHANGE SOMEONE OR
SALAS FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
THREE A. B. THIRTY SEVEN I
DON'T KNOW. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY SEVEN ODD TO KNOW.
THE CHANGES AND ONE MEMBER
SALAS FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
ONE FORTY TWO I DON'T KNOW.
SALAS SENATE BILL ONE FORTY TWO
TO KNOW. AS A MEMBER LACKEY
VOTE CHANGED ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY EIGHT I LIKE TO
KNOW. BEAU CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY EIGHT TO KNOW. LOW
CHANGES EMILY MEMBER MEDINA SB
ONE NINETY NINE NOTE TO AYE.
BEAU CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA SENATE BILL ONE NINETY
NINE NO TIME. GRAYSON AB FIVE
TWENTY I DON'T KNOW IF I'M NOT
VOTING. BOOK CHANGE SHOULD SOME
IMMIGRATION AT SOME AGO FIVE
TWENTY I TO NOT VOTING. GRAYSON
AB ONE SEVENTY FIVE I TO NOT
VOTING. GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVENTY FIVE I DO NOT
VOTING GRAYSON ACR NINETY NINE
I DO NOT VOTING. GRAYSON SIMPLY
GROW RESOLUTION NINETY NINE I
DO NOT VOTING. QUIRK ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FIVE NINE ZERO I TO
NOT VOTING. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
BILL FIFTEEN NINETY I TO NOT
VOTING. AGUIAR-CURRY AB TWELVE
TWELVE NOTE TO YES. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWELVE NO
TO OUR. ASSEMBLYMEMBER TASHA
WERE NO MORE MATH BILL AB EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE FROM I TO NOT
VOTING. BEAU CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER **** BATH
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SEVENTY
NINE I TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH BILL EIGHT AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FROM I TO KNOW.
SOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN ****
BATH SO WE WILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY
I TO KNOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY AYE TO NOT
VOTING. BOOK CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN EIGHTY AYE
TO NOT WORRY. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
SB TWO TWO FIVE HI TO NOT
VOTING. PETRIE-NORRIS SENATE
BILL TWO TWENTY FIVE I TO NOT
VOTING. THIS THING OUT. GIPSON
AB OF THREE FORTY TWO FROM ICE
NOT VOTING. GIPSON APRIL. PHONE
CHANGED SOME RIVER GIPSON
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY TWO I
TO NOT VOTING. AB TWELVE THIRTY
TWO FROM I TO NOT VOTING.
GIPSON ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
THIRTY TWO I TO NOT VOTING